LUCK.
NIELSEN [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER.
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS TANG YOUR MAYES.
MCCARTY.
OBERNOLTE WEBER HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE RECOGNIZE
THE PRESENCE OF A QUORUM AND
HAPPY.
A GOOD SUNDAY EVENING TO ONE AND
ALL TONIGHT'S PLAN IS TO CLOSE
DOWN ON ALL OF THE OPEN ITEMS
STAFF IS PREPARED ACTION LISTA
CORRESPOND TO THE SECTIONS OF
THE CONFERENCE AGENDA.
THE AGENDA ISSUE AND PAGE NUMBER
ARE INCLUDED FOR ITEMS ON THE
ACTION LISTS THAT ARE ON THE
AGENDA THEY'RE ALSO VERY IT'S
NOT IN CONFERENCE ITEMS ON THE
ACTION LIST WHICH DO NOT HAVE
PAGE OR ISSUE NUMBERS.
THEY'RE NOT NOTED AS NICK NICK
ITEM BUT IF YOU DON'T SEE A PAGE
NUMBER IN ISSUE NUMBER YOU'LL
KNOW THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE.
I THINK IT'S SAFE TO ASSUME
COLLEAGUES THAT THE LEGISLATURE
IS ON TRACK TO VOTE ON THE
BUDGET FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY FISCAL YEAR.
SOMETIME LATER THIS WEEK
CERTAINLY PRIOR TO OUR JUNE
FIFTEENTH CONSTITUTIONAL
DEADLINE.
THE BUDGET AGREEMENT THAT WE'RE
FINALIZING TONIGHT BILLS ON THE
STRONG BUDGET PROPOSAL OF THE
GOVERNOR WHILE ADDING
SIGNIFICANT LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES.
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
EXPANDING ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE
INCREASE DE THE S. RATES
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS TO COMBAT
POVERTY.
AND EXPANDING ACCESS TO
EDUCATION HIGHER EDUCATION EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION.
IN ADDITION THE BUDGET AGREEMENT
MAINTAINS OUR COMMITMENT TO
RESPONSIBLE BUDGETING WHICH
INCLUDES THE LARGEST RESERVES IN
HISTORY OVER TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS FINALLY PAYING OFF THE
REMAINING WALL OF DEATH FROM THE
GREAT RECESSION.
AND MAKING SUPPLEMENTAL PENSION
PAYMENTS.
BEFORE I BEGIN AS ALWAYS IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE ALL PAUSE AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THE HARD WORK THAT
GOES INTO ESTABLISHING A SPEND
THE PAYMENT PLAN. FOR THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
EVERY YEAR I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE LEGISLATURE
ARE CONFEREES THE STAFF
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE LA JOH.
LET'S BE CLEAR COLLEAGUES THAT
WE HAVE STAFF IN THIS BUILDING
WHO PRETTY MUCH WORKED AROUND
THE CLOCK JUST THESE LAST
SEVENTY TWO HOURS -- IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WE TIP OUR HAT AND IT
KNOWLEDGE THE HARD WORK THE
COUNTLESS HOURS THEY PUT IN --
TO THIS DOCUMENT ON BEHALF OF
ALL THE RESIDENTS OF THE GREAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND FOR THAT
TO ALL OF YOU WE THANK YOU.
I WITH THAT MR TING ANY REMARKS
BEFORE WE BEGIN.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY DAVE LET ME
JUST FIRST THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
FOR A CHERRY THIS CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE IN GETTING US.
TO ALMOST TOWARD THE FINISH LINE
I ALSO WANT TO THANK ALL THE
SENATORS PARTICIPATED BUT ALSO
IN PARTICULAR ARE ASSEMBLY.
AND CONFEREES DOCTOR WEBER
MISTER BELONG TO MR MAYES AYE MR.
MCCARTY REALLY APPRECIATE
EVERYONE WORKING TOGETHER AND
THEY CAN.
ALSO JUST TO ECHO THE THANKS FOR
THE STAFF -- YOU KNOW OUR STAFF
YOUR STAFF DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
ALLEN -- WHO REALLY HAVE WORKED --
REALLY ROUND THE CLOCK OVER THE
LAST -- THE LAST NUMBER OF HOURS
TO REALLY GET THIS -- BUDGET
HOME.
JUST TO SORT OF ECHO YOU SIR
THIS IS A GREAT BUDGET FOR OUR
STATE WE HAVE THE HIGHEST.
SPENDING LEVELS. FOR K. THROUGH
TWELVE EDUCATION REALLY
REINVESTS AND ENSURING THAT MORE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS.
TOWARDS TO SERVE HIGHER
EDUCATION WITHERS UCC AS YOU ARE
THE COMMUNICATORS.
IT ALSO REALLY INSURANCE TO
PROTECT OUR ENVIRONMENT AND%
REALLY.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
INVESTMENTS ARE MADE AND LASTLY
WE A LOT LAST WEEK WE HAVE MADE.
CHARACTERS GREAT STRIDES AND CAN
REALLY MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE --
TAKEN.
TAKEN OF APPROACH REALLY TRYING
TO RE ENVISION OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND MAKING SURE
THAT REALLY PEOPLE HAVE.
REAL PATHWAYS.
NOT JUST IN A REALLY OUT SO
AGAIN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN VERY
MUCH SUPPORTED TONIGHT.
APPRECIATE YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU I MEAN I THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT WITH KNOWLEDGE JUST
OPERATIONALLY WHAT IT TAKES TO
PUT THESE DOCUMENTS TOGETHER YOU
KNOW AS WE THINK.
ABOUT THE PROCESS FOR WILL BE
CLOSED DOWN TONIGHT TO WE GET TO
A POINT WHERE THERE IS ACTUALLY
BILL LANGUAGE IN PRINT IN ALL OF
THE HANDS OF HAVE TO TOUCH IT
FROM.
LEDGE COUNCIL EVERYONE SO IT
IT'S AN OMINOUS PROCESS TO PUT.
TO ACTUALLY PHYSICALLY PUT A
BUDGET TOGETHER -- AND WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF EVERYONE
WHO IS RESPONSIBLE WE ARE GOING
TO START.
GOOD EVENING MISTER THIS WILL
NOT THIS ONE I FOUND THIS ONE I
FOUND.
I GOT TO THE VERY END TO MESS IT
UP -- WE'RE GOING TO START JUST
IN TERMS OF OUR PROCESS -- I
MENTIONED IN MY INTRO THAT WE'VE
GOT -- THESE ACTION LISTS.
AND SO WE'LL GO THROUGH EACH
ISSUE NUMBER.
AGAIN THEY CORRESPOND WITH THE
FULL AGENDA -- IS MY UNDERSTAND
THAT STANDING THAT YOU WILL DâN
TECHNOLOGY ACTION THAT WAS
AGREED UPON AND THEN I WILL JUST-MANAGE -- THE VOTES FROM THE DAY
S. FAIR ENOUGH.
JUST SO YOU KNOW I'VE ALREADY
HEARD FROM -- STAFF FOR MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES AT THEIR
SOME VOTE TO THAT WHEN A
SEPARATE AND SO MEMBERS IF YOU
JUST LET ME KNOW THAT AFTER THE
MOTION IS RATE THEN WE'LL FIGURE
OUT HOW WE MANAGE THE VOTING
PROCESS FAIR ENOUGH.
EVERYONE.
OKAY GREAT LET'S START WITH SOME
ISSUE ONE UNDER CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION CHILD
CARE ACCESS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ON THIS
ISSUE THE WE'VE REACHED A
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE -- WHICH
IS APPROVING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S AT PROPOSAL FOR
EIGHTY POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AND I'M GOING
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR FUNDING
FOR ALTERNATIVE PAYMENTS WHAT'S
IN THE BUDGET YAR -- AND THEN
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR ON GOING
GENERAL CHILDCARE SLOTS WE
ANTICIPATE AND EXPECT THAT IN
FUTURE YEARS THOSE WILL BE
FUNDED BY GROWTH IN PROPOSITION
SIXTY FOUR FUNDING.
THANK YOU ALL ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ACCEPT THE COMPROMISE.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
WHAT THE ASSEMBLY VOTE OF THREE
TO TWO IN THE SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TO TWO THE COMPROMISE
KERRY'S.
ISSUE TO STAY PRESCHOOL SLOTS
INELIGIBILITY.
ON THIS ISSUE WE'VE ALSO
RESTRICT CONFERENCE COMPROMISE --
WE WOULD BE -- PRIORITIZING
WORKING FAMILIES FOR THESE --
STATE PRESCHOOL SLOTS AND IN
ADDITION AND ATTENDANCE AREAS
WHERE 80% OR MORE OF STUDENTS
QUALIFY FOR FREE OR REDUCED
PRICE MEALS WE'D -- ALLOW ALL
FAMILIES IN THE AREA TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE SLOTS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL IT IN A MOTION TO MOVE SO
MOVE WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
FIVE TWO ZERO SENATE VOTE OF
FOUR TWO ONE THE COMPROMISE
KERRY'S ISSUE THREE CHILDCARE
AND PRESCHOOL RIGHT.
THIS IS A CAR NOT ALSO
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE ON THE
APPLICATION OF A RATE ADJUSTMENT
FOR PART TASTE STATE PRESCHOOL
RATES -- THIS IS APPROVING THAT
APPLICATION FOR CHILDREN WITH
EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS.
THANK YOU WANTED EMOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO AND A SENATE VOTE OF THREE
TO TWO THE COMPROMISE KERRY'S.
ISSUE FOR CHILDCARE DAILY
EDUCATION ONE TIME FACILITIES
INVESTMENT.
THIS -- CONFERENCE COMPROMISE
REFLECTS PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE WHICH DOES THE
FOLLOWING THINGS IT TRANSFERS
EIGHTY NINE DOLLARS AND NON
PROFIT NINETY EIGHT FUNDING FROM
THE CHILD CARE FACILITIES
REVOLVING LOAN FUND -- FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THIS PROGRAM
TRANSFERS TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDING FROM
THE CHILD CARE FACILITIES
REVOLVING LOAN FUND FOR THE
INCREASE OF EARLY EDUCATION
EXPANSION PROGRAM -- 5% OF THE
GRANT FUNDING CAN BE USED BY CD
TO CONTRACT FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND UP 25% CAN BE
USED FOR RENOVATION REPAIR
MODERNIZATION ARE RETROFITTING.
FOR HEALTH SAFETY OR OTHERWISE
INJURE NEEDS AND INCLUDES A
COUPLE OF OTHER TECHNICAL
CHANGES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LIMITED
EMOTION
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED ON
ASSEMBLY BOTH OF FIVE TWO ZERO A
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO THE
COMPROMISE KERRY'S ISSUE
[inaudible] FOR CHILDCARE AND
EARLY EDUCATION ONE TIME
FACILITIES INVESTMENT.
IS CONFERENCE COMPROMISE THAT
PROVES ONE HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND -- FOR CHILD CARE EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT GRANT.
IN ADDITION THE CONFERENCE
COPPER COMPROMISED ADOPTS A
PLACE HOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO EXPAND TRAININGS IN
SUPPORT ACTIVITIES FOR A BROAD
RANGE OF PROVIDERS.
INSURE THAT STIPENDS IN
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
PROVIDED ALIGNED WITH THE
QUALITY COUNTS CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM
AND ALSO OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES.
WELL WHY SAID ONE TIME
DISABILITIES THAT WE DID THAT
ALREADY JUST TO CORRECT THE
RECORD I SHOULD HAVE SAID ISSUE.
FIVE YES WHICH IS CHILD CARE
REALLY EDUCATION ONE TIME
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT.
THANK YOU ALL ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
WITH THE BOTH OF FIVE ZERO FROM
THE ASSEMBLY.
AND THREE TWO ZERO ON THE SENATE
SIDE.
THE COMPROMISE SCARY.
MOVING ON TO ISSUE SIXTH CHILD
INVESTMENTS.
THIS IS ALSO A CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE -- IN WHICH APPROVAL
OF TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS FOR DATA
COLLECTION AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
CHILD CARE ORGANIZING -- TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO BEGIN A
STATEWIDE DATA SYSTEM FOR EARLY
EDUCATION. TWO POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR THE NEXT
THREE YEARS FOR THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD POLICY COUNCIL THAT
WOULD BE ESTABLISHING THAT
COUNCIL.
AND THEN FINALLY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONGOING GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT FOR CITIES EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE DIVISION.
INTO MOTION.
BUT IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
WITH A VOTE ON THE SIMPLIFIED A
FIVE TWO ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TO TWO THE COMPROMISE
KERRY'S.
ISSUE SEVEN CAL WORKS STAGE ONE
CHILD CARE INVESTMENT.
ON THIS ISSUE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE OF APPROVING CAL WORK
STAGE ONE CALLED MONTELLA
TECHNOLOGY -- AS WELL AS GENERAL
FUND IN THE BUDGET YEAR -- AND I
BELIEVE THE CHAIR MAY HAVE THE
MOST UPDATED NUMBERS I DO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH LIKE TO MAKE A
CORRECTION TO THE ACTION ITEMS
LISTS -- THE WE'RE GONNA PROVE
CAL WORKS STAGE ONE TWELVE WITH
ELIGIBILITY WITH FIFTY SIX POINT
FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY AND SEVENTY
POINT FIVE MILLION ON GOING.
OUR TO THE MOTION.
THANK YOU WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE
OF FIVE TO ZERO IN THE SENATE
VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO THE
COMPROMISE HERE.
OTHER CHILD CARE INVESTMENTS
ISSUE.
EIGHT ON THIS ISSUE THE
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE REFLECTS
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL
FUND ANNUALLY FOR THE EMERGENCY
CHILD CARE BRIDGE PROGRAM --
THIS PROGRAM -- I KNOW IS THAT
WHEN WE WERE INITIALLY
CONFERENCE WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
SUNSETS FOR MANY OF THESE ISSUES --
GIVEN CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
LEGISLATURE WE'VE MOVED FROM A
SUNSET APPROACH TO SUSPENSIONS
WHERE THE FUNDING COULD CONTINUE
WITH CERTAIN FUND -- CERTAIN
CONDITIONS ARE MET -- BUT FOR
RIGHT NOW THIS PROGRAM WOULD BE
SUSPENDED ON DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN ADDITION TO
THAT -- THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED ADOPTS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE DELAYING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
REQUIREMENT FOR ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE
FOURTEEN DAY NOTICE TO CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS UNTIL JULY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY EXCELLENT.
ALL ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO MOVE
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED --
WHAT THE ASSEMBLY VOTE OF? FIVE
TWO ZERO ESSENDON PHOTOS.
FIVE TWO ZERO THE COPPER MINE
[inaudible]
ARIES.
THE NEXT ITEM EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE MASTER PLAN IT'S A NICK
ITEM. TO ON THIS SITE AND ALSO
CONFERENCE COMPROMISED SO
APPROVAL OF FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE
SECRETARY OF HHS IN CONCURRENCE
WITH THE EXACT DIRECTOR OF THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION.
AND THE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TO CONTRACT FOR
RESEARCH ON SPECIFIED AREAS OF
THE CHILD CARE AND EARLY
EDUCATION SYSTEM AND THIS
RESEARCH SHOULD BE COMPLETED NO
LATER THAN OCTOBER FIRST OF NEXT
YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY THANK YOU.
A LITTLE TO THE MOTION.
THANK YOU WITH THE ASSEMBLY VOTE
OF FIVE TO ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF
A THREE TO ONE THE COMPROMISE
KERRY'S ISSUE NINE KINDERGARTEN
AND PRESCHOOL FACILITIES.
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE HERE IS TO
APPROVE THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
FACILITIES.
IT SETS THE STATE'S SHARE THOSE
FACILITY GRANTS AT 75% AND
FINALLY -- RECEIVING GRANT
FUNDING WOULD NOT IMPACT
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE SCHOOL
FACILITY PROGRAM.
IN A TO THE MOTION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY VOTE OUT FIVE
TWO ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE
ZERO THE COMPROMISED HERE
[inaudible]
ISSUE.
TEN PROP.
NINETY EIGHT FINANCE. TO ALL
PROPOSITION -- NINETY EIGHT THIS
COMPROMISE APPROVED THE
GOVERNOR'S VERSION OF PROP
NINETY EIGHT SPENDING AND
FUNDING AS WELL AS THAT PROPOSED
DEPOSIT INTO THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM STABILIZATION ACCOUNT.
HELLO TO THE MOTION.
THANK YOU FOR MOVES WITH THE
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
AND THE SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO FOR MY SCARY.
ISSUE -- ELEVEN CLEAR TECH AND
TWO CATION.
THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISE HERE
PROVIDES THE FOLLOWING ITEMS FOR
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR ACNE COLLEGE
BAKERSFIELD ONE AND A HALF
MILLION FOR COLLEGE OF THE
CANYONS ONE MILLION FOR FRESNO
CITY COLLEGE. ONE AND A HALF
MILLION ONE TIME FOR IRVINE CITY
COLLEGE ONE MILLION ONE TIME TO
MENDOCINO CITY COLLEGE SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND ONE TIME
FOR NORCO COMMUNITY COLLEGE FOR
CITY PROGRAMS.
AND THEN FINALLY WERE ADOPTING
THE SENATE RECOMMENDATION FOR
THE K. FOURTEEN STRONG WORK
FORCE PROGRAM [inaudible]
OF MESSAGING.
PICKING OUT YOUR WE WE MADE SOME
MINOR CHANGES WITH THE AGREEMENT
ARE FOUND FINANCES.
IT'S BEEN ON SLIGHT
MODIFICATIONS SO.
THE A NUMBER TWO ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION FOR THE COLLEGE --
CANYONS AND FOR THE ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION FOR THE IRVINE CITY
COLLEGE WERE REMOVED -- WE'RE
REPLACING IT WITH ONE MILLION
FOR MODESTO -- CITY COLLEGE ONE
MILLION FOR SAN BERNARDINO CITY
COLLEGE AND ONE MILLION.
FOR VALLEY CITY COLLEGE AND AND
WE DID -- TO GET AGREEMENT WITH
THAT DEPARTMENT.
APOLOGIZE FOR LAST MINUTE CHANGE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- THIRTY
ONE OCT.
COULD YOU REPEAT THAT PLEASE THE
DRIPPING -- YES.
SO FIRST OF ALL YOU WERE
ELIMINATING OFF -- NUMBERS TO
INFORM YOU IN FOR THAT COLLEGE
OF THE CANYONS AND DO.
IRVINE CITY COLLEGE AND
REPLACING WITH MODESTO.
SAN BERNARDINO AND IMPERIAL
VALLEY AND THERE THOSE ARE ALL
AT A MILLION DOLLARS EACH YES.
THEN WHY MADAM SURELY TARGETING
AS OPPOSED TO NO BETTER NO WORSE
IN GIVING EVERY.
SCHOOL IN AND YOU CAN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE A THIS IS A GREAT
QUESTION THIS IS -- THIS IS AN
ACTION THAT WE TOOK. TWO YEARS
AGO -- TO DO PILOTS WITH THESE
DIFFERENT INSTITUTIONS THE
PILOTS PROVED -- TO BE FAIRLY
SUCCESSFUL THESE WERE HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT AREAS -- SO PLACES
WHERE WE REALLY WANTED TO HELP
SUPPORT THE COMMUNICABLE DOESN'T
AS AREAS AND AGAIN THE CRITICS
HASSLE SO WE WANT TO CONTINUE
SOME FUNDING WITH THE SAME
SCHOOLS.
THANK YOU KNOW YOU'RE VERY
WELCOME.
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR THE
MODIFIED AUG CONFERENCE
AGREEMENT.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TO
ZERO IN THE SENATE VOTE OF THREE
TO TWO THE MODIFIED COMPROMISE
KERRY'S.
MOVING ON TO ISSUE TWELVE CAL
STARS CALPERS FOR LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES.
THERE'S A CONFERENCE COMPROMISE
HERE AS WELL I BELIEVE WE WILL
COVER THIS IN MORE DETAIL AND
STATE ADMINISTRATION GENERAL
GOVERNMENT CHAPTER.
SO WILL THE SKIP IT BECAUSE THIS
WILL CONFORM TO THE STATE
ADMINISTRATION ACTION THAT WILL
TAKE LATER.
THANK YOU ISSUE THIRTEEN LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
A PROPOSED ACTION HERE IS TO
APPROVE THE GOVERNOR'S AT
PROPOSAL FOR THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA VALENTINA MOTION.
SECOND.
ASSEMBLY ROLL CALL OF FIVE TWO
ZERO SENATE ROLL CALL OF FIVE
TWO ZERO THE COMPROMISE SCARY
SEISHI FOURTEEN SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
ON THIS ISSUE WE RESTRICT
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE OF
PROVIDING OF THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION ADDED FUNDING ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY TWO POINT SIX
MILLION TO BRING ALL ELEAZAR THE
STATEWIDE BASE RATE.
AND PROVIDING FOUR HUNDRED
NINETY THREE POINT TWO MILLION
TO PROVIDE GRANTS TO ALWAYS THAT
SERVE THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLDS
WITH INDIVIDUALIZED EDUCATION
PLANS -- THERE ALSO BE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE FOR ON GOING
FUNDING TO BE CONTINGENT UPON
THE PASSAGE OF LEGISLATION IN
THE UPCOMING.
BUDGET YEAR BUDGET I'M SORRY BUT
YOUR PLUS ONE BUDGET TO REFORM
THE SPECIAL EDUCATION SYSTEM TO
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS.
THANK YOU ALL IN A TO MISS
OBERNOLTE OF THE QUESTION THANK
YOU MANAGER AT A QUESTION ABOUT
THE ALLOCATION OF THE FORMER
NINETY THREE MILLION DOLLARS --
THE GOVERNOR'S ORIGINAL PROPOSAL
HAD A AN ALLOCATION FORMULA THAT
WOULD DEPENDED ON WOULD WHETHER
DISTRICTS EXCEEDED THE STATEWIDE
AVERAGE OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES.
OTHER BOTH THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY HAVE PROPOSALS THAT
WERE BASED SIMPLY ON ACCOUNTS OF
FOUR YEAR OLD AND I'M WONDERING
WHICH ALLOCATION FORMULA THAT --
THAT MONEY IS GOING TO BE
ALLOCATED ON JUST COMES
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE'RE
BASING IT ON THE COUNT OF THREE
AND FOUR YEAR OLDS NOT ON AND
DISTRICTS THAT ARC EXCEED THE
STATEWIDE AVERAGE AREN'T THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SEE NOT HIM I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION.
WITH ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TO
ZERO THE COMPROMISE KERRY'S.
OF LAW ORDER AND LAW ORDER.
WITH A FOURTEEN FIFTEEN ISSUE
FIFTEEN PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
FOR TEACHERS AND ADMINISTRATORS.
ON THIS ISSUE THE PROPOSALS IS
TO DOT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
WHEN IT COMES TO THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY CAT TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
LEADERSHIP ACADEMY.
IN ADDITION A CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED -- APPROVING THIRTY
EIGHT POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE EDUCATOR WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT GRANT THAT WOULD BE
BROKEN THAT WOULD INCLUDE WITHIN
A TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
ENGLISH HORN A ROAD MAP RELATED
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. FIVE
MILLION FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
RELATED PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
AND THE REMAINDER FOR OTHER
AREAS AND THAT WOULD INCLUDE IN
THOSE OTHER AREAS ETHNIC STUDIES.
IN ADDITION THIS CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE APPROVED SIX POINT
SEVEN MILLION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
SUBJECT MATTER PROJECTS ONE
POINT THREE MILLIONFOR EACH OF
THE CORE SUBJECTS WITH THE
REMAINDER SPLIT AMONG OTHER
PROJECTS THANK YOU MEMBERS.
A MOTION MOVED SECOND.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE
TWO ZERO AND THE SENATE VOTE OF
FIVE TO ZERO THE COMPROMISE
KERRY'S.
ISSUE SIXTEEN ON GOING K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION
INVESTMENTS MR THIS ONE OFTEN
THIS ONE UP ON A CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE HERE AT REFLECTING A
REFLECTING THE INTERESTED IN.
INCREASING SUPPORT FOR AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS -- IT APPROVES
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
THIS IS WITHIN PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT IN FUNDING FOR THE
AFTER SCHOOL EDUCATION AND SIXTY
KNOWN AS THE ASUS PROGRAM
SOMETIMES IT IS.
THANK YOU WE'VE GOT A MOTION
SECOND.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VODA FIVE ZERO
SEVEN VODA.
OF FOUR TWO ZERO THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE KERRY'S ISSUE.
SEVEN AB OTHERWISE.
JUST LIKE THAT THAT'S FINE SO
WHAT AND IN MISTER BILL FOR YOU
YOU'VE SAME.
TO MISTER WILSON ARE YOU A NO OR
EXTENSION.
STAYING EUROPE STAYING THANK YOU
SO IT'S THREE TWO ZERO
OFTENTIMES AND WE'RE GOING TO
SKIP ISSUE SEVENTEEN AND COME
BACK TO IT LATER FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGES BEING
REVIEWED ISSUE EIGHTEEN OTHER K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION
INVESTMENTS.
THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISE HERE
TWO NOTES ONE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BROADBAND PROPOSAL -- THE
COVERAGE COMPROMISED APPROVE
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION O THAT
THIS IS ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR THE BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANT PROGRAMS IN ADDITION IN
THIS ITEM -- THE COMPROMISE
REFLECTS APPROVAL OF ONE AND A
HALF -- ONE POINT FIVE FOR
HOMELESS COORDINATOR POSITIONS
AT DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
TWO HUNDRED SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS AN ONGOING FEDERAL STATE
OPERATIONS FUNDS.
THANK YOU A MOTION [inaudible]
ASSEMBLY VOTE. FIVE TWO ZERO
SENATE VOTES FIVE ZERO THE
COMPROMISE KERRY'S ISSUE
NINETEEN FIFTEEN TWELVE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE. TO THE COMPROMISE
REFLECTS THE ADOPTION A PLACE
HOLDER TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ON
CHARTER SCHOOL ENROLLMENT
TRAILER BILL AND THE TEACHER MRS
SEISMIC MONITORING TRAILER BILL.
IN ADDITION WE WOULD ADOPT THE
ASSEMBLY VERSION ON THE POST
RETIREMENT EXEMPTION LIMITATION
TRAILER BILL AND THE WAIVER TO
TEACHER TO ADMIN RATIO TRAILER
BILL.
THANK YOU.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
MISS OBERNOLTE THE QUESTION THAT
I ASKED THAT WE US PUT THE VOTE
ON THOSE FOUR ISSUES POINTS
ABSOLUTELY SIR SO WE'LL TAKE THE
FIRST VOTE ON ADOPTION OF
TRAILER BILL.
PLEASE HOLD A TRUE BILL LANGUAGE
ON CHARTER SCHOOL ENROLLMENT.
THE ASSEMBLY VOTE OF THREE TO
TWO AND A SENATE VOTE OF THREE
TO TWO COMPROMISE KERRY'S.
WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
TEACHER MISS ASSIGNMENT
MONITORING.
PLACEHOLDER TBL AND ASSEMBLY
VOTE OF THREE TO TWO AND A
SENATE VOTE OF ONE THREE TWO TWO
POST RETIREMENT EXEMPTION
LIMITATION.
GONNA DIE OUT ASSEMBLY VERSION
OF THE TBL IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE
TWO ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF FOUR
TO ONE A MOTION TO WAIVE TEACHER
TO ADD BEEN RATIO.
ASSEMBLY VERSION OF TBL.
A MOTION WAS IN SECOND THANK YOU
AND ASSEMBLY VOTE UP. FOUR TO
ONE A SENATE VOTE OF THREE TO
TWO MOVING ON TO ISSUE TWENTY
UNDER CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA. TO THE
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE HERE IS AS
FOLLOWS FIRST THEY WOULD CAP THE
STUDENT SUCCESS ALLOCATION OF
THE FORMULA 210% OF THE TOTAL
<c.cyan>ORMULA ALLOCATION.</c>
SECOND CLARIFY THAT FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR ANY TRANSFER DATA
IS BASED ON PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
INFORMATION.
THIRD STARTING IN THE BUDGET
YEAR TRANSFER DATA WOULD BE
BASED ON RECENTLY ENROLLED
STUDENTS ARE SPECIFIED.
AND NUMBER FOUR IT WAS
IMPLEMENTED THREE YEAR ROLLING
AVERAGE FOR THE STUDENT SUCCESS
METRICS AND FINALLY IT WOULD
IMPLEMENT AND ON DEPLETED COUNT
FOR THE HIGHEST AWARD OBTAINED.
THANK YOU FOR MOVED AND SECONDED.
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE ZERO A
SENATE VOTE OF THREE TWO ZERO
COMPROMISE KERRY'S.
ISSUE TWENTY ONE ONLINE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THE PROPOSED
ACTION HERE IS TO APPROVE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF THREE TO
TWO COMPROMISED AREAS OR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
IS ACCEPTED ISSUE TWENTY TWO
VETERANS RESOURCE CENTERS.
THE PROPOSED ACTION INCLUDES
APPROVAL OF THE FOLLOWING ITEMS
NUMBER ONE A CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE FOR FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING IN AN INCREASE
TO THESE VETERANS RESOURCE
CENTERS.
THE ASSEMBLY VERSION PROPOSAL OF
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND ONE
TIME FOR THE NORCO VETERANS
RESOURCE CENTER.
THIRD CONFERENCE COMPROMISED TWO
POINT FOUR MILLION ONE TIME TO
SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE BASIC
NEEDS VETERANS RESOURCE CENTER
AND FINALLY NUMBER FOUR
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE FOR ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION. FOR THE MIR
ACOSTA COLLEGE VETERANS RESOURCE
CENTER.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION MR
OBERNOLTE.
OUR MANAGER WERE WONDERING IF
THE SAN MARINO VETERANS RESOURCE
CENTER WAS LEFT OUT BY MISTAKE
ALL OF THE WAS THE ONLY ONE THAT
WAS EXCLUDED -- THIS IS CHRIS
FOR TO SMOKE FINANCE -- I WOULD
TO FOR TAR LEGISLATIVE
COLLEAGUES -- WHO WE WERE
WORKING WITH ON THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE -- FOR THE DIFFERENT
AUGMENTATIONS THE YOU DO SEE
HERE THESE WERE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISES.
SO WHILE WE INVESTIGATE THAT WHY
DON'T WE SKIP ISSUE TWENTY TWO
LET STAFF -- FIGURE OUT.
IF.
YOU SAY FAMILY NOW [inaudible]
NO WAS.
A RON ISLEY DROP WE'LL SEE AND
WE'LL COME BACK WITH HOOK ONTO
ISSUE.
TWENTY THREE THEY'LL FIGURE IT
OUT.
SO ON ISSUE NUMBER -- TWENTY
THREE THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISED
ACT PROPOSED ACTION REFLECTS
APPROVAL OF THREE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME THIS
WOULD ADDRESS HUNGER AND BASIC
NEEDS.
AND NUMBER -- TWO THE SENATE
PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS STUDENT
HOMELESSNESS AND FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR ASSESSMENT
OF COLLEGE BASED FOOD PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU LETTER TO THE MOTION.
THANK YOU WITH ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
FIVE TWO ZERO AM ET US SENATE
VOTE OF THREE TO ONE I GOT.
TO THE HEAD ONE EXTENSION AHEAD
ONE NOW.
SO.
THREE TO ONE FROM THE SENATE
SIDE.
ISSUE TWENTY FOUR FACULTY.
THE PROPOSED ACTION HERE IS TO
APPROVE THE GOVERNOR'S ACTION IN
THE NAY REVISION.
ON THE MOTION.
OF THE ASSEMBLY BOTH OF FIVE TWO
ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO ZERO THE GOVERNOR'S ACTION
IS.
ACCEPTED IF YOU TWENTY FIVE
VARIOUS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ADJUSTMENTS.
THE PROPOSED ACTION HERE --
INCLUDE SOME -- SENATE VERSION
AND SOME ASSEMBLY VERSION ON THE
SENATE SIDE IT INCLUDES THE
SENATE'S PROPOSAL ON H. B. C.
USE TRANSFER PATHWAY PROGRAM.
THE CCC TEACHER CREDENTIALING
PARTNERSHIP PILOT PROGRAM AND
THE FUND FOR STUDENT SUCCESS.
ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE THE
PROPOSED COMPROMISE -- REFLECTS
THE ASSEMBLY PROPOSALS ON THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO EXEMPT
THE SAN FRANCISCO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS FORT MASON
CENTER FROM THE FIELD ACT.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE BUT I
ASKED WE WERE SPLIT THE VOTE --
BETWEEN THE SENATE ITEMS IN THE
ASSEMBLY I DON'T PLEASE.
HAPPY TO OUR CAN I HAVE A MOTION
ON THE SENATE ITEMS ITEM.
ONE EXCELLENT WITH ACE ASSEMBLY
VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO IN A
SENATE VOTE OF FOUR TWO ZERO CAN
I HAVE A MOTION ON ITEM TO THE
ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY VERSION.
ALL WITH ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FOUR
TO ONE AND A SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TO ONE COMPROMISE KERRY'S.
MOVING ON TO ISSUE TWENTY SIX
ORAL HISTORIES.
ON THIS ITEM TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET ACT TO PROVIDE A TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
ON DOWN GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
A STATE GOVERNMENT ORAL HISTORY
PROGRAM.
THIS PROPOSED CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED WOULD REDIRECT
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
ONE TIME OF THAT TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AND USE
IT TO SUPPORT THIS ORAL HISTORY
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU LIMITED EMOTION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU. FOR THE ASSEMBLY VODA.
FORTY ONE AND THE SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TO UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN
THE UC RETIREMENT PROGRAM.
THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISE HERE
IS TO RE DIRECT THESE FUNDS FOR
OTHER UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
PROPOSES THANK YOU.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED --
WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF THREE TO
THIRDS VOTE OF THREE TO TWO
COMPROMISED KERRY'S ISSUE TWENTY
EIGHT SEISMIC RETROFIT.
THE PROPOSED ACTION HERE IS TO
APPROVE THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REFER.
THANK YOU ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TO
ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO WE PROVE THE GOVERNOR'S --
LANGUAGE ISSUE TWENTY NINE VERY
IF YOU SEE ADJUSTMENTS SO ON
THESE ITEMS -- WILL GO THROUGH
THEM QUICKLY FIRST IS ON THE
UCSF DYSLEXIA CENTER THAT
PROPOSED ACTION WOULD APPROVE
THE GOVERNOR'S -- NAY REVISION
PROPOSAL AND REPORTING LANGUAGE
A SECOND A CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED TO AUTHORIZE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A MEDICAL SCHOOL
PROJECT THAT YOU SEE AT UC
RIVERSIDE AS WELL AS MERCED
CAMPUSES.
AND THIS PROPOSED ACTION
INCLUDES BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
SPECIFYING LEGISLATIVE INTENT TO
SUPPORT THE DEBT SERVICE
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE PROJECTS.
NUMBER THREE ALSO CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED PROVIDE SIX MILLION
DOLLARS THIS IS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR THE UC CASF CSU NEAR
A DIVERSITY COOPERATION.
NUMBER FOUR APPROVING THE SENATE
ACTION ON THE UC BERKELEY LABOR
CENTER AND NUMBER FIVE AT
PRESENT APPROVING THE ASSEMBLY
ACTION ON THE UC PROGRAMS REPORT.
THANK YOU A CERTAIN NIELSEN
[inaudible]
NUMBER.
FOUR SO WE CAN TAKE ONE MOTION
ITEMS ONE TWO THREE AND FIVE SIR.
SENATOR MORE LOCK.
I'M SURE IN THE FIRST RUN WE HAD
A ASSEMBLY RECOMMENDATION OF
NINETY FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND. FOR OPERATIONS
THAT DOES NOT SEEM TO BE HERE MY
THAT YOU ARE NOT SIR IT'S NOT IN
THE BUDGET.
SO THEY'RE LOOKING AT INCREASING
ENROLLMENT AND WE'RE NOT GONNA
HELP THEM OUT.
THERE ARE. THREE SOME AGAIN --
WE DO -- SHIFT FORTY NINE POINT
NINE MILLION THE WAS PROPOSED
FOR TO CREATE AND A STUDENT
SUCCESS TO FUND OF ROUGHLY FORTY
EIGHT HUNDRED NEW UNDERGRADUATE --
ENROLLMENT -- AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA AND MISS FERGUSON
IS AT UNDER THE ITEMS FOR CSU.
COMING UP AHEAD.
I BELIEVE THAT THE CONFERENCE
ITEM -- THAT YOU WILL SEE IS
ISSUE THIRTY THREE WHICH SPENT
THIRTY SIX ON ENROLLMENT AND
COVERED BOTH UC AND CSU.
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU MISTER
BERG -- THREE AS WELL.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SEE NOT ONLY ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ACCEPT.
THE COMPROMISE AGREEMENT ON
ITEMS ONE TWO THREE AND FIVE
THANK YOU WHAT THE ASSEMBLY VOTE
UP FIVE TWO ZERO A SENATE VOTE
OF FIVE TO ZERO ALL EXCEPT A
MOTION ON ITEM FOR WITH REGARD
TO UC BERKELEY LABOR CENTER. TO
MOVE.
SECOND IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
THREE TO TWO AND A SENATE VOTE
OF I'M SORRY.
FORTY ONE ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FOUR
TO ONE A SENATE VOTE OF THREE TO
TWO COMPROMISE CARE.
ISSUE THIRTY NEW CAMPUS STUDY.
SECU ITEMS ON THIS PROPOSED
ACTION FIRST -- WOULD BE
APPROVING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL -- FOR TWO MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME FOR A STUDY OF
THAT POTENTIAL NEW CSU CAMPUS IN
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY LIKELY IN THE
CITY OF STOCKTON.
AND NUMBER TO A CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED REFLECTING AN
ADDITIONAL TWO MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME FUNDING AND THIS
WOULD CONDUCT CAMPUS STUDIES FOR
CSU FOR TWO OF ESTA SAN MATTEO
CONCORD AND PALM DESERT REGIONS.
THANK YOU ONLY TEN EMOTION SO
MOVED.
EXCELLENT BUT MOVEMENT SET WITH
AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF THREE TO
TWO COMPROMISE KERRY'S.
ISSUE THIRTY ONE VARIOUS SEE A
FEW ADJUSTMENTS.
SO ON THESE ITEMS THREE NOTES
FIRST EVER THAT PROPOSED ACTION
REFLECTS APPROVAL OF THE
GOVERNOR'S VERSION ON FOR STAR
FONG FOSTER YOUTH COVERT.
SECOND REFLECTS SENATE'S ACTION
ON SPECIAL EDUCATION SPECIALIST
GRADUATE ENROLLMENT AS WELL AS
THE CAPITAL FELLOWS PROGRAM.
AND THEN THIRD REFLECTS THE
ASSEMBLY VERSION ON THE CSU
CENTER TO CLOSE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
IT'S BEEN MOVED.
AND SECOND IN WITH AN ASSEMBLY
VOTE OF FIVE ZERO A SENATE VOTE
OF FOUR TWO ZERO COMPROMISED
KERRY'S.
MOVING ON ISSUE THIRTY TWO
ACADEMIC QUALITY AND GRADUATION
INITIATIVE.
YOU'RE THE PROPOSED ACTION IS
THE ASSEMBLY ACTION ITEM ON BOTH
YOU SEE TWENTY THIRTY AS WELL AS
THE CSU GRADUATION INITIATIVE
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. TO MOVE.
ASSEMBLY BOTH OF FIVE TWO ZERO
THE SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
THE ASSEMBLY VERSION IS ACCEPTED
ISSUE THIRTY THREE ENROLLMENT.
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
THE PROPOSED ACTION AS MR
FERGUSON MENTIONED REFLECTS
FORTY NINE POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND. TO
INCREASE NEW RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT BY FOUR
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY
STUDENTS ABOUT THE LEVEL
PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET -- AS WELL AS
ADOPTING THE SENATE ACTION FOR
ENROLLMENT GROWTH THAT CSU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF THREE MORE LOT.
IN THIS ONE TO CLARIFY THIS IS
UNDER THE CSU CATEGORY.
IS THIS IS REFLECTED.
FOR OKAY I JUST DON'T SEE IT
OKAY THIRTY AS I APOLOGIZE THANK
YOU THANK YOU I'M SORRY IT'S
OKAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT EMOTION WITHIN
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TO ZERO
AND THE SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO THE SENATE VERSION OF THE
COMPROMISE.
IS IT KERRY'S ISSUE THIRTY FOUR
FACULTY.
THE PROPOSED ACTION HERE IS
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE OF TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THIS
IS ONE TIME FUNDING TO SUPPORT
YOU SEE EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY PRACTICES.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OUT. FOUR
TO ONE AT THE SENATE VOTE OF
IF
YOU -- IT'S OKAY THE ISSUE
THIRTY FOUR THAT'S WHAT I WAS ON
RIGHT.
A SENATE VOTE OF THREE TO TWO
THANK YOU.
ISSUE THIRTY FIVE SUPPORT
PROGRAM FOR FORMALLY
INCARCERATED STUDENTS.
FREE PROPOSED ACTIONS ON THESE
ITEMS -- NUMBER ONE IS
CONFERENCE COMPROMISED. THREE
AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE CCC REENTRY GRANT THIS IS
ONE TIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND -- SECOND THE
SENATE ACTION ON THE UC BERKELEY
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS PROGRAM AND
THIRD THE ASSEMBLY ACTION ON CSU
PROJECT REBOUND.
THANK YOU LIMITED EMOTIONS.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VODA. FORTY ONE
AND THE SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO COMPROMISED KYRIE'S ISSUE.
THIRTY SIX DID NOT REACH.
ON THIS SIDE OF THE PROPOSED
ACTION REFLECTS FOR ACTIONS
NUMBER ONE CONFERENCE COMPROMISE
FOR SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME FUNDING TO YOU SEE. FOR OUR
REGION STERN SUPPORT SERVICES
FOR LOW INCOME UNDER REPRESENTED
MINORITY STUDENTS NUMBER TWO
ADOPTING THE ASSEMBLY ACTION ON
CAL SOAP WITH PPL TO CREATE A
NEW INLAND EMPIRE CONSORTIA AND
ENSURING THE SAME OR HIGHER
FUNDING FOR CONSORTIUM THAT
ALREADY EXIST.
NUMBER THREE ADOPTING THE SENATE
ACTION ON STUDENT SUCCESS
AWARENESS TEAM IN STUDENT LOAN
AWARENESS AND FINALLY ADOPTING
THE GOVERNOR'S ACTION PROPOSAL --
FOR FUNDING FOR THE SAN JOAQUIN
INLAND EMPIRE INNOVATION AWARDS.
THE MANAGER WOULD USE PUT OFF
ITEM ONE PLEASE HAPPY TO AN ITEM
ONE IS THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISE
PROVIDE SIX MILLION ONE TIME TO
YOU SEE. TO CONDUCT OUTREACH.
EXCELLENT I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON ITEM ONE FIRST.
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED WITHIN
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FOUR TO ONE A
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE ZERO ALLAH
TEALA MOTION FOR ITEMS. TO THREE
AND FOUR BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTER FIVE ZERO
AND THE SENATE VOTE OF FIVE ZERO
COMPROMISED HERE.
IF YOU THIRTY SEVEN CAL GRANTS
COMPETITIVE SUMMER AND ACCESS
THE WARDS THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE HERE IS TO EXPAND THE
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT PROGRAM BY.
ADDING THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR AN ADDITIONAL -- ELEVEN
THOUSAND COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT
AWARDS THIS IS ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND ADDING --
FOUR THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
AWARDS IN ADDITION THIS
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE REFLECTS
FOR MILLIONS OF YOU SEE AND SIX
MILLION CSU TWELVE SUMMER
TUITION FEES FOR STUDENTS WHO
ARE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE STATE
FINANCIAL AID -- AND THIS --
PROGRAM IS ALSO UNDER THAT
SUSPENSION -- AT THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY I'M
SORRY THE SUSPENSION AT THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND WE ALSO
ADOPT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR STUDENTS PARENTS ACCESS TO
WORK.
THANK YOU ALL INTO THE MOTIONS
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE
ZERO A SENATE VOTE OUT FIVE ZERO
THE COPPER MINES HERE EASE.
ISSUE THIRTY EIGHT CAL GRANTS
FOR A. B. FIVE FORTY STUDENTS
HIS PROPOSED ACTION ADOPTS THE
ASSEMBLY ACTION WHEN IT COMES TO
EIGHTY FIVE FORTY COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
AS WELL AS THE ASSEMBLY ACTION
ON CAL GRANT BE SERVICE
INCENTIVE GRANTS AND THEN ALSO
ADOPTS A CONFERENCE COMPROMISED
FOR EIGHTY FIVE FORTY RESIDENT
TUITION TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU ONLY TO MOTION.
SPIN MOVED AND SECONDED.
THE ASSEMBLY VERSION OF BOTH OF
THREE TWO ONE AND THE SENATE
VOTE OF THREE TWO ONE THE SOSA
SAID. THREE TWO ONE HE WAS OFF
[inaudible]
RIGHT. THREE HOURS ONE NO ONE OF
TENSION [inaudible] ONE ONE THE
MAJOR COMPROMISE KERRY'S.
ISSUE THIRTY NINE CHILD SAVINGS
ACCOUNT.
THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE THE
SIMPLY VERSION BUT WE'LL HEAR
FROM FINANCE.
AT THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE UPS
ARE INDIA PROPOSED ACTION IS TO
ADOPT THE ASSEMBLY ACTION ON THE
SIDE PERFECT -- SOLITARY MOTION.
BLOOM THE SECOND WITH AN
ASSEMBLY VOTE OUT. FIVE TWO ZERO
A SENATE VOTE OF THREE TO TO THE
ASSEMBLY.
ACTION KERRY.
ISSUE FORTY TEACHER RECRUITMENT
AND PREPARATION.
THIS COMPROMISE WITH -- TAKE THE
ASSEMBLY ACTION TO ESTABLISH THE
GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAM AND ALSO ADD PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
SPECIFIES THAT GRANT RECIPIENTS
MUST COMMIT TO TEACH.
AT A SCHOOL THAT HAS A HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF TEACHERS HOLDING
EMERGENCY TYPE PERMITS.
ALERTED EMOTION -- THAT MOVED
AND SECONDED WITHIN ASSEMBLY
VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO AND THE
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TO ZERO THE
COMPROMISE KERRY'S ISSUE.
FORTY ONE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT.
A COUPLE OF ITEMS WITHIN THIS
ITEM -- BEGINS WITH PROVIDING
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE FUNDING
UP WHICH TEN MILLION DOLLARS IS
ON GOING FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH
STUDENT SERVICES ACT AND THIS IS
FOR COMPETITIVE GRANTS FOR
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN COUNTY
MENTAL OR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS.
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION ALSO INCLUDE SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS FROM POP SIXTY
THREE THIS WILL BE ONE TIME TO
PROVIDEMENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AT COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THREE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR TWO CSU AND
FIVE POINT THREE ON GOING FOR
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR MAYES.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS
PROVIDES A ONE TIME FUNDS FOR
THE COMMITTEE COLLEGES AND CSU
BUT I'M GOING FUNDS FOR YOU SEE
WHY.
BUT THE DIFFERENCE IS THE
FUNDING SCORE SO FOR THE UC IT
IS -- PART OF THE GENERAL FUND
PACKAGE THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAD PROPOSED IN JANUARY -- AND
ON THE PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE
MENTAL HEALTH FUNDS THAT ARE
GOING TO USE -- CSU AND
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THAT -- CONFERENCE COMPROMISED
TO PROVIDE THAT OUT OF A
PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE ON A ONE
TIME BASIS.
AND I WOULD NOTE THAT THE FIVE
POINT THREE MILLION FOR YOU SEE
WAS A REQUEST OF YOU SEE.
HELLO TEN EMOTIONS SECOND.
THE ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE ZERO A
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE ZERO
COMPROMISE KERRY'S.
ISSUE.
WE'RE GONNA TRANSITION TO PHASE
SIXTEEN OF THE ACTION LISTS TO
KNOCK IN CONFERENCE ITEMS.
STARTING WITH -- YOU SEE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
ON THE SIDE IN THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISES TO PROVIDE ONE FORTY
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN GENERAL FUND THIS IS ONE TIME
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FOR YOU
SEE.
THANK YOU.
AN ANTENNA MOTIONS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE
TWO ZERO SAN ANTONIO. THREE TWO
COMPROMISE KERRY'S EXTENSION
PROGRAMS WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION
WITH REGARD TO THE GOVERNOR'S
VERSION.
HELLO TINA MOTION. FOR THE
SECOND [inaudible]
THANK.
ASSEMBLY BOTH OF FIVE TWO ZERO A
SENATE VOTE OF FOUR TWO ZERO
GOVERNOR'S VERSION KERRY'S VERY
CONVERSE IF CALIFORNIA
ADJUSTMENTS.
HIS ITEMS THAT CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE REFLECTS THE
FOLLOWING FIRST ONE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME FOR THE
UC BERKELEY GRADUATE SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION THIS WOULD ESTABLISH
THE MARKETS FOSTER PHD
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM.
SECOND TWO AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME FOR YEAH UCLA'S
LATINO POLICY POLITICS
INITIATIVE.
THIRD OF THREE AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME FOR THE
UCLA RALPH BUNCHE CENTER.
FOURTH SEVEN AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME TO CHARLES R.
DREW UNIVERSITY TO INCREASE
STUDENT SUPPORT SERVICES AND
SUPPORT ENROLLMENT GROWTH. FIFTY
THREE POINT EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT
FIVE NINE DOLLARS NE TIME TO
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA FOR
FIREARMS VIOLENCE PREVENTION
TRAINING FOR HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS. SIX TO TEN MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME FOR
CONSERVATION GENETICS GENOMICS
SEVENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME FOR THE MARINE MAMMAL
CENTER. EIGHT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME FOR THAT LOSS
ON FILIPINO STUDY CENTER THIS IS
AT UC DAVIS. NINE TWO MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME FOR THE UC
BERKELEY ASIAN AMERICAN AND
ASIAN DIASPORA STUDIES
DEPARTMENT.
AND TEND TO ONE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
AND THIS WOULD MAINTAIN HE
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX FRAUDULENT
MEDICAL EDUCATION FUNDING LEVEL
AT FORTY MILLION DOLLARS.
THANK YOU WITH [inaudible]
CERTAINLY [inaudible]
YES SENATOR.
LAST NAME IS NOT ON OUR
DOCUMENTS.
THE ONE POINT THREE MILLION
GENERAL FUND TO MAINTAIN PROP
FIFTY SIX GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
FINANCE.
CERTAINLY -- HELP THERE SO.
WHAT THIS ACTION IS DOING IS
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX SATISFIED --
ABRUPTLY FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
TO PROVIDE FOR RESIDENCY SLOTS --
THEY'RE GENERALLY TARGETED
TOWARDS A MORE RURAL AREAS OF
THE STATE -- YEAH WHAT THE
RECENT REVENUE PROJECTIONS ARE
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX BEING
SLIGHTLY -- UNDER WHAT WAS
ANTICIPATED THE PROPOSITION
WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE.
REDUCE THE AMOUNT FOR THIS
PROGRAM FROM FORTY MILLION TO
THIRTY EIGHT POINT SEVEN MILLION
THIS ONE POINT THREE MILLION IS
INTENDED TO MAINTAIN THE PROGRAM
FORTY MILLION ONGOING.
WOULD YOU STILL LIKE A SEPARATE
IT OUT.
CERTAINLY I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION TO ACCEPT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE ON ITEMS ONE THROUGH --
NINE WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
THREE ZERO AND THE SENATE VOTE
OF THREE TWO ZERO I'LL ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ON THE COMPROMISE
AND I'D AND TEN IT'S BEEN MOVED
AND SECONDED WITH ASSEMBLY VOTE
OF FIVE ZERO IN THE SENATE VOTE
OUT. FOUR TWO ZERO COMPROMISED
CAREY.
THE VARIOUS LIBRARY ADJUSTMENTS
ON THE NECKLACE.
FINANCE OF THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE HERE -- PROVIDES FOR
THE FOLLOWING TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS THE POMONA
PUBLIC LIBRARY FOR FACILITIES
UPGRADES AND PROGRAM
IMPROVEMENTS MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME FOR CALIFORNIA HUMANITIES.
FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME FOR THE WITH YOUR
LIBRARY SERVICE UPGRADES ONE AND
A HALF MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
FOR THE EXPANSION OF FILLMORE
LIBRARY. TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
SATELLITE LIBRARY IN HILLA BEST
A HALF MILLION DOLLARS FOR
LAGUNA WHAT'S LIBRARY AND TWO
AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME FOR THE CITY OF FORTUNES
HUNT LIBRARY RENOVATIONS.
THANK YOU SIR.
ON THE MOTION.
THAT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
TO ACCEPT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE
OF FIVE TO ZERO IN THE SENATE
VOTE OF THREE TWO ONE
COMPROMISED KERRY'S.
SEE IF YOU DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISE --
PROPOSED ACTION ITEM HERE IS TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME IN GENERAL FUND
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AT CSU
FULLERTON EMOTION.
SECOND.
THE ASSEMBLY VOTE OUT FIVE ZERO
IN THE SENATE VODA. FORTY ONE
COMPROMISE KERRY'S VERY YOU SEE
IF YOU ADJUSTMENTS.
THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISE HERE
REFLECTS FIVE ITEM SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE TIME TO SEE
IF YOU TO MAKE IT SELLS MARVIN
TAMALE AFRICAN AMERICAN
POLITICAL AND ECONOMIC INSTITUTE.
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
FOR THE CSU CHANNEL ISLANDS
CHILD CARE CENTER ELEVEN AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
FOR THE CALIFORNIA SCIENCE
ALMOST. THREE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE CSU COUNCIL ON OCEAN
AFFAIRS SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY
AT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONE TIME FOR CSU SAN
JOSE AND THIS WOULD BE TO PLAN A
MIXED USE HOUSING PROJECT AT THE
ALFRED OFFICE BUILDING SITE.
THANK YOU IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
FIVE ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF FOUR
TWO ZERO THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AGAIN UNDER
THE NECKLACE THEIR CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS. TO THE
CONFERENCE COMPROMISES TO
APPROVE THE FOLLOWING PROJECTS
AND I BELIEVE THERE ARE TWENTY
NINE PROJECTS ON THIS LIST -- SO
I CAN READ THEM VERY QUICKLY --
OR OR NOT.
I'M ON YOUR SIDE.
YOU HAVE LONG WAY TO GO -- SEC
ARE THERE ANY ISSUES WITH TAKE
IN ALL TWENTY NINE ISSUES ITEMS
UP IN ONE VOTE.
SEEN NOT ONLY ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE
TWO ZERO IN A SENATE VOTE OF
FOUR TWO ZERO COMPROMISED CAREY.
WE NEED TO RETURN TO TO TO
AUTUMN THROUGH [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH -- THE QUESTION WAS RAISED
ON ISSUE TWENTY TWO ABOUT THE
ELIMINATION OF ONE ADDITIONAL
CAMPUS I BELIEVE ON THE
SHOOTINGS YOU CARE TO RESPOND.
YEAH I THINK IN THE END IT JUST
WASN'T ENOUGH FUNDING TO FUND
THAT ONE PROGRAM.
HELLO TO THE MOTION TO ACCEPT
THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISE
[inaudible]
SOME OF OUR IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED.
ALL WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
FOUR TWO ZERO AND THE SENATE
VOTE OF FIVE ZERO COMPROMISED
KERRY'S.
WE HAVE AN ADDITIONAL ITEM --
ISSUE SEVENTEEN THAT WILL RETURN
TO LATER AFTER.
WE CONTINUE TO REVIEW THE
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE.
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON WE ALWAYS
DID.
WHEN I CAME BACK TO THE ONE THAT
WAS HIT?
WOULD YOU THINK ABOUT.
WE WILL NOW TRANSITION.
TO RESOURCES AND TRANSPORTATION.
I WILL WAIT -- FOR STAFF CHANGE
[inaudible]
SHOULD CHANGE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
I KNOW.
NOW THEY'RE NOT.
I DON'T THINK WE NEED
[inaudible]
ONE PROBLEM [inaudible]
PRODUCT.
SO WE'RE GOING TO SKIP ITEMS
ISSUES ONE INTO BECAUSE IT WAS
ALREADY INCLUDED IN THE
EDUCATION.
SECTION.
HOW ABOUT THAT SO WE'LL MOVE ON
TO ISSUE THREE PRAGUE SIXTY PROP
SIXTY EIGHT IMPLEMENTATION?
FINANCE.
SO ON THESE ITEMS THAT WE HAVE
FOR YOU TO CONFERENCE COMPROMISE
WHEN IT COMES TO THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE.
AS WELL AS THE FIFTY NINE
DOLLARS FOR THEIR TO WANT TO
RIVER POLLUTION CONTROL.
IN ADDITION THE PROPOSED ACTION
ADOPTS THE ASSEMBLY ACTION OF
SIX MILLION DOLLARS FOR HABITAT
RESTORATION PRO PROJECTS.
AND ADOPTS THE SENATE ACTION FOR
THIRTY ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ALAMEDA CREEK
RESTORATION AND THREE AND A HALF
MILLION FOR ARROYO SECCO WATER
REUSE AND RESTORATION PROJECT.
THANK YOU ALL IN A TEN A MOTION
TO ACCEPT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISEIT REFLECTS BOTH
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE VERSIONS.
SECOND BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED --
WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TO
ZERO SAN ANTONIO. FOUR TWO ZERO
COMPROMISED KERRY'S ISSUE FOR
VARIOUS TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS
WERE LOOKING AT THE CONFERENCE
COPPER MINES YES IN HERE ALL
PASSED OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE MS
CALVERT.
THANK YOU TERESA COVERED
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A
CONFERENCE COMPROMISES THE
ASSEMBLY VERSION.
FOR THEM THEIR RECESSES
RESOURCES BOARD POSITIONS ANNA
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE FOR A
TRANSFER FOR THE ILLEGAL DRUG
LAB CLEAN UP ACCOUNT.
THANK YOU.
A LETTER TO THE MOTION.
SECOND IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
FIVE TO ZERO IN THE SENATE VOTE
OF THREE TWO ZERO ISSUE FIVE
REAPPROPRIATION.
FUSING VERY TOOK ACTION ON THAT.
ISSUE SIX ENHANCE FIRE
PROTECTION WORK I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION FOR THE SENATE VERSION.
WITH ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE ZERO
AND HE SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TO
ZERO THE SENATE VERSION KERRY'S
ISSUE SEVEN PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS PROGRAM CONTINUATION
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR
ASSEMBLY VERSION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED FOR
THE ASSEMBLY VOTE UP. FIVE ZERO
AND A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE ZERO
THREE VERSION KERRY'S.
IF YOU WAIT WILD FIRE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE ADJUSTMENT
THERE'S A COMPROMISE RIGHT THE
PROPOSED -- YES SENATE IN
SOMEONE COMPROMISE YES TO REJECT
THE MAY REVISED PROPOSAL FOR A
GUILLOTINE EMOTION. FOUR TO ONE
AND A SENATE VOTE OF FORTY ONE
WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE TEN
CALIFORNIA BIO DIVERSITY IN
ISSUE THE INITIATIVE.
THERE'S A CONFERENCE COMPROMISE
THAT'S CORRECT SO THIS WOULD
APPROVE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL BUT IT WOULD ALSO ADD
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL LICENSE
PLATE FUND.
THAT'S TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR FOR THE NEXT
THREE YEARS THAT'S FOR CDFA FOR
THE COLLECTION OF RARE PLANTS
FOR CONTRACTS AND GRANTS.
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PLANT RESCUE
PROGRAM AND I WOULD ALSO ADD
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE REQUIRING
COLLABORATION BETWEEN CDFA AND
CDS W. ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THESE CONTRACTS AND GRANTS.
THANK YOU IT'S BEEN MOVED.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO TAKE
IT ALL THESE ISSUES IN ONE
MOTION.
SEEING NONE OF THE SINCE BEEN
MOVED IN ASSEMBLY VOTE OUT. FIVE
ZERO IN THE SENATE VOTE OF FOUR
TWO ONE FUSE ME. THREE TO ONE
THREE TO ONE SORRY.
ISSUE ELEVEN HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND SUNSET
EXTENSION THE MOTION IS THE
ASSEMBLY VERSION.
MOVED WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
FOUR TO ONE AND A SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TWO ZERO ASSEMBLY VERSION.
IT'S SCARY.
ISSUE TWELVE CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN THIS REFLECTS A
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE FOR A
TOTAL OF ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS IN DISCRETIONARY
SPENDING WITHIN THE CAP AND
TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN.
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY RESERVATION TO ONE
MOTION EXCEPT IN THE ENTIRE CAP
AND TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN.
IT'S AMAZING I'M GUESSING WHAT
WE'RE WE JUST GOT THE SHE JUST
SECONDS AGO.
THIS SHEET -- THER SIMPLY SHOWS
YOU WHAT THE ASSEMBLY VIRGINIA
IT WAS -- THE IT'S A SIDE BY
SIDE COMPARISON BETWEEN THE
ASSEMBLY SENATE.
AND ADMINISTRATION OF THE SAFE
DRINKING WATER VERSION IS WHAT'S
BEFORE US.
YES.
YES AND IT'S ALSO REFLECTED ON
ON AT LEAST ON OUR AGENDA PAGE
[inaudible]
THREE OKAY.
MISTER MOORE LOCK.
I'M SURE WHAT'S THE NEXUS
BETWEEN CAP AND TRADE IN
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GASES AND
PROVIDING SAFE DRINKING WATER.
SO WE'RE FINANCE YES -- SO WE'RE
HAPPY TO SPEAK TO THAT SO IN
THESE COMMUNITIES WHERE THERE IS
AN ACCESS TO SAFE DRINKING WATER
YOUR OFTEN BRING IN BOTTLED
WATER -- YOUR TRACKING AND WATER
THAT SEEKS TO DRINK AND ALL
THESE HAD EMISSIONS IMPACTS OF
THAT WE BELIEVE THESE
INVESTMENTS -- NOT ONLY HELP
THIS COMMITTEES BY GIVING THEM
SAFE DRINKING WATER BUT ALSO
FULFILL THE GOALS OF THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU THANK MANAGER.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ACCEPT THE
COMPROMISE SECOND IT'S BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED WITHIN
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF THREE TWO ONE
AND A SENATE VOTE OF FOR TWO
ZERO GET NOTIFIED OF HARD ARE.
TWELVE FOR YEAH THANK YOU.
ISSUE THIRTEEN SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
SO HERE THERE IS A CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE -- AS WE DISCUSSED
WITH A CAP AND TRADE EXPAND TO
PROPOSAL BRIEFLY -- IN TERMS OF
BUDGET BILL IT WOULD BE A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND.
AS WELL AS THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND JUST FOR
THIS YEAR AND FINALLY THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND FOR THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS.
IN ADDITION REAR -- RISKY
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE ON A
TRAILER BILL THERE WOULD BE A 5%
G. G. R. F. CONTINUES
APPROPRIATION BEGINNING AND
BUDGET YOUR PLUS -- ONE THAT 5%
WOULD BE CAPPED AT A HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
AND THEN BEGINNING IN -- TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
AND GOING THROUGH -- TWENTY
THIRTY FOUR GOING THROUGH UNTIL
TWENTY THIRTY THERE WOULD BE A
GENERAL FUND BACKSTOPS TO FILL
THE SAFE DRINKING WATER FIND
SHOULD THAT 5% LEVEL FALL BELOW
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ANY OF THOSE YEARS.
THANK YOU.
ALERTING THE MOTION. TO ACCEPT
THE COMPROMISE WITH ASSEMBLY
VOTE OUT. FIVE ZERO AND THE
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO THE
COMPROMISE KERRY'S -- ISSUE
FOURTEEN DISCUSSIONS WILL
CONTINUE ISSUE.
FIFTEEN TEMPORARY ASSISTANCE FOR
CERTIFIED RECYCLING CENTERS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
I'M SORRY FINANCES TO ACCEPT THE
SILLY VERSION FOR YES -- QUALITY
THE MOTION WE'VE HEARD IT WITH
AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE ZERO IN
THE SENATE VOTE OF THREE ZERO
THE ASSEMBLY VERSION KERRY'S
ISSUE.
SIXTEEN HEALTHY STORES
REFRIGERATION GRANT PROGRAM --
WE TOOK ACTION ON THAT ALREADY.
ISSUE SEVENTEEN WILDFIRE IN
CLIMATE CHANGE IS A CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED YES TO THE
COMPROMISE HERE'S TO DEFER
ACTION ON THE REQUESTED RESOURCE
IS PENDING FURTHER DISCUSSION --
BUT IT WOULD APPROVE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE ALLOWING FOR
FLEXIBILITY IN THE SALARY PAID
TO THE PRESIDENT OF THE PC --
THAT THAT WOULD BE BASED ON
SPECIFIED FACTORS AND SUBJECT TO
LEGISLATIVE NOTIFICATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO TO THE MOTION TO ACCEPT
THE CONFERENCE COPPER MINE
[inaudible]
SEC [inaudible]
SOMETHING.
IF FINANCING PLEASE CLARIFY THE
COMPROMISE.
YES -- MARK YOU WANT TO SPEAK TO
THAT SERVICES -- FOR JERRY
DISCUSSING THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IN PARTICULAR
[inaudible]
SURE.
YES SUMMER HUNDRED HER TO
FINANCE THIS.
AND TRAILER BILL JUST --
PROVIDES FOR A IT INCREASES THE
AMOUNT THAT WHAT THE THE STATE
CAN PAY THAT PRESIDENT OF FOR PC.
CERTAINLY SENATE BILL SECTION
NOW.
FOR RECOMPENSE IN THE PROS AND
THE P. UC.
THE INTENT IS TO BE ABLE TO
AFFORD.
THE VISUALS WITH -- BROADER
EXPERIENCE AND CUT THE SKILL SET
THAT WERE LOOKING.
FOR SO IT'S NOT AN AUTOMATIC
COMPENSATION INCREASE IT RAISES
THE CEILING SO IN THE EVENT THAT.
THAT IS YOU NEED TO YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY YOU'RE AUTHORIZED TO
DO SO THAT'S CORRECT YES I
WOULDN'T HAVE ANY TROUBLE
GETTING -- THERE'S A THE THE UC.
FOR THE DAY.
CURRENT PRESIDENT JUST SIGNALS
THAT HIS INTENTION TO STEP DOWN
SO THIS COULD BE ISSUE -- FAIRLY
SOON. THIRTY MORE LOT
[inaudible]
MANAGER -- THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED
THIRTY FOUR POSITIONS.
THE SENATE APPROVED.
THAT REQUEST AND THEN THE
ASSEMBLY APPROVED THIRTY EIGHT
POSITIONS AND SO I DON'T KNOW.
WHAT THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISES
I HAVE NOTHING IN WRITING?
SO I DON'T KNOW WHY WE'RE JUST
TALKING ABOUT A RACE TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CPUC ACT.
ARE YOU GETTING YOUR POSITIONS
ARE YOU DID YOU COME UP WITH
THIRTY SIX WHAT'S THE COMPROMISE
THAT THAT ISSUE IS STILL PENDING
WE HAVEN'T COME TO A COMPROMISE
ON THAT SPECIFIC ITEM YET.
SO ALL WE'RE VOTING ON RIGHT NOW
IS A PAY RAISE.
AND TECHNICALLY IT'S NOT A PAY
RAISE IT IT GIVES THE
FLEXIBILITY -- IT RAISES THE
CEILING -- FOR THAT POSITION SO
WE'RE NOT VOTING ON AN ACTUAL
PAY RAISE.
BUT WE WILL NOT.
YOU ARE VOTING ON WE ARE
APPROVING TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
ALLOWING FOR FLEXIBILITY.
IN THE SALARY PAID TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE P. YOU SEE
BASED ON SPECIFIED FACTORS AND
SUBJECT TO LEGISLATIVE
NOTIFICATION.
THANK YOU BàN FOR YOUR VOTING
ON THE THE INCREASE OF THE
FEELING FOR THAT CURRENT.
SALARY.
YEAH ONE MORE.
SURE THIRTY NIELSEN.
AND WHO WOULD MAKE THE
DETERMINATION IT WOULD BE THE P.
UC COMMISSIONERS THE GOVERNOR.
THE LEGISLATURE WHO MAKES THE
DETERMINATION.
OF WHAT THE SALARY WILL BE.
HE HAS OPENLY WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION -- THERE'S A A
PROCESSES THIS IS NOT THAT --
ONLY POSITION THE THAT THE THIS
FLEXIBILITY APPLIES TO AND SO
THERE IS A AN EXISTING PROCESS
FOR WORKING WITH CAL HR FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO WORK THROUGH
KELLEY CHART TO ESTABLISH
WHATEVER THAT IS [inaudible]
MADAM CHAIR.
JUST TO CLARIFY WE'VE BEEN
HAVING A LOT OF FUN WITH THE
CPUC AND SO NOW WE'RE REPORTING
THE PRESIDENT WITH A PAY RAISE.
I'M TRYING.
TO DIGEST THIS WE ARE NOT.
REWARDING THE CURRENT PERSON
WITH AN ACTUAL INCREASE WHAT
WE'RE SAYING IS THROUGH CAL HR.
THE NEXT TIME THEY POST THE
POSITION THEY WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY -- AFTER THE
LEGISLATIVE NOTIFICATION TO
INCREASE THE CEILING OF THE
SALARY.
IN TERMS OF THE NEXT PERSON
HIRED INTO THE POSITION THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR YOU'RE MORE THAN
WELCOME.
WITH THAT CLARIFICATION -- ALL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ACCEPT THE
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE ON ISSUE.
SEVENTEEN SECOND.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY BOTH OF FOUR TO
ONE AND THE SENATE VOTE OF FORTY
ONE AGAIN UNDER RESOURCES UNDER
THE NOT IN CONFERENCE LISTS
INNOVATION PROCUREMENT.
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE SO HERE THE
COMPROMISES TO APPROVE THEM A
REVISION PROPOSAL BUT ADD
MODIFICATIONS -- TO THE
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE NUMBER ONE
TO THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
CAP WHEN IT COMES TO THE TOTAL
LEVEL OF AUGMENTATIONS THAT
COULD BE AUTHORIZED UNDER THIS
COMPROMISED -- AND NUMBER TWO
REQUIRING A THIRTY DAY
NOTIFICATION AND REVIEW PERIOD
INSTEAD OF THE PROPOSED FIFTEEN
DAY PERIOD FROM THE MAY REVISION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ON A TOP UNLIMITED A MOTION TO
ACCEPT THE CONFERENCE COPPER
MINE.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE
ZERO IN THE SENATE VOTE OF FIVE
TO ZERO GOT IT.
UNDER OF THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY AGAIN.
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE ON THE NOT
IN CONFERENCE ITEM.
YES IT THIS REFLECTS FUNDING FOR
A NUMBER OF PROJECTS AND HAPPY
TERROR LIST OR NOT LESS THAN --
DEPENDING ON THE CHAIRS
PREFERENCE.
THAT WILL BE NECESSARY TO MOVE.
A TWO IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED TO ACCEPT OF THE
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE AND ALL
THE ITEMS LISTED UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY. THIRTY NIELSEN.
LOOK OFF HE CAMP TWENTY ONE
MILLION LOCAL ASSISTANCE.
THE WALLS IN THE TUBS FIRES
WE'LL SHOOT TEMPLE CAM.
SELECT AS WITH THAT ONE OFF.
AND ALSO THE SAME PER CAT.
FAILED BRIDGE THOSE TWO SO I
WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ACCEPT THE SPENDING PLANS FOR
THE SANTA CRUZ PORT DISTRICT
COLUMBIA MEMORIAL SPACE INTERNET
TO HIS MUSEUM OF LA COUNTY.
DEL MAR BLUFF STABILIZATION
PROJECT AND DISCOVERY SCIENCE
CENTER OF ORANGE COUNTY.
ALERTING THAT MOTION.
SECOND BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE
ZERO AND A SENATE VOTE OF THREE
TWO ONE NOT JUST TO PROTECT.
THREE TWO ZERO I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON CAN'T READ BILLS.
DâN SABER CAT TRAIL BRIDGE IT'S
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED WITHIN
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
AND A SENATE VOTE OF THREE TWO
ZERO NO SHE DIDN'T LET.
I'M HERE TO PLEASE.
HELLO HELLO ONE SECOND SETTLE SO
ALL YOU WANT THOSE TWO SEPARATE
I'M SORRY SIR.
SO IF IF WE WILL. ONE ONE VOTE
AND SABR CAT A SECOND VITAL
WOULD BE ANOTHER GOT IT I'M
GOING TO SLOW DOWN TO THE TO
NIELSEN AND NOT TRY TO RUSH THIS
I APOLOGIZE.
SO COLLEAGUES ARE WE CLEAR I'M
GONNA ASSET THAT LAST VOTE BE
[inaudible]
THE STRICKEN.
AND I'M GOING TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON CAN'T RE BILLS.
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED UNABLE
TO THE SIMPLY VOTE UP. FIVE ZERO
AND A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
SUPER CAT TRAIL BRIDGE.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE UP
[inaudible] FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO
AND ASSEMBLY VOTE OF THREE TO
TWO WORK IT OUT PROP IT UP TO
THEM [inaudible]
BACK.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
MOVING ON TO THE CALIFORNIA
SCIENCE CENTER THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE TWO AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME FOR A
NEW ADA COMPLIANT ELEVATOR.
Q. ALL ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
ALL WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE. FIVE
ZERO AND THE SENATE VOTE OF FOUR
TWO ZERO CALIFORNIA AFRICAN
AMERICAN MUSEUM THE CONFERENCE
COPPER MINES THIS IS FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE THAT'S IN ONE TIME
FUNDING.
AS WELL AS FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN ONGOING FUNDING FOR
OPERATIONS.
THANK YOU IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED WITH ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
FIVE TO ZERO AND A SENATE VOTE
OF
FOUR TWO ZERO ON THE SCIENCE
CENTER MOTION US SENATE
COLLEAGUES.
CRIER CHUTE.
TO REFRESH MY MEMORY ARE YOUR
VOTE AGAIN THE SCIENCE CENTER --
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE ON THE ADA
COMPLIANT [inaudible]
THE ELEVATOR.
YES AND SO THAT'S THREE TWO ZERO
THREE THREE ZERO MOVING ON TO
THE PART MEANT OF PARKS.
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE FINANCE.
THIS ITEM THERE ARE NUMBER OF
AUGMENTATIONS AND YOU SHOULD
HAVE THE WEST BEFORE YOU AND
THAT WE DO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT'S BEEN MOVEDAND SECONDED
IS THERE ANY -- OBJECTION TO
TAKING ALL THE ITEMS ARE ITEMS
IN ONE VOTE.
SCENE NINE WE'VE HAD A MOTION
AND A SECOND AND ASSEMBLY VOTE
OKAY. FIVE TWO ZERO AND A SENATE
VOTE OF THREE TWO ZERO THE
CONFERENCE COMPROMISED KERRY'S
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES AT
THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISE
FINANCE THAT'S CORRECT THIS IS
NINE AND NINE POINT TWO FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND. FOR THE
ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS RESEARCH
MITIGATION AND CLIMATE
FORECASTING PROGRAMS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES.
THANK YOU IT'S BEEN MOVED.
AND SECONDED WITHIN ASSEMBLY
VOTE OFFIVE TWO ZERO AND THE
SENATE VOTE OF THREE YEAH
[inaudible] FOR TWO ZERO
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
WE HAVE A CONFERENCE COMPROMISE
THAT'S CORRECT THIS IS SEVENTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR THE INTERLAKE
TOTAL FISH SCREENS.
THANK YOU ON A TO THE MOST ON
THE COMPROMISE.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE A FIVE TWO
ZERO AND THE SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TWO ZERO THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE KERRY'S.
MOVING ON TO THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD THERE IS
A CONFERENCE COMPROMISE FINANCE
CORRECT -- TWO ITEMS HERE NUMBER
ONE IS TWO AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME GENERAL FUND --
FOR DRINKING WATER DROUGHT
RELIEF -- THIS FURTHER SELLING
OF TEMPORARY WATER TANKS FOR
HOUSEHOLDS THAT HAVE LOST THEIR
WATER SUPPLY DUE TO TRY WELL --
AND THE SECOND IS TWELVE AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL
FUND ONE TIME FOR SAFE AND CLEAN
DRINKING WATER FOR THE SOUTHERN
CENTRAL VALLEY AND YOU HAVE THE
LIST OF PROJECTS AND HOW THAT.
FUNDING WOULD BE DIVIDED BEFORE
YOU WE DO.
A LETTER TO THE MALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO TAKING HIM IN
ONE MOTION.
SEEN ON THE MOTION HAS BEEN
MOVED A HAND [inaudible]
THIRTEEN NIELSEN [inaudible]
THE THE FIRST ONE WHICH WOULD BE
THE THE DROUGHT RELIEF.
AND THE SECOND ONE WITH THE SAFE
AND CLEAN DRINKING WATER CENTRAL
VALLEY.
WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON THOSE.
ARE YOU OKAY SIR IF THE SECOND
VOTE ON THE SAFE AND CLEAN
DRINKING WATER FOR THE SEVEN
CENTRAL VALLEY INCLUDES ALL THE
OTHER.
SMALL BOATS UNDERNEATH IT.
YES.
RIGHT.
SO IN A TEN AM A MOTION ON THE
DRINKING WATER DROUGHT RELIEF
PACKAGE.
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED WITHIN
ASSEMBLY VOTE UP. FIVE ZERO AND
A SENATE VOTE OF FOUR TWO ZERO
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR THE
REMAINING OF THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO AND THE SENATE VOTE OF FOUR
TWO ZERO COMPROMISED KERRY'S.
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY IT IS A MULTI PAGE.
CONFERENCE COPPER MINE.
I WILL HAVE MEMBERS TO TAKE A
LOOK.
IF THERE ITEMS YOU LIKE TO VOTE
ON SEPARATELY SPEAK NOW.
THIS IS.
WHAT TO DO?
THE QUESTION ON THE CAL FIRE --
DEFENSIBLE SPACE ASSISTANCE FIVE
MILLION GENERAL NUMBER
[inaudible]
THE NEXT. FOR THE SHOVEL BORE.
THAT'S THE NEXT ONE TO CAL FIRE.
FOR THE SAME.
THING SO SIR [inaudible] FOR
BOTTOM OF PAGE ELEVEN I DON'T
KNOW IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S OKAY IT
LOOKS LIKE THIS IS.
THE DEFENSE OF THE THE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM FIVE MILLION GENERAL
FUND ONE TIME WELL THAT'S YEAH
THAT'S THAT BE THE ONE I WONDER
SEPARATE AND IT LOOKS LIKE THESE
OTHERS ARE ALL.
LIST WHICH I DON'T HAVE ANY
PROBLEM WITH OKAY GREAT.
SO I WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION
LET'S DO DEFENSIBLESPACE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS FIRST.
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO MOVE
SECOND.
SIR MORE LOT.
YOU'RE JUST FOR CLARIFICATION ON
PAGES FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN WERE
DOING.
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY.
AND ON PAGE SIXTEEN WERE DOING
CAL FIRE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES IN COASTAL CONSERVANCY.
AND WE WOULD BE BE DIVIDING THAT
WITH THE SHOT.
EXCERPTED WELFARE LORD IN A
DIFFERENT STATE OR YOU'VE GOT
DIFFERENT PAVE THE ROAD ALTHOUGH
I'M CYCLE FOR USE IN THE PAGE
NUMBERS.
OKAY.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
THE LONGER LIST THOUGH THAT
WOULD BE OKAYTO DO AND SORRY
THAT OKAY WITH YOU JOHN THE OLD.
THERE YOU GO [inaudible]
YEAH
.
I JUST.
DO [inaudible]
ASSEMBLY FLAGS [inaudible]
THE POTS.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO CREATE A
CLIP [inaudible]
FOR FIVE YEAH
.
COUPLE BY READ ALL OF THE LET ME
DO THAT.
THAT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
IT IS RIDICULOUS
.
FIRST OF ALL LET WE WILL
RECONVENE LET ME APOLOGIZE FOR
THE RISING TEMPERATURE IN THE
ROOM.
ON AND THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU WORK IN A PUBLIC BUILDING ON
SUNDAY SOMETIME.
OFF ANY THE GENTLEMAN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE THEIR CULTS
FEEL FREE TO O SO -- MR THIS
WILL NOT THEN.
I THINK WE'RE PREPARED NOW SIR
AND IF YOU WOULD ALLOW ME TO
WALK US THROUGH THESE THREE
MOTIONS.
BUT WE'RE NOW ALL ON THE SAME
PAGE.
SO AGAIN I WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION.
I AM ON PAGE TEN UNDER
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY UNDER THE NECKLACE.
I WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ACCEPT ALL OF THE ITEMS LISTED
ON PAGE.
TEN ALL OF THE ITEMS LISTED ON
PAGE TWO WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
REBUILD CAMPS AND DEFENSIBLE
SPACE ASSISTANCE.
THERE THE LAB AT THE BOTTOM.
THE SECOND TO THE LAST TWO
THIRDS OF THE LAST ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA PAGE [inaudible]
ELEVEN THANK.
ON PAGE.
TEN I WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ACCEPT ALL OF THE ITEMS.
ON PAGE.
ELEVEN I WILL ACCEPT ALL OF THE
ITEMS WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
REBUILD CAMPS. TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND ONE TIME
FOR LOCAL ASSISTANCE. TO RESTORE
HAS KRAMER AND SHALOM INTO TWO
CAMPS DESTROYED BY FIRE.
AND DEFENSIBLE SPACE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS FIVE MILLION GNERAL
FUND ONE TIME FOR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE RELATING TO WILDFIRES.
WHAT I WAS SAYING WAS THEY ARE
LEASE ON MY AGENDA?
THEY ARE THE THIRD AND THE
SECOND TO THE FROM THE BOTTOM OF
THE SHEET.
BUT NOW AFTER ISSUES INCLUDE.
THE NATURAL HISTORY ON THE
BOTTOM IS INCLUDED.
OKAY I'M I'M MOVE -- TROUBLED.
SECTOR.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE
TWO ZERO AND THE SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TWO ZERO THE SECOND MOTION
I WILL ENTERTAIN.
IS TO ACCEPT THE COMPROMISE FOR
RE BUILD CAMPS ON THE BOTTOM OF
PAGE.
ELEVEN ALL EXCEPT THAT EMOTION.
IT'S BEEN SECONDED WITHIN
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
AND THE SENATE VOTE OF FOUR TWO
ZERO ALL EXCEPT THE MOTION
FOCUSED ON DEFENSIBLE SPACE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME LOCAL
ASSISTANCE.
SO MOVED AND SECONDED WITHIN
ASSEMBLY VOTO. FIVE TWO ZERO AND
THE SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
THANK YOU.
MOVING ON TO CAL FIRE IS THE
CONFERENCE COPPER MINES FINANCE
SO HERE THE COMPROMISES FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO CAL FIRE.
AND THIS IS TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE-RELATED TO THE SPREAD OF THE
SHOT HOLE BORE INVASIVE BEATLES.
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED WITHIN
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TO ZERO
AND A SENATE VOTE OF FOUR TWO
ZERO DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES WE HAVE A CONFERENCE
COPPER MINES.
FINANCE THROUGH ACTIONS HERE --
FIRST IS ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
LOCAL ASSISTANCE THE CITY OF WAR
A HILLS -- AND SECOND IS EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS AND ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND -- FOR THE
WATER REPLENISHMENT DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU ALL ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTED FIVE TO
ZERO AND THE SENATE VOTE OF
THREE ZERO CONFERENCE.
A CONFERENCE COMPROMISED KERRY'S
COASTAL CONSERVANCY WE HAVE A
COMPROMISE SO HERE IT'S TWO
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR CAPITAL WORSE.
THANK YOU ALL IN A TO THE MOTION
TO MOVE IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTO
FIVE ZERO A SENATE VOTE UP.
THREE TWO ONE THREE TWO ONE
MOVING ON DEPARTMENT OF HEART.
WE HAVE.
A COMPROMISE ON NUMEROUS ACTIONS.
BEFORE YOU AND HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU SOME OF THAT.
ARE THERE ANY ISSUES WITH THE
ITEMS.
IN A SINGLE MOTION.
THE MOVE [inaudible]
THANK.
IT'S IN THE REQUEST YEAH RIGHT
RIGHT.
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION IT'S
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS ASSEMBLY
VOTE OF FIVE ZERO A SENATE VOTE
OF THREE ZERO COMPROMISED
KERRY'S.
SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY THERE'S A COMPROMISE
YOU ACTIONS HERE FIRST THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND FOR GREENBELT
PARK IN THE CITY OF LA.
AND SECOND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR SICK MORE POCKET PARK.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED FOR
THE COMPROMISE WITH AN ASSEMBLY
PHOTO. FIVE ZERO IN THE SENATE
VOTE OF THREE TO ONE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD THERE'S
A COMPROMISE FREE ITEMS HERE
FIRST OF THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FOR
EMERGENCY DRINKING WATER.
SECOND IS TWO POINT SIX FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR THE COUNTY
VENTURA WATERWORKS DISTRICT.
AND THIRD IS FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR CITY BABYLON
FUEL TANK REPLACEMENT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
AND SECOND THANK YOU WITH
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE ZERO IN
THE SENATE VOTE OF THREE TWO
ZERO COMPROMISE HERE.
MOVING ON TO TRANSPORTATION FEES
WE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE THERE'S A
COMPROMISE FOR ITEMS HEREFIRST
IS TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CITY OF SAN RAFAEL.
CENTER FOR FOOD AND AGRICULTURE
SECOND IS THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONE TIME TO THE SANTA
BARBARA EARL WARREN SHOWGROUNDS.
THIRTIES FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE C.
BANK FOR CFA AND FINALLY HALF
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR THE HOMELESS GARDEN IN
THE CITY OF SANTA CRUZ.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL INTO THE
MOTION FOR THE COMPROMISE.
THE MOVE FOR HER THANK YOU WITH
AN ASSEMBLY VOTE UP. FIVE TWO
ZERO AND THE SENATE BOTHA. THREE
TWO ZERO THE COMPROMISE KERRY'S
MOVING ON TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION.
CENTER MORE LOT IN JUST BECAUSE
WE HAVE DIFFERENT -- CHEATS BUT
DID WE COVER DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE THAT WAS JUST ONE
ITEM [inaudible] FIVE MILLION.
PERCENT COMING UP [inaudible]
EIGHT REGARDING THE INNER LIKE
TO OFFICE GREENS [inaudible]
THE SAID WERE LIKE ALL RIGHT.
OKAY BEAUTIFUL.
LET'S SEE NOW WE'RE WAS A AND
YOU ARE HELPING.
MOVING ON TO TRANSPORTATION
CALVET APARTMENT TRANSPORTATION --
WE HAVE THE HOLIDAY TO THE
MOTION TO ACCEPT THE ASSEMBLY
VERSION OF THE FOOTHILL
BOULEVARD LINK BACK WE IN
PEDESTRIAN GREEN BELL.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO A
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
THREE VERSION IS ACCEPTED ISSUE
NINETEEN THE BURBANK TO ANAHEIM
METROLINK CORDER.
THE MOTION IS ASSEMBLY VERSION
SECOND WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
FIVE TWO ZERO SENATE VOTE OF
FIVE TWO ZERO AWESOME VERSION IS
ACCEPTED.
ISSUE TWENTY PALO ALTO GRAND
GRAY THE SEPARATION PROJECT
ASSEMBLY VERSION IS THE MOTION
WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE UP. FIVE
TWO ZERO SENATE VOTE OF
FOR FIVE
TWO ZERO ISSUE TWENTY ONE
CALIFORNIA SHORTLINE RAIL ROAD
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENT ACT
OF TWENTY NINETEEN THE MOTION IS
SENATE VERSION WITH AN ASSEMBLY
VOTE OF THREE TO ONE AND A
SENATE VOTE OF THREE TO TWO
SENATE VERSION KERRY'S.
ISSUE.
TWENTY TWO SR ONE FIFTY SIX THE
CASTROVILLE SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS
THE MOTION IS -- ASSEMBLY
VERSION.
OFF WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
FIVE TWO ZERO AND A SENATE VOTE
OF FIVE TWO ZERO THIS ONLY
VERSION GARY.
ADDITIONAL TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENTS.
FINANCE THERE IS A COMPROMISE
YES FIVE ITEMS FIRST IS TEN
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE DISSOLUTION OF THE NORTH
COAST RAIL AUTHORITY.
SECOND IS FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR SUICIDE PREVENTION MEASURES
ON THE SAN DIEGO CORONADO BRIDGE.
THIRTIES FIVE AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS FOR SOUND WALL
CONSTRUCTION ALONG THE FOOTHILL
FREEWAY. FOR THIS ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR AC TRANSIT FOR BUS
SERVICE TO OAKLAND UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND FIFTH IS ONE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE IMPACT
TEEN DRIVERS PROGRAM AT C. H. P..
THANK YOU SO MUCH IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO TAKING ALL ACTIONS
IN ONE MOTION [inaudible]
THANK.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE
ZERO AND THE SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TWO ZERO THE COMPROMISE.
KERRY.
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL ISSUE
TWENTY THREE CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROPOSALS THERE IS A COMPROMISE
YES SO THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISE
HERE IS ONE HUNDRED THIRTY TWO
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
IN LEASE REVENUE BONDS AUTHORITY
AND THIS IS FROM THE PUBLIC
BUILDINGS CONSTRUCTION FIND TO
CONTINUE CONSTRUCTION OF EL
CENTRO HEY WORD AND ST BERNARD
YOU KNOW EVERY OFFICES -- AND WE
WOULD ALSO DIFFER THAT BUDGET
YOUR SUPPLEMENTAL PENSION
PAYMENTS.
TO TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THANK YOU.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION TO ACCEPT
THE COMPROMISE.
WITH ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TO
ZERO AND THE SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TO ONE ISSUE TWENTY FOUR
ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME TASK
FORCE THE MOTION IS ASSEMBLY
VERSION -- WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE
OF FIVE TWO ZERO AND A SENATE
VOTE OF FIVE TO ZERO THIS ONLY
VERSION KERRY'S.
ISSUE TWENTY FIVE DIEM BE
OPERATIONAL IMPROVEMENTS THERE'S
A COMPROMISE YES -- ON THIS
ISSUE -- THAT PROPOSED ACTION IS
TWO HUNDRED FORTY TWO POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR AND ONE HUNDRED NINETY NINE
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS AND
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE PROPOSED COMPROMISE ALSO
REFLECTS -- NUMBER OF ACTIONS --
REFLECTING SOME THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE LEGISLATURE IN
PARTICULAR REQUIRING QUARTERLY
REPORTING A PROGRESS ON
IMPLEMENTING CERTAIN
ORGANIZATIONAL AND PERFORMANCE
IMPROVEMENT EFFORTS.
AS WELL AS MONTHLY REPORTING OF
K PERFORMANCE METRICS -- THIS
PROPOSED ACTION ALSO ALLOWS FOR
AUGMENTATION OF THE BUDGET IF
REQUIRED AND PASSES ON CREDIT
CARD FEES TO DMB CUSTOMERS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT'S BEEN MOVED.
AND SECONDED OUT OF ASSEMBLY
VOTE OF THREE TO TWO AND A
SENATE VOTE OF THREE TO TO THE
COMPROMISE HERE.
WITH THAT WE'VE CONCLUDED.
RESOURCES AND TRANSPORTATION.
LIKE TO INVITE EVERYONE TO TAKE
A BRIEF STRETCH BREAK AS WE MOVE
INTO HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
THAT MAKES SENSE
.
ARE YOU READY WITH YOUR
RECORDING DEVICE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
COLLEAGUES WERE READY TO BEGIN.
YEAH IT'S FINANCE WITH A MIND
STATING HIS NAME FOR THE RECORD.
TAKE THIS ONE OFF AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD COLLEAGUES AND GET STARTED
WITH HEALTH.
AND HUMAN SERVICES. TWO FOUR ARE
ON ISSUE -- ONE WE WANT TO DEFER
UNTIL LATER DISCUSSION.
YES WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A PATH
IN ISSUE ONE ISSUE.
TWO OFFICE OF HEALTHY AND SAFE
COMMUNITIES.
THE OUR RECOMMENDATION IS THE
EXCEPT SENATE VERSION.
THANK YOU WITH ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
I'M MRS SOMEBODY.FIVE FIVE ZERO
AND THE FILM A SENATE VOTE OF
THE MISSES A MALE HERE AT MC
REALIZED SHE WASN'T THERE.
WHAT THE SENATE VOTE ON ISSUE
TWO OF?
ISSUE TWO OFFICE OF HEALTHY AND
SAFE COMMUNITIES.
OF FOUR TWO ZERO ISSUE THREE
STATE OF THE STATE'S PUBLIC
HEALTH THERE IS A MOTION TO
ACCEPT THE SENATE VERSION.
IS THERE A SECOND SECOND THANK
YOU WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF AND
ASSEMBLY VODA. FIVE TWO ZERO ONE
ISSUE THREE SENATE VOTE OF FIVE
TWO ZERO SENATE VERSION IS
ACCEPTED.
MOVING ON TO WE'RE GOING TO
RETURN TO ISSUE ONE UNDER
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
COMMISSIONS THE MOTION IS TO
ACCEPT THE ASSEMBLY VERSION.
AND SO WHAT IS IT WE'RE
DEFERRING UNTIL LATER.
TO I CAN SPEAK TO THAT SHOULD BE
IT -- FOR THAT -- BUT YOU BILL
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE -- THAT
CONFERENCE GOV RISES TO ACCEPT
THE ASSEMBLY VERSION BUT WE ARE
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS ON HOW
TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE AND TIME
TO COME.
HOW DOES THIS WITH WHICH IS TO
BE ISSUED THAT HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL COMMISSION
AND OKAY THE COMMISSION ITSELF
YES ALL RIGHT?
SO THE MOTIONS ASSEMBLY VERSION
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTO. FIVE TWO
ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO ON ISSUE.
ONE BOND ISSUE TO ALL RE OPEN
THE ROLE ON THE SENATE VERSION.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO ADD ON THANK
YOU SHE WOULD HEAR.
ON ISSUE.
TO SO THE VOTE ON SENATE ISSUED
TWO IS.
FIVE TWO ZERO WE'VE COMPLETED
THE VOTE ON THE ISSUE THREE DID
WE NOT.
WE'RE NOT GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT OFSHE
PET.
ISSUE FOR MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT THERE IS A
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE YES SO THE
PROPOSED LEVEL SPENDING OVERALL
REMAINS FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
BUT WITHIN THIS FORTY SIX POINT
THREE MILLION FOR MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. ONE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR SCHOLARSHIPS
FOR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND TWO
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
ONE TIME FOR PSYCHIATRY
FELLOWSHIPS.
THANK YOU.
THEIR MOTION TO ACCEPT THE
COMPROMISE.
HAS BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED WITH
AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TO ZERO
IN THE SENATE VOTE UP FIVE TWO
ZERO THE COMPROMISE KERRY'S.
ISSUE FIVE PUBLIC USE FILE
ACCESS THE MOTION IS SENATE
VERSION.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE
ZERO AND ASSEMBLY SENATE VOTE OF
FIVE ZERO THE SENATE VERSION.
IS KERRY.
ISSUE SIX WERE VERSION ALL PAYER
CLAIMS DATABASE EXCESS FUNDING
THE MOTION IS ASSEMBLY VERSION.
MORE THAN ASSEMBLY VOTE OUT.
FIVE ZERO IN THE SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TWO TWO THE ASSEMBLY
VERSION KERRY'S.
ISSUE SEVEN MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATION ENROLLMENT TAX
THERE IS A CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED.
YES THAT IS TO ADOPT A PLACE
HOLDER TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
AUTHORIZE AN NCO TAX AND FOR NOW
THERE IS NO BUDGET IMPACT
PENDING FEDERAL APPROVAL OF THE
TAX.
THANK YOU THERE'S A MOTION THE
COPPER MINES.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FOUR
TWO ZERO AND THE SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TWO ZERO IF YOU WAIT FULL
SCOPE MEDI CAL FOR UNDOCUMENTED
ADULTS THERE IS A COMPROMISE YES
TWO ITEMS HERE FIRST IS TO ADOPT
THE NAY REVISION PROPOSAL OF
EXPANDING.
FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL DOT THROUGH
AGE TWENTY FIVE REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS AND THE
SECOND OPPOSE ALL IS A
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE REFLECTING THE REVISED
AB EIGHTY FIVE REALIGNMENT
PROPOSAL FOR CMS P. COUNTIES.
MR OBERNOLTE WHICH IS PUT THE
VOTE ON THOSE TWO ITEMSPLEASE
HAPPY TO ALEX ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO APPROVE THE GOVERNMENT'S
PROPOSALS REGARDING REGARDING --
EXPANDS THE FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL.
SECONDS BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
WITHIN A ASSEMBLY VOTE OF THREE
TO TWO AND A SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TO TWO ISSUE TO ADOPTION
OF PLACE HOLDER -- TBL REGARDING
AB EIGHTY FIVE REALIGNMENT
PROPOSALS.
IT'S BEEN MOVED ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
FIVE TWO ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF
FOUR TO ONE COMPROMISED KERRY'S
ISSUE NINE PROP FIFTY SIX
SUPPLEMENTAL PROVIDER RATE.
THERE'S A COMPROMISE YES ON PROP
FIFTY SIX A FEW KEY ITEMS FIRST
IS THE COMPROMISING FOODS FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
FUNDING FOR SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS TO PEDIATRIC SUB ACUTE
FACILITIES.
SECOND IS THIRTEEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING FOR
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS FOR
COMMUNITY BASED ADULT SERVICES.
THIRD IS FIVE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING FOR NON
EMERGENCY MEDICAL TRANSPORTATION
PROVIDERS FOR THIS TWO MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING FOR PEDIATRIC
HOSPITAL BASED PHYSICIAN
SERVICES.
AND FIFTY IS THAT THERE'S NO
REMOVALOF THE STATUTORY CAPS
FOR CLINICAL LABORATORIES OR
DURABLE MEDICAL EQUIPMENT.
SENATOR MORE LOCK THE QUEUE
MANAGER IT'S JUST A QUESTION I
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED TWO POINT
TWO BILLION FOR SEPARATING
CREASES [inaudible]
AND THAT'S NOT INCLUDED AT ALL
OR IS THIS ON TOP OF THE TWO
POINT TWO WE WERE I'M NOT CLEAR.
IF POINT TWO OF OUR FOR OVERALL
SUPPLEMENT DO WANNA SPEAKS AGAIN
YES -- RYAN MILLER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE OVERALL SPENDING
LEVEL IS ACTUALLY -- JUST ABOUT
THE SAME FROM A REVISION TO THE
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE -- THE
DIFFERENCE IS THAT -- THE
COMPROMISE FUNDS THE OCC --
EXPANSION OF OPTICAL BENEFITS
OUT OF THE GENERAL FUND RATHER
THAN FROM PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX
FUNDS.
AND THESE SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS --
ESSENTIALLY BACK FILL THE
DIFFERENCE SO THE SPENDING IS IS
ESSENTIALLY THE SAME FROM THE
MAYOR VISION.
SO EN OUR ORIGINAL PASSED THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED TWO POINT TWO
BILLION.
WITH SEVEN HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
POINT FIVE MILLION PROP FIFTY
SIX FOR SUPPLEMENT RATE
INCREASES AND THAT'S IN PLACE.
AND THIS IS ON TOP OF THAT NO
THE THIS IS ACTUALLY JUST --
BACK FILLING AGAIN FOR A A PART
OF OUR MAYOR VISION PROPOSAL
THAT WAS MOVED TO THE GENERAL
FUND.
SO THESE -- PAYMENTS THAT ARE
OUTLINED IN THE AGENDA REPLACE
THE OPTICAL BENEFIT EXPANSION
WHICH WERE INSTEAD DOING FROM A
DIFFERENT FUND SOURCE ALRIGHT.
THANK YOU. FOR THE CLARIFICATION --
SIR ANY OBJECTION TO TAKING A
SINGLE VOTE FOR ALL THE ITEMS IS.
LISTED UNDER ISSUE.
NINE CENA I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION.
THANK YOU WITH ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
FIVE TWO ZERO AND THE SENATE
VOTE OF THREE TWO ZERO
COMPROMISED.
IF YOU TEN PROP FIFTY SIX ONE
TIME INVESTMENT THERE'S A
COMPROMISE IS COMPROMISE ADOPTS
THE SENATE VERSION TERMS OF THE
FUNDING LEVELS AND ALSO INCLUDES
PLACE HOLDER BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE.
AND THIS IS TO COLLABORATE ON
THE DEVELOPMENT OF TRAUMA
SCREENING TRAINING CURRICULUM
WITH FAIRIES ACCREDITED
PROFESSIONALS AND AND ENTITIES.
THANK YOU ALL ENTERTAIN A MOTION
SALUTE.
WHAT THE ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE
TO ZERO IN THE SAN ANTONIO? FIVE
ZERO COMPROMISE KERRY'S ISSUE
ELEVEN RESTORATION OF MEDI CAL
OPTIONAL BENEFITS THERE'S A
COMPROMISE YES SAYS MY COLLEAGUE
WAS BRIEFLY REFERRING TO THIS
INCLUDE SEVENTEEN POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR.
AND FORTY POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING TO RESTORE
OPTIONAL MEDICAL BENEFITS
INCLUDING AUDIOLOGY INCONTINENCE
CREAMS AND WATCHES OPTICAL
BENEFITS PODIATRY AND SPEECH
THERAPY.
THANK YOU ALL ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO MOVE SECOND CENTER MORE A LOT.
JUST A CLARIFICATION THE ONLY
DIFFERENCE IS THAT YOU HAVE NOT
INCLUDED CHIROPRACTIC FROM YOUR
ORIGINAL PROPOSAL. FOR FROM THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE CORRECT.
YES THAT'S THE DOT IS YES YES
THANK YOU.
THERE'S BEEN -- A MOTION --
WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO AND THE SENATE VOTE OF FIVE
TWO ZERO COMPROMISED CAREY.
ISSUE THIRTEEN THE MOTION IS
ASSEMBLY VERSION ON THE NON
WHOLE PERSON CARE COUNTIES
FUNDING.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND
ASSEMBLY VOTE UP. FIVE TWO ZERO
A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
ASSEMBLY VERSION CARE.
ISSUE FOURTEEN STRENGTHENING
FISCAL ESTIMATES AND CASH FLOW
MONITORING -- THE SENATE VERSION
IS PROPOSED ANYTHING YOU WANT TO
ADD TO THAT.
BASICALLY THIS IS APPROVING THE
GOVERNOR IS A PROPOSAL BUT IT
ALSO INCLUDES SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE -- AND
ESTABLISHES LEGISLATIVE AND
ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF WORKING
GROUP TO IMPROVE THIS ESTIMATE
WHICH WE KNOW IS OF CONCERN TO
MANY EXCELLENT.
HELLO TO THE MOTION.
BUT ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TO ZERO
THE COMPROMISE KERRY'S.
ISSUE FIFTEEN MANAGE CARE
SANCTIONS TBL CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE YES THE MAIN ITEM
HERE IS PLACE HOLDER BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE ABOUT POVIDES CONTRACT
EXEMPTIONS FOR EXTERNAL QUALITY
REVIEW ORGANIZATION AND OUTRAGE
CONTRACTS. TO IMPROVE PREVENTIVE
SERVICES FOR KIDS IN MEDI CAL.
THE BALANCE OF WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED IN TERMS
OF ITS MEDICAID MANAGED CARE
SECTIONS TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
WILL BE DEFERRED TO FUTURE
POLICY DISCUSSION.
OUR TO THE MOTION [inaudible]
SECOND.
WITH ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TO
ZERO SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO COMPROMISE [inaudible]
KYRIE'S.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE INTO A
SERIES ISSUE SIXTEEN THROUGH
TWENTY TWO THAT -- AND ACTUALLY
THE TWENTY THREE I'M MORE
ACCEPTING ONE HOUSES VERSION
OVER THE OTHER.
SO ISSUE SIXTEEN ASSISTED LIVING
WAIVER EXPANSION THE MOTION OF
THE ASSEMBLY VERSION.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE
TWO ZERO SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO THE SILLY VERSION KERRY'S
ISSUE SEVENTEEN EXPAND DESPERATE
TO OPIOIDS AND OTHER DRUGS
SENATE VERSION IS THE MOTION AND
ASSEMBLY VOTE OUT. FIVE TWO ZERO
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
SENATE VERSION KERRY'S.
ISSUE EIGHTEEN SUBSTANCE USE
COUNTS AS AN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS ASSEMBLY VERSION IS
THE MOTION WITH AN ASSEMBLY
PHOTO FIVE TWO ZERO A SENATE
VOTE OF FIVE TO ZERO ISSUE
NINETEEN EXTENSION OF MEDI CAL
FOR POST PART OF MENTAL HEALTH.
THE SENATE VERSION IS THE MOTION
FOR ASSEMBLY.
VOTE OF FIVE TO ZERO A SENATE
VOTE OF FOUR TWO ZERO SENATE
VERSION KERRY'S.
ISSUE TWENTY CHILDREN'S CRISIS
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS ASSEMBLY
VERSION IS THE MOTION WITH
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TO ZERO A
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
ASSEMBLY VERSION KERRY'S ISSUE
TWENTY ONE HEALTH IN ROMAN
NAVIGATORS.
ASSEMBLY VERSION IS THE MOTION
WITH AN ASSEMBLY PHOTO. THREE
TWO ONE AND THE SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TO TWO ASSEMBLY VERSION
KERRY'S ISSUE TWENTY TWO
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY TRANSITION
SENATE VERSION IS THE MOTION
WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE UP. FIVE
TWO ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE
TWO ZERO SENATE VERSION KERRY'S
ISSUE TWENTY THREE FRIDAY NIGHT
LIFE FUNDING.
SENATE VERSION IS THE MOTION
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OUT. THREE
TO TWO AND A SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TO TWO SENATE VERSION
KERRY'S ISSUE TWENTY FOUR CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS THERE IS
A CONFERENCE COMPROMISE.
FINANCE THIS COMPROMISE IS TEN
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND FOR
EACH OF THE NEXT THREE YEARS
THANK YOU THAT'S THE MOTION
WITHIN ASSEMBLY BOTHA. FIVE TWO
ZERO A SET OF SOME SENATE VOTE
OF FIVE TWO ZERO THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISES ACCEPTED.
ISSUE TWENTY FIVE IDEOLOGY
LIAISON THERE'S A CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE I'LL BRIEFLY LET MY
COLLEAGUE EXPLAINED THANK YOU --
SO THE ASSEMBLY HAD PROPOSED A
POSITION TO SERVE AS A LIAISON
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES -- THE COMPROMISES --
FOR DH CS TWO USES EXISTING
RESOURCES TO IMPROVE ITS WORK
WITH THIS GROUP [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LET THAT BE THE MOTION WITH AN
ASSEMBLY VOTE UP. FIVE TWO ZERO
A SENATE VOTE -- FIVE TWO ZERO
THE COMPROMISE KERRY'S ISSUE
TWENTY SIX COUNTY OF RESIDENCE --
S. U. D. TREATMENT DISPUTE THE
MOTION IS THE SENATE VERSION
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE UP. THREE
TO ONE AND A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE
TWO ZERO THE SENATE VERSION IS
ACCEPTED.
ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN HOSPITAL
REIMBURSEMENT FOR NEW HIGH COST
DRUGS THE MOTION IS THE SENATE
VERSION WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE --
THREE TWO ONE AND THE SENATE
BODO. FIVE TWO ZERO SEVEN
VERSION IS ACCEPTED.
ISSUE TWENTY EIGHT VIRTUAL
DENTAL HOMES CLARIFY LANGUAGE
THE SENATE VERSION IS THE MOTION
WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE OUT. THREE
TWO ONE AND A SENATE VOTE OF
FIVE TWO ZERO SENATE VERSION IS
ACCEPTED.
MOVE INTO THE PART OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES MENTAL HEALTH
OVERSIGHT SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION ISSUE
TWENTY NINE EARLY PSYCHOSIS
TREATMENT AND RESEARCH.
THE ASSEMBLY VERSION IS THE
MOTION WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OUT.
FIVE TWO ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF
FIVE TWO ZERO ASSEMBLY VERSION
IS ACCEPTED.
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUE THIRTY SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASE PREVENTION
FUNDING THERE IS A COMPROMISE.
YES AND THIS COMPROMISES FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING GENERAL
FUND AS WELL AS THE ADOPTION A
PLACE HOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU THAT IS THE MOTION.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTO. FIVE ZERO
IN THE SENATE VOTE UP FIVE TWO
ZERO THE COMPROMISE KYRIE'S
ISSUE THIRTY ONE COMPREHENSIVE
HIV PREVENTION RESOURCES THERE'S
A COMPROMISE YES HERE ALSO --
ADOPTION OF TRIP PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND
FINALLY DOLLARS ON GOING GENERAL
FUND THAT IS THE MOTION WITHIN
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
AND A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO COMPROMISED KYRIE'S.
ISSUE THIRTY TO HEPATITIS C.
PREVENTION FUNDING THERE IS A
COMPROMISE SAME STRUCTURE ON
HERE AS WELL.
THANK YOU THAT IS THE MOTION
WITH AN ASSEMBLY PHOTO FIVE ZERO
LISTENING VOTE OF THREE TO TWO
THE COMPROMISE KERRY'S ISSUE
THIRTY THREE ALZHEIMER'S EARLY
DETECTION AND DIAGNOSIS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THERE IS A COMPROMISE YES THIS
IS ONE TIME FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND FOR ALZHEIMER'S
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THANK YOU THAT IS THE MOTION.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OUT FIVE
TWO ZERO AND THE SENATE VOTE OF
FIVE TWO ZERO THE COMPROMISE
SCARY'S.
ISSUE THIRTY FOR SAFE COSMETICS
PROGRAM FUNDING THE MOTION IS
SENATE VERSION WITH AN ASSEMBLY
VOTO. THREE TO ONE AND A SENATE
VOTE OF THREE TWO TWO SENATE
VERSION KERRY'S.
ISSUE THIRTY FIVE LESBIAN
BISEXUAL IN QUEER WOMEN'S HEALTH
THE MOTION IS SENATE VERSION THE
ASSEMBLY VOTE IS. THREE ZERO THE
SENATE VERSION IS. THREE TO ONE
THE SENATE VERSION IS ACCEPTED.
ISSUE THIRTY SIX CALIFORNIA
IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY ASSEMBLY
VERSION IS THE MOTIONS ASSEMBLY
VOTE UP. FIVE TWO ZERO AND IT'S
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
ASSEMBLY VERSION IS ACCEPTED.
ISSUE THIRTY SEVEN INTEGRITY OF
HEALTH CARE FACILITY INSPECTIONS
THE ASSEMBLY VERSION IS THE
MOTION WITH ASSEMBLY VOTE UP.
FIVE ZERO AND THE SENATE VOTE OF
FIVE ZERO ASSEMBLY VERSION IS
ACCEPTED.
ISSUE THIRTY EIGHT MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES REDUCTION THERE IS A
COMPROMISE EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME.
THAT IS THE MOTION WITHIN
ASSEMBLY VOTO. FIVE TWO ZERO A
SENATE VOTE OF THREE TO TWO THE
COMPROMISE KERRY'S.
ISSUE THIRTY NINE SICKLE CELL
DISEASE CENTERS OF EXCELLENCE
ASSEMBLY VERSION IS THE MOTION
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE UP. FIVE
TWO ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE
TWO ZERO ASSEMBLY VERSION IS
ACCEPTED.
IF YOU FORTY PARKINSON'S
REGISTRY FUNDING THE SENATE
VERSION IS THE MOTION WITH AN
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO A
SENATE VOTE OF FOUR TO ONE THE
SENATE VERSION IS ACCEPTED.
HERE ISSUE FORTY ONE PEER
NAVIGATORS IN HARM REDUCTION
PROGRAMS ASSEMBLY VERSION IS THE
MOTION WITH THE ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
FIVE TWO ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TO TWO ASSEMBLY VERSION IS
ACCEPTED.
ISSUE FORTY TWO SYRINGE ACCESS
PROGRAM AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY
VERSION IS THE MOTION WELL THAT
ASSEMBLY VOTE UP. FIVE TWO ZERO
A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
ASSEMBLY VERSION IS ACCEPTED.
ISSUE FORTY THREE CALIFORNIA
pINFANT HEALTH ASSEMBLY VERSION
IS THE MOTION WITH AN ASSEMBLY
VOTE OFIVE TO ZERO A SENATE
VOTE. FIVE TWO ZERO ASSEMBLY
VERSION IS ENACTED ISSUE FORTY
FOUR CHILDHOOD LEAD POISONING
PREVENTION I. T. PROJECT.
ASSEMBLY VERSION IS THE MOTION
WITH ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TO
ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE ZERO
THE ASSEMBLY VERSION IS ACCEPTED.
IF YOU FORTY FIVE MIDDLE HELP
TRIAGE GRANT THERE'S A
COMPROMISE.
THAT'S CORRECT ON THIS ISSUE
THAT COMPROMISE CONSISTS OF
THREE ITEMS WHICH IS TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FUND FOR SCHOOL MENTAL
HEALTH PARTNERSHIPS THAT'S
ONGOING.
AND THE SECOND TWO ITEMS ARE
ALSO FROM THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FUND BUT BOTH ONE TIME
IT'S FORTY MILLION DOLLARS -- IN
ONE TIME FUNDING FOR THE SAME
PARTNERSHIPS AS WELL AS TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION.
THANK YOU THAT IS THE MOTION --
WHAT THEY ASSEMBLY PHOTO? FIVE
TWO ZERO SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TO
ZERO THE COMPROMISES ACCEPTED
ISSUE FORTY SIX COMMISSION
TRANSPARENCY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE STAFFING.
THERE'S A CONFERENCE COMPROMISED
THE RATE THE MAY REVISION WITH
NO FUNDING.
CORRECT.
WITH IT IS THAT THAT IS THE
MOTION WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
FIVE TO ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF
FIVE TWO ZERO MOTION CARRIES.
ISSUE FORTY SEVEN COMMISSION
MEMBERSHIP TECHNICAL CLEANUP
LANGUAGE -- WE TOOK ACTION ON
THAT ALREADY THE NEXT TWO ITEMS
ISSUE FORTY NINE HOSPITAL POLICE
OFFICER ACADEMY THERE'S A
COMPROMISE YES THIS WOULD BE
ADOPTING THE SENATE ACTION
APPROVING THE GOVERNOR'S
HOSPITAL POLICE OFFICER ACADEMY
RESOURCES ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
AS WELL AS ADOPTING PLACE HOLDER
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE REQUIRING
AN ANNUAL REPORT ON THAT
WORKFORCE.
THAT IS THE MOTION.
WITHIN ASSEMBLY.
VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO HAVE A
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
COMPROMISED KERRY'S ISSUE FIFTY
VOCATIONAL SERVICES INPATIENT
MINIMUM WAGE SENATE VERSION IS
THE MOTION WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE.
FIVE ZERO IN THE SENATE VODA.
FIVE ZERO THE SENATE VERSION
KERRY.
ISSUE FIFTY ONE PREMIUM
AFFORDABILITY ASSISTANCE AND
MANDATE PENALTY THERE IS A
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE.
YES -- THERE A COUPLE ITEMS HERE
FIRST IS APPROVAL OF THAT
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED SUBSIDY
LEVELS IN THE NAY REVISION
BUDGET.
SECOND IS AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE DOLLARS OVER
THE NEXT THREE YEARS -- AND THAT
WILL BE USED TO TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE STATE
SUBSIDIES TO STATE SUBSIDIES TO
INDIVIDUALS BELOW 110038% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL AND THEN
THE BALANCE THAT FUNDING WOULD --
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL SUBSIDIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS BETWEEN FOUR HUNDRED
AND 6100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL IN ADDITION THE COMPROMISE
INCLUDES PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE -- CHANGING
MODIFYING THE GOVERNOR'S
LANGUAGE TO SUNSET EXEMPTION
FROM THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURES ACT AFTER THREE YEARS.
REQUIRING THE FTP TO REPORTS
STATISTICS ON THE MANDATE
PENALTY AS WELL AS CLARIFYING
ANY EXEMPTIONS FROM MANDATE
PENALTY.
THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISES THE
MOTIONS WITH AN ASSEMBLY VODA.
FORTY ONE AND THE SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TWO TWO THE COMPROMISE
KERRY'S.
SO LET'S DO A VOTE AGAIN ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE FOR THE MOTION THE
TO ACCEPT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE ON PREMIUM
AFFORDABILITY SYSTEMS AND
MANDATE.
THE ASSEMBLY VOTE HE IS. THREE
TO ONE RECENTLY THOUGH IT IS
[inaudible]
THREE TO ONE YES.
COLLEAGUES WERE IN -- WILL BE ON
TO HEALTH ISSUES THAT ARE NOT IN
CONFERENCE.
STARTING WITH CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES
STAFFING RESOURCES FOR
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS. TO
DECIDE ON THE PROPOSED ACTION
WOULD APPROVE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED RESOURCES FOR HHS
AGENCY -- EXCEPT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S REQUESTED DEPUTY TO
CRACK DIRECTOR FOCUSED ON HEALTH
REFORM WOULD DEFER CONSIDERATION
OF THAT POSITION.
IN ADDITION THIS PROPOSED ACTION
WOULD ADOPT PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE ESTABLISHING THE
OFFICE OF THE SURGEON GENERAL --
AND ESTABLISHING THAT POSITIONS
OF AUTHORITY AND
RESPONSIBILITIES AND MAKING
CERTAIN GENERAL APPOINTEES AFTER
THE START OF THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR SUBJECT TO SENATE
CONFIRMATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT IS THE MOTION.
THE ASSEMBLY -- VOTE IS. FIVE
TWO ZERO THE SENATE VOTE IS.
FOUR TWO ONE COMPROMISES
ACCEPTED CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY CAL
QUALITY CARE DOT ORG THERE'S A
COMPROMISE.
YES AND HERE IT IS THE MAYOR OF
THIS PROPOSAL NO FUNDING THANK
YOU THAT IS THE MOTION WITHIN
ASSEMBLY VOTE. FIVE TWO ONE IN
THE SENATE VOTE OF WHAT DOES ADD
SOMEBODY TO CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
FIVE TWO ZERO YEAH.
AND THE SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO COMPROMISED KERRY'S.
OFSHE PIT INVESTMENT WORKFORCE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING THERE IS
A COMPROMISE YES FOR THE WHAT
PROGRAM SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
OVERALL THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND ONE TIME
AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND
ONE TIME.
IN ADDITION THIS COMPROMISE
ADOPTS PLACEHOLDER BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE REQUIRING A COUNTY
MATCH UP 33% WHEN STATE FUNDS
ARE SPENT.
AND THESE RESOURCES ARE DESIGNED
TO FUND THE FIVE YEAR WHAT PLAN
FOR THE TAINING A MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS.
THANK YOU THAT IS THE MOTION
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VODA. FIVE ZERO
AND THE SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO COMPROMISED GEARY'S OFSTED
PEDIATRIC RESIDENCY PROGRAM
THERE'S A COMPROMISE THIS IS TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE GENERAL
FUND.
PROGRAMS THAT IS THE MOTION WITH
AN ASSEMBLY VOTE UP FIVE TWO
ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TO
ZERO COMPROMISES ACCEPTED.
POSH BED SEISMIC SAFETY THERE'S
A COMPROMISE YES THIS WOULD
ADOPT PLACEHOLDER TBL EXTENDING
THE FILING DEADLINE FOR SEISMIC
SAFETY COMPLIANCE DOCUMENTS FOR
SPECIFIED HOSPITALS THAT'S THE
MOTION WITH ASSEMBLY VOTE. FIVE
ZERO SENATE VOTE. FIVE ZERO
COMPROMISES ACCEPTED DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES PROP
FIFTY SIX FAMILY PLANNING
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT.
THERE'S A COMPROMISE YES HERE
IT'S THE MAYOR VERSION PROPOSAL
WITH NO TRAILER BILL THANK YOU
THAT IS THE MOTION WITH AN
ASSEMBLY VODA. FOUR TO ONE AND A
SENATE VOTE A THREE TWO ZERO
COMPROMISE ACCEPTED DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES ASTHMA
PREVENTION SERVICES THERE'S A
COPPER MINE YES HERE IT'S
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR THE SERVICES.
THANK YOU THAT'S THE MOTION THAT
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TO ZERO
COMPROMISE ACCEPTED.
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES FREE CLINIC OF SIMI
VALLEY IS A COPPER MINES YES
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THIS
CLINIC.
THAT IS THE MOTION WITH ASSEMBLY
VOTE. FIVE ZERO A SENATE VOTE.
THREE TO TWO MOTION CARRIES
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH
FIRST AID.
THERE IS A COMPROMISE NO MAY.
THERE'S A COMPROMISE MAY WE
VISION WITH NO FUNDING THAT IS
THE MOTION WAS AN ASSEMBLY VOTE.
FIVE TWO ZERO AND THE SENATE
VOTE A FIVE TWO ZERO COMPROMISE
ACCEPTED.
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
INFECTIOUS DISEASE FUNDING IS A
COPPER MINES YES THE COMPROMISES
THE ADOPTION A PLACEHOLDER BBL
BUDGET A LANGUAGE MERGING THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE PROPOSED
LANGUAGE.
THAT IS THE MOTION WITH AN
ASSEMBLY PHOTO. FIVE TWO ZERO IN
THE SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
MOTION CARRIES DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH INTERNATIONAL AIDS
CONFERENCE THERE IS A COMPROMISE
YES TWO MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR THIS CONFERENCE.
THAT'S THE MOTION WITH ASSEMBLY
VOTE UP FIVE TWO ZERO SENATE
VOTE OF THREE TWO ZERO
COMPROMISE ACCEPTED.
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH FARM
WORKER HEALTH STUDY THERE'S A
COPPER MINE YES ONE AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR THE STUDY.
THAT'S THE MOTIONS WITH AN
ASSEMBLY VOTE -- FIVE TWO ZERO
AND A SENATE VOTE OF THREE TWO
ZERO IT KERRY.
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
VALLEY FEVER INSTITUTE.
THERE'S A COMPROMISE YES THIS
WOULD BE TWO MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THIS
INSTITUTE WHICH IS AT THE KERN
MEDICAL CENTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
ASSEMBLY VODA. FIVE TWO ZERO
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
THAT THAT'S FOR JEAN FULLER FIT
INTO THE OFFICE.
YES MOTION CARRIES MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION HUGE
DROP IN CENTERS THERE'S A
COMPROMISE YES THIS IS FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME -- FROM
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND
AND THESE ARE FOR THESE LOCAL
CENTERS THAT PROVIDE INTEGRATED
USE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
THANK YOU THAT IS THE MOTION
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE UP. FIVE
TWO ZERO AND SENATE VOTO. FOUR
TWO ZERO CALIFORNIA HEALTH
BENEFIT EXCHANGE SINGLE PREMIUM
INVOICE THE COMPROMISES MAY
REVISE WITH NO TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
THAT IS THE MOTION WITHIN
ASSEMBLY VOTO. FIVE TWO ZERO IN
THE SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
IT CARRIES.
THEIR VARIOUS PROGRAM
SUSPENSIONS IS A COMPROMISE YOU
AND TALK ABOUT THOSE GUYS SO --
AFTER AS DISCUSSED AFTER INITIAL
SUNSET PROPOSAL AFTER
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE LEGISLATURE --
WE'VE COMPROMISED ON THE LIST OF
PROGRAMS BELOW GOING TO RESIST
PENSION PROCESS -- AND THEIR
SEVEN ITEMS LISTED BEFORE YOU --
BUT IF THE DIRECTOR OF FINANCE
DETERMINES -- IN THAT YEAR THE
GENERAL FUND REVENUES ARE
PROJECTED TO EXCEED EXPENDITURES
FOR THE FOLLOWING FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AND THE DIRECTOR WILL EXTEND
THOSE PROGRAMS BY ANOTHER YEAR.
EXCELLENT.
THAT IS THE MOTION.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE
TWO ZERO AND THE SENATE VOTE OF
THREE ZERO MOTION CARRIES.
MOVING ON TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING.
ISSUE FIFTY TWO SINGER NUTRITION
PROGRAMS AS A CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE YES SAID THIS WOULD
BE SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUAL FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT HOLD ON ONE
SECOND PLEASE.
WE DEVOTED ON GRAHAM SUSPENSIONS.
IT WAS A NICK LIST ITEM -- THE
CONFERENCE AGREEMENT -- DEFINING
WHAT IT MEANS TO SUSPEND AND
INVESTMENT SO IT TALKS ABOUT.
WILL BE SUSPENDED EFFECTIVE
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE NOT A PROBLEM
[inaudible]
SOMETHING.
WE WANT TO CLARIFY.
THE VOTE TAKEN ON ISSUE THIRTY
NINE THE SICKLE CELL DISEASE
CENTERS OF EXCELLENCE WE
ACCEPTED THE ASSEMBLY VERSION
[inaudible]
WITH ADDITIONAL.
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE SAID
ADDRESS.
AS OPPOSED TO TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
IT WILL BE B. B. L.. FOR THE
ASSEMBLY VERSION AGAIN ISSUE.
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU MOVING ON
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING ISSUE
FIFTY TO THE SENIOR NUTRITION
PROGRAMS THERE'S A COMPROMISE
YES IT IS TO BE SEVENTEEN AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
FROM THE GENERAL FUND FOR THIS
PROGRAM -- WITH THE SUSPENSION
AT THE END OF CALENDAR YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THANK YOU CAN
YOU DEFINE WHAT THE OUR NEW TERM
SUSPENSION MEANS WE'RE CLEAR
ABOUT THAT YES SO -- THIS WOULD
FOLLOW THAT SAME PROCEDURE
OUTLINED BEFORE PERFECT.
OUR THAT IS THE MOTION WITH THE
ASSEMBLY VOTE UP [inaudible]
FIVE TWO ZERO AND A SENATE VOTE --
FIVE TWO ZERO COMPROMISE KERRY'S
ISSUE FIFTY THREE THERE ARE
NUMEROUS ADDITIONAL ADJUSTMENTS
WOULD YOU PLEASE YES LAUREN
PARTICULAR OUT FIRST IS THE
APPROVAL OF FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY TO SUPPORT
THE EIGHTY ARE SEE NO WRONG DOOR
MODEL.
THAT THIS WOULD ALSO HAVE A
SUSPENSION AT THE END OF
CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND SECOND IS ONE TIME FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE DIGNITY
AT HOME FALL PREVENTION PROGRAM --
THAT IS THE MOTION WITH AND
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TO ZERO
SEVEN VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
CONFERENCE THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED THEORIES.
MOVING ON TO THE CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE ISSUE FIFTY
FOUR FUNDING FOR ADMIN SUPPORT
THE MOTION IS ASSEMBLY VERSION
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTO FIVE TWO
ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE FOUR
TWO ZERO MOTION CARE IS FOR THE
FAMILY.
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION ISSUE FIFTY FIVE
STABILIZING SERVICES FOR
CONSUMERS THERE'S A COMPROMISE
YES SO A COUPLE OF ITEMS OVER
HERE FIRST IS THAT THE
CONFERENCE COMPROMISED ADOPTED
FUNDING LEVELS.
ABOVE WHAT THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED
IN THE NAY REVISION IN
PARTICULAR TWENTY FIVE NINE
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
OUT YEARS AGAIN WITH THE
SUSPENSION AT THE END OF
CALENDAR YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE PURPOSE OF
THIS FUNDING OR HOW IT IS
DESIGNED IS ALSO HAS ALSO OF ALL
SINCE THE MAY REVISION -- HEADED
PROVIDES A MORE BROAD BASED
APPROACH TO THE RATE INCREASES
FOR SERVICE PROVIDERS --
COMPARED TO THE MAY REVISIONS
THAT WERE THOSE RATE INCREASES
WOULD BE EFFECTIVE ON JANUARY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY THE
PROPOSED ACTION ALSO APPROVED
THE ASSEMBLY VERSION WITH REGARD
TO THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE QUIRK --
APPROVED GOVERNOR'S MAY RUSSIAN
PROPOSALIN TERMS OF THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE -- AND DENVER
SINCE THE PRIOR ACTION OF BOTH
HOUSES WITH REGARD TO THE HAVE
TO DOING POLICY AND WITH REGARD
TO OTHER SERVICES.
THANK YOU THAT IS THE MOTION
CENTER MORE LOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR LIKE THE
BY FOR KATE ONE AND THREE AND
TWO AND FOUR PLEASE.
SO WE CAN TAKE TO VOTE TWENTY
THREE TOGETHER IN TWO AND FOUR
TOGETHER [inaudible]
PLEASE.
SUCH WILL BE THE ORDER THIRTEEN
NIELSEN IS THAT THE SAME REQUEST.
PERFECT ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS SO
THE MOTION WILL BE ON ITEMS ONE
AND THREE WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE
OF FIVE TWO ZERO AND THE SENATE
VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO THE SECOND
MOTION WILL BE FOR ITEMS TWO AND
FOUR THE ASSEMBLY.
BOTH WILL BE THREE TO TWO THE
SENATE VOTE WILL BE.
THREE TO TWO COMPROMISE IS
ACCEPTED.
MOVING TO DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES ISSUE
FIFTY SIX REGIONAL CENTER
TRANSPARENCY AND OVERSIGHT TBL
THERE'S A COMPROMISE YES SIR
HERE THE TBL IS DESIGNED TO
ADDRESS REGIONAL CENTER
TRANSPARENCY ENOUGH SEC.
THANK YOU THAT IS THE MOTION.
WHAT THE ASSEMBLY VOTE -- THREE
ZERO AND THE SENATE VOTE OF FIVE
TWO ZERO ISSUE FIFTY SEVEN
SAFETY NET SUPPORT THE MOTION IS
SENATE VERSION WITH AN ASSEMBLY
VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO AND THE
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
SEVEN VERSION KERRY'S.
ISSUE FIFTY EIGHT INCREASE
INSPECTIONS OF CHILD CARE
CENTERS THERE'S A COMPROMISE YES
SIR HERE THE COMPROMISES THE
ADOPTION OF PLACEHOLDER TBL
STATING THE LEGISLATURE'S INTENT
THAT HE'S INSPECTIONS OCCUR
ANNUALLY.
THANK YOU THAT WILL BE THE
MOTION.
THE ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO AND THE SENATE VOTE OF FIVE
TO ZERO COMPROMISED KERRY'S
ISSUE FIFTY NINE BRINGING
FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM -- THE
MOTION IS THE ASSEMBLY VERSION --
INCLUDING THE ADOPTION OF
PLACEHOLDER TBL CORRECT.
THE ASSEMBLY VODA. FIVE TWO ZERO
IN A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO MOTION CARRIES.
ISSUE SIXTY CAL WORKS HOMES
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THE MOTION IS
ASSEMBLY VERSIONS AND ASSEMBLY
VOTE UP. FIVE TWO ZERO SENATE
VOTE OF FIVE TO ZERO ASSEMBLY.
ACCEPTED ISSUE SIXTY ONE COUNTY
ADMIN FUNDING FOR CAL FRESH
EXPANSION THERE'S A COMPROMISE
YES OF THE COMPROMISES TO
APPROVE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
BUT ALSO ADOPT PLACEHOLDER TBL
AS WELL AS B. B. L..
THE PLACEHOLDER TBL WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON UPDATING
THE CALIFORNIA BUDGETING
METHODOLOGY AND THE B. B. L.
WOULD REQUIRE COUNTY WELFARE
AGENCIES IN THE DEPARTMENT. TO
SUBMIT AVAILABLE DATA TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON A
MONTHLY BASIS TO ILLUSTRATE
WORKLOAD AND COST TRENDS THAT
ARE ASSOCIATED WITH ENROLLMENT
ACTIVITIES.
SUCH WILL BE THE MOTION.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE UP FIVE
TWO ZERO SEVEN VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO COMPROMISES ACCEPTED ISSUE
SIXTY TWO SENIOR.
SENIOR ACCESS TO CAL FRESH
ASSEMBLY VERSION IS THE MOTION
WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE UP. FIVE
TWO ZERO SEVEN PHOTO. FIVE TWO
ZERO SILLY VERSION KERRY'S ISSUE
SIXTY THREE ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES IN THE PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATION GUARDIAN ****
CONSERVATOR TRAINING SENATE
VERSION IS THE MOTION FOR THE
SIMPLY VOTE A FIVE TWO ZERO A
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
SENATE VERSION KERRY'S ITEM.
SIXTY FOUR SUPPLEMENTAL SECURITY
INCOME SS HE GRANTS ASSEMBLY
VERSION IS THE MOTION WITH AN
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE ZERO AND
THE SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
THE LIVER IS ACCEPTED.
ISSUE SIXTY FIVE TRACKING OF
CHILD AND ADOLESCENT NEEDS IN
STRENGTH.
INSURANCE NEEDS AND STRENGTHS
TOOL EXPENDITURES ASSEMBLY
VERSION IS THE MOTION WITH
ASSEMBLY VOTO. FIVE TWO ZERO THE
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TO ZERO SOME
REVERSION KERRY'S.
IF YOU SIXTY SIX TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PLUS PROGRAM THERE'S A
COMPROMISE YES THIS IS THE
SENATE VERSION ON DSS -- BUT I
BELIEVE THIS WILL BE COVERED AND
THE NEXT.
SET OF ITEMS.
THAT IS THE MOTION WITH AN
ASSEMBLY VERY VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO SEVEN PHOTO [inaudible]
FIVE ZERO IF YOU SIXTY SEVEN
CHAO WILL FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSING PROGRAM THERE'S A
COMPROMISE YES THE COMPROMISE IS
EIGHT POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY WITH THE
SUSPENSION AT THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THAT IS THE MOTION
WITH ASSEMBLY VOTE OUT. FIVE
ZERO SEVEN PHOTO. THREE TWO TWO
ISSUE SIXTY EIGHT CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP THE
MOTION IS ASSEMBLY VERSION WITH
AN ASSEMBLY VOTE UP. THREE TO
ONE AND A SENATE VOTE OF THREE
TWO ASSEMBLY VERSION KERRY'S
ISSUE SIXTY NINE OTHER
ADJUSTMENTS AS A COMPROMISE YES
Q. ITEMS HERE FIRST IS TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND. TO BE USED OVER
THE THREE YEARS FOR THE YOUTH
AND FAMILY CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE.
AND THE SECOND IS APPROVAL OF
THE ASSEMBLY ACTION WITH REGARD
TO THE IN WHEN CONGREGATIONS
UNITED FOR CHANGE.
THAT WILL BE THE MOTIONS WITH AN
ASSEMBLY INVOLVED -- THREE ZERO
IN THE SENATE VOTE OF THREE TO
TWO MOVING INTO THE NOT IN
CONFERENCE LIVE.
UNDER HUMAN SERVICES DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES CAL WORKS
ASSET TESTS THERE'S A COMPROMISE
YES THIS COMPROMISE RAISES THE
CAL WORKS ASSET WHEN THEY TO TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE MOTOR
VEHICLE EXEMPTION. TO TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS THS COMES
AT A COST AT SEVEN AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR TWENTY SEVEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO THIS COMPROMISE ALSO
ADOPTS PLACEHOLDER TBL LANGUAGE
TO IMPLEMENT THESE CHANGES AND
TIES THOSE LIMITS TO INFLATION
FACTORS OVER TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER THIS ONE OFTEN
CAN YOU REMIND US WHAT THE
CURRENT CAL WORKS ASSET LIMIT IS
I BELIEVE GEN YOU SHOULD CONFIRM.
HI JACOB FOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I I DON'T HAVE THE EXACT
NUMBER BUT I THINK IT'S AROUND --
TWENTY TWO THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS WE CAN CONFIRM THAT VICE
WE'VE ALMOST TRIPLE THAT IT
APPEARS IT'S IT IT'S BEEN AT
THAT LEVEL FOR QUITE AWHILE.
THAT THAT I REMEMBER THAT WE HAD
MADE THE CHANGE OKAY SO THAT IS
THE MOTION.
A WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE
TO ZERO AND THE SENATE VOTE OF
FOUR TWO ZERO COMPROMISE KERRY'S
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES RATE
INCREASE AS A COMPROMISE YES
THIS WOULD PROVIDE A COLA
pFACE EXCEPT FOR THAT PORTION PAY
TO FAMILY.
HOMES ARE RESOURCE FAMILIES --
AT A COST OF SIX AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FROM
THE GENERAL FUND THIS WOULD ALSO
SUSPEND AT THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THAT WILL BE THE
MOTIONS THAT ASSEMBLY VOTE UP.
FIVE TWO ZERO SENATE VOTE OF
FIVE TO ZERO COMPROMISED KERRY'S
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
CAL WORKS EARNED INCOME
DISREGARDED INCOME REPORTING
THRESHOLD IS A COMPROMISE YES SO
THIS WOULD MAKE CHANGES IN THE
EARNED INCOME DISREGARD ANY
INCOME REPORTING THRESHOLD THAT
WERE PREVIOUSLY ADOPTED BY BOTH
HOUSES.
WITH THE ONE EXCEPTION OF THE
INFLATOR FOR THE EARNED INCOME
DISREGARD AND THIS WOULD COME AT
A COST OF SIX POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR. SEVENTY FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE YEAR
AFTER THAT EIGHTY FIVE POINT
SEVEN MILLION TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND NINETY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU THAT WILL BE THE MOTION.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE
TWO ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF FOUR
TWO ZERO COMPROMISED SCARY.
CONTINUING ON OUR NICOLAS
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES I
HSS RELATED ISSUES THERE IS A
COMPROMISE.
YES SO ON THIS ITEM THE FIRST IS
THAT THE PROPOSED ACTION ADOPTS
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WITH
REGARD TO RETENTION COUNTY I HSS
AND WE REQUIREMENT IN THE BUDGET
YEAR.
AS WELL AS ASSOCIATED TBL
LANGUAGE.
THE SECOND ITEM IS TO ADOPT A
PLACEHOLDER TBL THAT SUBJECTS
THE COUNTY TO A FINANCIAL
PENALTY UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES WHEN THE COUNTY
AND THE HSS PROVIDER FAILED TO
REACH AN AGREEMENT ON THE
PROVIDER WAGE INCREASE
NEGOTIATIONS.
PLACEHOLDER TBL WOULD ALSO ALLOW
AYE HSS SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
ENROLL IN AN ELECTRONIC PAYROLL
NO LATER THAN TWELVE MONTHS
AFTER THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
FEDERAL ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION MANDATE.
OR ON NOVEMBER FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND INCLUDES OTHER
ITEMS RELATED TO THESE PAYROLL
CARDS AND FINALLY -- THIS
PROPOSED ACTION APPROVED
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION PROPOSAL
WITH REGARD TO RESTORING THE 7%
ACROSS THE BOARD REDUCTION DIET
JUST A SERVICE HOURS AND THAT
GOES THROUGH DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE MR
OBERNOLTE.
WOULD USE PUT OFF AUTUMN TO
PLEASE. THIRTY MORAL UP.
MINIATURE MASS SPEAK TIED INTO
ABSOLUTELY.
I'M [inaudible]
THE NEGOTIATIONS.
A BETWEEN THE COUNTY AND I HSS.
HAS SORT OF BEEN GOING BACK AND
FORTH.
RECENTLY WAS THE STATE THAT WAS
DOING THE NEGOTIATING AND I
DON'T RECALL COUNTIES PUTTING A
PENALTY ON GETTING.
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES TAKEN CARE
OF SO THIS IS SORT OF NEW IS.
COULD YOU KIND OF EXPLAIN WHERE
THIS CAME FROM [inaudible]
YOUR SPEAK.
BECAUSE TO SERVICES THIS IS
BRIAN -- SORT OF IN ISSUE THAT --
CAME UP A COUPLE YEARS AGO THERE
WAS SOME SOME STATUTORY --
LANGUAGE ADOPTED TO REQUIRE SOME --
UP TO GROUP REQUIRE PROCESS IF --
COUNTIES -- AND THE ORGANIST THE
LABOR ORGANIZATIONS COULDN'T
COME TO AN AGREEMENT.
BOB THIS IS SORT OF EXPANDING ON
THAT -- THAT CURRENT THAT
LANGUAGE AND WE'RE WORKING ON
THE DETAILS OF THIS BUT
ESSENTIALLY THERE -- THE WHAT
THE PROPOSAL IS IS THAT TO THE
EXTENT IF CERTAIN CONDITIONS ARE
MET -- AND THOSE CAN YOU KNOW
THAT THOSE CONDITIONS -- ARE
RELATED -- TO TO YOU KNOW
[inaudible]
DESPITE.
HAVING AN IMPASSE WHERE YOU'VE
GONE THROUGH THE FACT FINDING
PROCESS AND YOU'RE STILL AT AN
IMPASSE.
AND IF I COUNTY DOES NOT --
IMPLEMENT WHAT A THIRD PARTY
FACT FINDER -- HAS DETERMINED
OUR HAS RECOMMENDED THE AND
THERE WOULD BE A PROCESS TO LOOK
AT IMPLEMENTING UP -- IMPOSING A
PENALTY SO -- WE ARE WE
APOLOGIZE WE DON'T WE'RE WORKING
ON THIS -- AS WE SPEAK -- WE
EXPECT TO HAVE SOMETHING SOON
FOR PEOPLE TO REVIEW.
DO YOU HAVE A MODEL.
IT'S BEEN DONE BEFORE -- SO FOR
THIS PROGRAM NOW NOT IN THE I
JUST PROGRAM I CAN'T SPEAK TO
OTHER AREAS OF YEAH.
WE HAVE.
TO LOOK AT THAT BUT IN THIS AREA
THIS.
DODD BUT IT'S NOT BEEN THE CASE.
ALL RIGHT I I JUST THINK IT'S
SORT OF UNIQUE BECAUSE IT'S BEEN
GOING BACK AND FORTH AND SO NOW
WHEN IT'S IN THE COUNTIES COURTS.
THAT WE WE WE KIND OF PUT
SOMETHING HEAVY ON HIM WHEN
THEY'RE READY TRYING.
TO MAKE ENDS MEET SO I I FIND
THAT RATHER ODD THANK YOU
MANAGER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THIRTY NIELSEN.
I'LL JUST ADD TO THIS NOT TO BE
DEBATED HERE TO MUCH BUT THIS
WILL BE AN ISSUE DEPENDING ON
YOUR LANGUAGE THAT I PROBLEM
VIGOROUSLY OPPOSE [inaudible]
PROSPECTIVELY.
AS WELL AS TONIGHT [inaudible]
DANGEROUS PRECEDENT.
THANK YOU WITH THAT THE MOTION
BEFORE YOU ARM WILL INCLUDE
ITEMS. ONE THREE AND FOUR OF THE
PRINTED MOTION.
THAT'S THE MOTION THE VOTE FROM
THE ASSEMBLY AS FIVE TO ZERO THE
VOTE FROM THE SENATE IS. FIVE
TWO ZERO THAT COMPROMISE KERRY'S
OF THE MOTION BEFORE YOU IS TO
ADOPT PLACEHOLDER TBL THAT
SUBJECTS ACCOUNT INTO A
FINANCIAL PENALTY PENALTY UNDER
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES.
THAT'S ISSUE.
TO ASSEMBLY VOTE OF THREE TO TWO
AND A SENATE VOTE.
OF THREE TO TWO THAT COMPROMISE
KERRY'S.
WOULD LIKE TO SAY THE THE GF
PROFESSIONALS FOR MAKING THE
ROOM BEARABLE.
WE APPRECIATE YOU [inaudible]
CONTINUING ON THE NECKLACE ON
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEMS THERE'S A COMPROMISE YES
THIS IS FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND THIRTY
NINE DOLLARS IN THE OUT YEARS
WITH THE SUSPENSION AT THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT IS THE
MOTION WITH AN ASSEMBLY.
VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO IN A
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
COMPROMISE KERRY'S -- DSS OTHER
ADJUSTMENTS AS A COMPROMISE YES
THIS INCLUDES TWO ITEMS FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR THEY'LL GROW FOOD
BANK RELOCATION.
AS WELL AS ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FOR
THE ORANGE COUNTY DIAPER BANK
THANK YOU THAT'S THE MOTION WITH
ASSEMBLY VOTE UP FIVE TWO ZERO
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO FOUR TWO ZERO COMPROMISED
KERRY'S.
DEPARTMENT OF AGING DEPARTMENT
HEALTH CARE SERVICES THE MULTI
PURPOSE SENIOR SERVICES PROGRAM
MSF PETE THERE'S A COMPROMISE
YES FOR THAT PROGRAM FOURTEEN
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FOR A
SUPPLEMENTAL RATE INCREASE FOR
LOCAL AND S. S. P. SITES.
AND THAT CAN BE SPENT OVER THREE
YEARS THAT IS THE MOTION FOR AN
ASSEMBLY VOTE A FIVE TWO ZERO
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
COMPROMISED GEARS APARTMENT OF
AGING ANOTHER ADJUSTMENT THERE'S
A COMPROMISE Q. ITEMS FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE
TIME.
AWAY SENIOR CENTER AS WELL AS
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONE TIME FOR THE SANTA
CLARITA VALLEY SENIOR CENTER
THAT IS THE MOTION WITH AN
ASSEMBLY VOTE OUT. FIVE TWO ZERO
A SENATE VOTE OF FOUR TO ONE THE
COMPROMISE KERRY'S.
THAT'S OKAY.
THAT'S IT.
SO COLLEAGUES WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE A SHORT BREAK -- AND I
WOULD SUGGEST.
THAT WE COME BACK.
AT SEVEN FORTY FIVE THAT'S A
TWENTY MINUTE BREAK THAT WILL
ALLOW STAFF TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THE SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
LANGUAGE THAT'S BEFORE US AND
ALLOW MEMBERS AND STAFF
[inaudible] TO HAVE A BIT OF A
RESPITE IN THE IN THE MEDI
LOWNDES [inaudible]
SO.
CONFEREES AND BUDGET COMMITTEE
STAFF.
MEDI LOUNGE IT WILL BE BACK AT
SEVEN FORTY FIVE HI EVERYBODY --
TOOK FULL ADVANTAGE OF THEIR
SHORT BREAK AND STRETCHED
[inaudible]
CALL HOME.
SAID HI TO MOM KIDS.
STICK YOUR HEAD OUTSIDE GET SOME
FRESH AIR.
I DID NONE OF THE ABOVE -- WE
ARE GOING TO GO TO PUBLIC SAFETY
FIRST.
I SHOULD HAVE ANNOUNCED THAT
BEFOREHAND WERE GONNA GO TO
PUBLIC SAFETY FIRST -- SOME OF
THE FOLKS.
SOME OF THE KEY PERSONNEL THAT
NEED TO BE HERE. FOR THE STATE
ADMINISTRATION INTERNAL
GOVERNMENT DISCUSSION.
ARE IN NEGOTIATIONS AS WE SPEAK
WHO WILL GIVE THEM A LITTLE TIME.
AND TO REALLY GO TO PUBLIC
SAFETY.
AND WE'VE GOT EVERYBODY WE'VE
GOT A FULL HOUSE WE DO
[inaudible]
IF.
SO STARTING WITH PUBLIC SAFETY
CORRECTIONS AND THE JUDICIARY WE
WILL START.
WITH THE ISSUE ONE THE PRISON TO
COMMUNITY PIPELINE PACKAGE.
MR THIS ONE OFTEN.
HE SAID THERE IS A CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE ON THIS ISSUE --
CONSISTING OF FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN THE
BUDGET YEAR AS BALLS ON GOING
I'LL BRIEFLY DESCRIBE THE
ALLOCATION OF THAT FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
GOES TO REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
pCORRECTION SETTINGS THAT ALSO
COMES WITH A PLACEHOLDER TBL
OUTLINING A GRAND PROCESS WITH
THE STEERING COMMITTEE.
THERE'S ALSO THIRTY TWO POINT
NINE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
ADULT REENTRY GRANTS. EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS FOR DJJ
THERAPEUTIC COMMUNITY SEVEN ON A
ONE TIME BASIS FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE CITY OF OAKLAND
AS WELL AS AN ADDITIONAL FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO THE CITY OF
OAKLAND.
AND THOSE ARE FOR A PAROLE
PREPARATION PILOT AS WLL AS RE
ENTRY SUPPORT TO EXIT TO
EXONERATES.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THAT.
IS THE MOTION SO.
SENATOR NIELSEN IF I MAY COULD I
SPLIT OFF OF THE VERY LAST THE
INNOCENCE FIFTY THOUSAND AS A
SEPARATE VOTE.
ARE TO THE CITY VOCAL IN THE
FIFTY THOUSAND PROVIDE REENTRY
SUPPORT TAKES HONOREES YES
PLEASE.
ALL RIGHT.
SO THE MOTION COLLEAGUES WILL BE
TO ACCEPT -- THE ITEMS.
THE CONVERSE COMPROMISE A FIFTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND THE
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS OFFERED
BY CBO SOMETHING CORRECTION
SETTINGS THE ADULT RE ENTRY
GRANT THE DJJ THERAPEUTIC
COMMUNITIES.
AND ON THE ONE TIME BASIS TO THE
CITY OF OAKLAND THE FOUR MILLION
FOR PAROLE.
PILOT IN STATE FACILITIES.
THAT IS THE MOTION.
WITH THE ASSEMBLY VOTE OUT.
THREE TO TO A SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TWO TWO THE NEXT MOTION IS --
THE FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
THE CITY VOCAL TO PROVIDE RE
ENTRY SUPPORT TO EXONERATE IS
WITH AN ASSEMBLY.
THANK YOU WITH AN ASSEMBLY
MOTION OF FOUR TWO ZERO AND THE
SENATE MOTIONS OF FIVE TWO ZERO
COMPROMISE ACCEPTED.
ISSUE TO ACCESS TO JUSTICE
PACKAGE THE MOTION IS ASSEMBLY
VERSION.
WITH ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TO
ZERO IN THE SENATE VOTE VOTE OF
FIVE TWO ZERO MOVING TO THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH ISSUE THREE PRE
TRIAL SERVICES PILOT.
THE MOTION IS SENATE VERSION
WITH ASSEMBLY VOTE UP. THREE TO
ONE AND A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE
TWO ZERO ISSUE FOR TRIAL COURT
JUDGESHIPS THE ASSEMBLY VERSION
IS THE MOTION WITH AN ASSEMBLY
VOTE OF FIVE ZERO A SENATE VOTE
OF FIVE ZERO ASSEMBLY VERSION
CARE IF.
ISSUE FIVE LEGALLY FOR RENT TO
THE LANDLORD TENANT DISPUTE THE
MOTION IS THE ASSEMBLY. FOR THE
ASSEMBLY VOTE OUT. THREE TO ONE
A SENATE VOTE OF THREE TO TWO
ASSEMBLY VERSION CARE IT'S
MOVING ON TO NICK LIST ITEMS.
THE SHRIVER ACCESSIBLE COUNCIL
THERE IS A COMPROMISE YES THIS
IS TWO AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND FOR THE
EXPANSION OF EXISTING PROGRAM
WHICH REPRESENTS PHONE COME
FAMILIES.
THAT IS THE MOTION WITH AN
ASSEMBLY VOTE UP. FIVE TWO ZERO
SENATE VOTE OF THREE TO ONE EL
DORADO OUNTY COURTHOUSE LAND
PURCHASES THE COPPER MINES.
YES THE COMPROMISES IMPROVING A
ONE TIME ALLOCATION FOR THE LAND
PURCHASE OF TWO POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS THANK YOU THAT
IS THE MOTION ASSEMBLY PHOTO.
FIVE TWO ZERO SENATE VOTE OF
FIVE TWO ZERO THANK YOU MOVING
ON TO THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
ISSUE SIX PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT DOWN RESILIENCY THE
ASSEMBLY VERSION IS THE MOTION.
THE ASSEMBLY VOTE IS FIVE TWO
ZERO SENATE VOTE IS. FIVE TWO
ZERO CELEBRATION KERRY'S ISSUE
SEVEN DISASTER PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSE THE SENATE VERSION
SENATE VERSION IS THE MOTION
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE
TWO ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE
TWO ZERO SENATE VERSION KERRY'S.
ISSUE.
EIGHT INTERNET CRIMES AGAINST
CHILDREN THERE IS A COMPROMISE
APPROVAL OF FIVE MILLION
ANNUALLY FOR THREE YEARS.
THAT IS THE MOTION ASSEMBLY VOTE
A FIVE TWO ZERO SENATE BOTH OF
FIVE TWO ZERO COMPROMISED
SCARY'S.
WILL MOVE INTO NICOLAS OPTIONS
INVESTMENTS IN LOCAL DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS EFFORTS THERE IS A
COMPROMISE YES THIS IS A NUMBER
OF ITEMS RELATED TO DO -- FIRE
AND EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTERS --
AND SYSTEMS AND THEIR LISTED IN
THE HEAD WITH THEM TOO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION -- TO ONE
MOTION FOR ALL EIGHT ITEMS.
SCENE NINE THE COMPROMISE IS THE
MOTION WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
FIVE TWO ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO NEXT NICOLAS
ITEM FUNDING TO PREVENT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
IT'S A CONFERENCE COMPROMISED TO
PROVE FIVE MILLION TO FUND
GRANTS FOR PREVENTION EFFORTS OF
SEXUAL AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
THAT IS THE MOTION.
ASSEMBLY VODA FIVE ZERO A SENATE
VOTE OF THREE TWO ZERO
COMPROMISED GARY'S SCHOOL SAFETY
IN COMMUNICATIONS THERE'S A
COPPER MINES.
YES SO THE COMPROMISE HERE IS
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE WE
ASKED TO ADMINISTER GRANTS FOR
K. TWELVE SCHOOLS COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
AND THIS WILL BE FOR
INTEROPERABLE TECHNOLOGY IN
RESPONSE TO EMERGENCY EVENTS.
THAT WILL BE THE MOTION WITH AN
ASSEMBLY VOTE OUT [inaudible]
FIVE ZERO THE SENATE VOTE OF
FIVE TWO ZERO COMPROMISED
KERRY'S HOMELESS YOUTH EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND HOUSING PROGRAM
THERE'S A CONFERENCE COPPER
MINES. TO APPROVE SIX POINT SIX
SEVEN MILLION SIX IN THE
HOMELESS YOUTH EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND HOUSING PROGRAM
THAT IS THE MOTION.
THE ASSEMBLY VOTE HE IS. FIVE
ZERO THE SENATE VOTE IS. THREE
TWO ONE COMPROMISE KERRY'S.
MOVING ON TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
ISSUE NINE THE JUSTICE HUMAN
RESOURCES.
AND I WILL GO BACK TO THE ONE I
JUST CAN'T [inaudible]
TRAINING.
THERE IS A CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
COMPROMISE THE APPROVAL OF A ONE
TIME ALLOCATION.
OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR GENERAL FUND FOR
DISTRICT ATTORNEY TRAINING --
MISTER THIS ONE OFTEN CAN YOU
TELL US THE NATURE OF THAT
TRAINING.
SO -- THIS WAS WORKED OUT IN THE
LAST COUPLE DAYS ONE CHECK IN
WITH OKAY THANK YOU.
YES -- WELL WE ARE THIS WAS
RECENTLY ADDED TO THE FINAL
PACKAGE THAT WILL HAVE TO GET
BACK WITH YOU -- SHORTLY WITH
THE DETAILS OKAY JUST I'M JUST
BECAUSE IT WAS AT IT MOST
RECENTLY I'M CURIOUS ABOUT THE
NATURE OF THE CONTENT OF THE
TRAINING WHAT KIND OF TRAINING
EDS.
OKAY THANK YOU -- WILL GO AHEAD
AND TAKE A VOTE BUT I'D
APPRECIATE.
KNOWING WHAT THAT IS SO THAT IS
THE MOTION -- WITHIN ASSEMBLY
VOTE [inaudible]
OF FOUR TWO ZERO AND THE SENATE
VOTE OF THREE TWO ZERO MOVING ON
TO JEFF THIS HUMAN RESOURCES THE
MOTION IS ASSEMBLY VERSION.
THAT IS THE MOTION WITH AN
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO A
SENATE VOTE OF THREE TO TWO
SOMEBODY VERSION KERRY'S.
ISSUE TEN ARMED IN PROHIBITED
PERSON SYSTEM THERE IS A
COMPROMISE YES SERVICE
COMPROMISED APPROVES THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL BUT IT ADDS%
TBL.
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICE
ON APRIL FIRST OF EACH OF THE
FOLLOWING YEARS TO REPORT TO THE
JAIL BC AS WELL AS THE PHYSICAL
COMMITTEES OF EACH HOUSE OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
A NUMBER OF ITEMS THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUAL INDIVIDUALS IN THE
APPS PROGRAMS THE DEGREE TO
WHICH THE BACKLOG APPS HAS BEEN
REDUCED OR ELIMINATED.
AND OTHER SPECIFIED INFORMATION
RELATED TO THE UP EFFORTS OF THE
DOJ IN REDUCING THE OBSTACLE.
THANK YOU.
THE COMPROMISE IS THE MOTION --
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE
ZERO A SENATE VERSION OF FIVE
TWO ZERO COMPROMISED SCARY.
MOVIE NON ISSUE.
ELEVEN IMPLEMENTATION OF
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE ASSEMBLY
VERSION IS THE MOTION WITH
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE ZERO
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TO ZERO
SIMPLY VERSION KERRY'S.
ISSUE TWELVE YEAR OLD GAMBLING
CONTROL CARDROOM AND THIRD PARTY
PROVIDER WORKLOAD ASSEMBLY
VERSION IS THE MOTION WITHIN
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO A
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TO ZERO
SIMPLY VERSION KERRY'S.
PAY ISSUE THIRTEEN
IMPLEMENTATION OF PRICE GOUGING
LEGISLATION ASSEMBLY VERSION IS
THE MOTION WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE
OF THREE TO ONE AND A SENATE
VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO ASSEMBLY
VERSION KERRY'S.
ISSUE FOURTEEN AUDIT ON HATE
CRIMES ASSEMBLY VERSION IS THE
MOTION WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
FIVE ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE
ZERO ASSEMBLY VERSION KERRY'S.
MOVING TO NYC ARE YOU ITEMS
IMPLEMENTATION OF VARIOUS OF
FIRE ARMS BILLS -- THERE'S A
CONFERENCE COMPROMISED TO PROVE
NAY REVISION DO YOU WANT TO GO
INTO FURTHER DETAILS MISTER THIS
ONE OFTEN.
WE'LL GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT AS
WELL.
SEARCH UNDER ALL ITEMS THAT ARE
IN THE NAY REVISION BUT IN TERMS
OF THE SPECIFICS ON THAT PACKAGE
WITH ACT YES ALL RIGHT.
BUT IN THE JARS WITH APARTMENT
FINANCE I THINK IT'S JUST THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MODIFIED ALL OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS
TO REFLECT LOWER AMOUNTS AND WE
WERE OKAY WITH THAT OKAY GREAT.
WITH THAT -- THAT IS THE MOTION
CONFERENCE COPPER MINES.
APPROVED THE MAY REVISE WITHIN
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF THREE TWO ZERO
AND THE SENATE VOTE OF THREE TWO
TWO MAY RICH MAY REVISION BUT
THE JUST MISS CAREY'S.
THE NEXT NECKLACE SEX
TRAFFICKING THERE'S A COMPROMISE
TO PROVE ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND TO DETERMINE THE
SCOPE OF SEX TRAFFICKING
SACRAMENTO.
AND THE FUNDING IS TO BE SPENT
OVER THREE YEARS THAT IS THE
MOTION THE ASSEMBLY VOTE OUT.
FIVE ZERO A SENATE BODO
[inaudible] FIVE ZERO
COMPROMISE IS CARRIED SEXUAL
ASSAULT EVIDENCE KIDS TESTING IS
A COMPROMISE YES SO THIS IS TWO
ITEMS TWO MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME TO ENSURE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES.
SUBMIT SEXUAL ASSAULT FORENSIC
EVIDENCE TO A CRIME LAB AS WELL
AS 800-558-0050 FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR DOJ ONE TIME FOR THE
COST OF SEXUAL ASSAULT EVIDENCE
KIT TESTING.
THAT IS THE MOTION WITH AN
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE ZERO A
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE ZERO
COMPROMISE KERRY'S MOVING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION ISSUE FIFTEEN
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE RE
ORGANIZATION.
THERE'S A COMPROMISE YES TO THE
COMPROMISE HERE IS TO APPROVE
THE ASSEMBLY ACTION WITH REGARD
TO TBL ADDING INSIDE SIRI
COMMITTEE.
AND ALSO APPROVED FUNDING FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF A
THERAPEUTIC COMMUNITY PILOT.
THANK YOU THAT'S THE MOTION WITH
AN ASSEMBLY VODA. THREE TO TWO A
SENATE VOTE OF THREE TO
COMPROMISED KERRY'S.
ISSUE SIXTEEN DJ OR PRODUCER
PILOT WITH CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS THE ASSEMBLY
VERSION IS THE MOTION WITH AN
ASSEMBLY VOTE I FOUR ZERO A
SENATE VOTE OF THREE TO TWO
COMPROMISE QUE.
ASSEMBLY VERSION KERRY'S.
ISSUE SEVENTEEN INTEGRATED
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER TREATMENT
AT ALL CDC OUR FACILITIES THE
SENATE VERSION IS THE MOTION.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FORTY
ONE A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO COMPROMISED KERRY'S.
SENATE VERSION CARRIES PARDON ME
CDC OUR POPULATION SAVINGS THERE
IS A COMPROMISE FINANCE THAT YOU
TO ADJUSTMENTS -- AND THE ADULT
POPULATION APPROVING AN EIGHTEEN
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLAR
REDUCTION THE GENERAL FUND IN
THE BUDGET YEAR AND EIGHTEEN
POINT SIX MILLION ON GOING AFTER
THAT.
THAT IS THE MOTION WITH ASSEMBLY
VOTO. FIVE TWO ZERO SENATE VOTE
OF FIVE ZERO COMPROMISE KERRY'S
SUBLIMINAL REFORMS TO PAROLE
CONSIDERATION THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISES TO APPROVE MAY
REVISE ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO
ADD.
CLICK ON THE PART OF FINANCE SO
THIS -- REMOVES -- SOME
REQUIREMENTS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAD REQUESTED TO
ACTUALLY PREVENT THE BORDER
PEARL HEARINGS TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH SOME STRUCTURE DECISION
MAKING TRAINING THAT THEY WERE
PROVIDING TO THEIR COMMISSIONER
SO THIS GOES BACK TO OUR MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL.
WHICH WAS JUST -- POSITIONS TO
ROLL OUT SOME NEW CHANGES AND
THE HEARING REQUIREMENTS.
THANK YOU THAT IS THE MOTION.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OUT. THREE
TO ONE AND A SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TWO TWO CONFERENCE KERRY'S
STATE.
pUNIT.
CONFERENCE COMPROMISES TO
APPROVE MAY REVISE FINANCE.
SO -- THIS REMOVES THE
REQUIREMENT THAT MADE THE
FUNDING CONTINGENT UPON
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS TO HAVE
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL OVERSEE
CERTAIN IN MAY -- GRIEVANCES AND
GOES BACK TO JUST THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL TO DO --
MOVE THE INQUIRY PROCESS FOR
STAFF COMPLAINTS TO THE OFFICE
OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS.
THANK YOU THAT IS THE MOTION
WITH ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE ZERO
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE ZERO AND AND
SEE FIVE ZERO THANK YOU.
THERE IS CAPITAL OUTLAY AND
MAINTENANCE BCP'S THERE IS A
COMPROMISE YES SERVICE APPROVED
A MAJOR REVISION PROPOSAL FOR A
NUMBER OF CAPITAL OUTLAY
MAINTENANCE ITEMS THAT ARE
LISTED IN THE SHE THANK YOU THAT
IS THE MOTION WITH THE ASSEMBLY.
OF BOTH OF FIVE ZERO AND THE
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
CONFERENCES -- COMPROMISES
ACCEPTED.
MOVING ON TO THE B. S. C. C.
ISSUE EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA
VIOLENCE PREVENTION AND
INTERVENTION.
THERE'S A COMPROMISE YES SO THE
COMPROMISED -- THE MINISTRATION
PROPOSED TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS OF WHICH NINE MILLION
DOLLARS WAS ONE WAS ON GOING THE
SENATE VERSION INCLUDES AN
ADDITIONAL THREE MILLION DOLLARS
AND THAT BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
FOR THAT ITEM.
INCLUDES SEVERAL SET ASIDE FOR
THAT THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
THAT IS THE MOTION WITH ASSEMBLY
VOTE OUT. FIVE ZERO SENATE VOTE
OF FIVE ZERO COMPROMISE KYRIE'S.
ON THE NECKLACE STANDARDS AND
TRAINING FOR CORRECTIONS THERE
IS A COMPROMISE SILICON
COMPROMISE HERE IS TO PROVE THE
NAY REVISION AND YES AND SO THIS
IS A RESTAURANT FOR RESTORATION
OF HISTORICAL FUNDING LEVELS.
AND BSE SEETHER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING CORRECTION STANDARDS
AND TRAINING FOR CORRECTIONS --
FUNDING LEVEL HAS DECLINED
BECAUSE THE PENALTY FIND A
PENALTY FUND REDUCTIONS AND THIS
IS JUST A RESTORATION OF
HISTORICAL LEVELS TO CONTINUE
THAT TRAINING.
THANK YOU THAT IS THE MOTION.
NO THIS IS STANDARD IN TRAINING
FOR CORRECTIONS.
OURS DOES NOT HAVE IT.
IT'S NOT ONLY THE NON CONFERENCE.
YES -- CAM ZERO NAMED AFTER.
DISTRICT CHANGE THIS
REIMBURSEMENTS.
IT CAN BE A PROBLEM JUST ONE
DISK.
WHICH MEMBERS OF THE OKAY -- NO
VOTE ON IT SEE [inaudible]
THE BALDWIN PARK WEST COVINA.
THAT'S ABOUT AS ACTION.
AND WE'RE GONNA COME BACK TO
THAT IF YOU WERE GOING TO LIKE I
THINK COPIES WERE SENT.
TO SOME PERHAPS IN OTHERS BY
ACCIDENT DIDN'T RECEIVE IT.
UNTIL WILL MAKE SHE GET COPIES.
WELCOME BACK TO THE ITEM.
AND CHAIR.
YES SIR WE ASK QUESTIONS ON THIS
WHILE WE'RE HERE FEATURE CAM I
JUST WANNA KNOW WHY NO BETTER NO
WORSE WHY ARE WE JUST FOCUS ON
ONE AREA NOT THE WHOLE STATE.
ARE YOU ONCE THEY'RE TO TRAINING
FOR CORRECTIONS [inaudible]
PROVIDE.
SNIFFERS FOR THE CITIES OF OR
NOT.
NO NO I HAD MOVED THERE YET SIR.
YOU MEAN I WAS STILL ON
STANDARDS AND TRAINING FOR
CORRECTIONS UNDER -- BE SEC.
SO WE ARE GOING -- TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYBODY HAS THE LANGUAGE.
I THINK IT WAS A A LATE AT ON IT
WILL MAKE YOUR BODY GETS IT.
IN THE MEANTIME EVERYONE DOES
HELP PUBLIC SAFETY MITIGATION
EFFORTS.
WE ALSO HAVE SOMETHING USEFUL
INFORMATION ON JUST.
OKAY WITH CALLS UP THIS WHEN WE
COME BACK THAT I APPRECIATE THAT.
SO EVERYONE HAS THE PUBLIC
SAFETY MITIGATION EFFORTS FOR
THE CITY THE BALLPARK IS IS SO
WESCO BEING IN SOUTH EL MONTE.
MISTER MOORE Là YOU HAVE A
QUESTION MANAGER JUST CURIOUS
WHY ARE WE DOING THIS FOR
EVERYBODY.
SO WHAT WE ASK IS A PACKAGE AT
CONCERTS.
HANDS UP WITH SOME OF THESE
ADDITIONS OF THESE WORLD
RENEGOTIATING.
I CONSIDER THAT NOT RESPONSIVE
THIS TIME.
TELL THE WORLD.
THAT'S TRUE AND SO THERE WE ARE
HAVE THAT THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE COMPROMISED IS THE
MOTION.
WITH THAT THE ASSEMBLY VOTE IS.
FIVE TWO ZERO THE SENATE VOTE IS.
THREE TWO COMPROMISE KERRY'S
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PILOT
PROGRAM AGAIN ON THE NECKLACE.
THE COMPROMISE IS TO APPROVE A
ONE TIME ALLOCATION OF FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PILOT.
IN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY.
ANYTHING TO ADD.
THAT IS THE MOTION [inaudible]
QUESTION.
THE ASSEMBLY VOTE IS
[inaudible] THREE ZERO SENATE
VOTE IS THREE TO TURN TWO MOTION
CARRIES.
AGAIN IN NYC GUN VIOLENCE
REDUCTION PILOT PROGRAM THERE'S
A COMPROMISE FINANCE THIS IS
THREE MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
FROM THE GENERAL FUND IT'S FOR
THE GUN VIOLENCE REDUCTION
PALETTE PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT ENTITIES.
THAT ARE CONDUCTING ACTIVITIES
REGARDING SEIZING WEAPONS AND
AMMUNITION FROM PERSONS WHO
SHOULD NOT BE POSSESSING THAT.
THAT IS THE MOTION SIR TO
NIELSEN.
LAST YEAR THERE WAS FIVE MILLION.
IN THE BUDGET FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO DO THIS VERY THING
IT DID NOT GET SPENT.
WHAT COMFORT CAN YOU GIVE US THE
THIS APPROPRIATION WOULD GET
SPENT ONE LAST YEAR'S FIVE
MILLION DID NOT GET SPENT?
AM I DON'T EXACTLY RECALL THAT
AND THE CONTENTS OF THAT I HAVE
PRIOR TO FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
PREVIOUSLY BUT THIS IS DEDICATED
JUST TO A PILOT IN SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY.
SO PRESUMABLY THEY WILL AND THEY
ARE PREPARED TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAM -- LOCALLY THIS YEAR.
THAT'S WRONG THAT'S WRONG OKAY
I'M SORRY WE'RE ON THE GUN
VIOLENCE REDUCTION PILOT PROGRAM.
IT'S OKAY APPROVAL ONE TIME
ALLOCATION OF THREE MILLION
GENERAL FUND FOR GUN VIOLENCE
REDUCTION POP PROGRAM TO SUPPORT
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT ENTITIES
CONDUCTING ACTIVITIES RELATED TO
SEIZING WEAPONS.
AND AMMUNITION FROM PERSONS WHO
ARE PROHIBITED FROM POSSESSING
THEM.
AND SO CENTER NIELSEN'S POINT
WAS THAT LAST YEAR FIVE MILLION
WAS ALLOCATED. TO THIS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND INSTANT FEELS
OKAY.
OR TWENTY SIXTEEN EXCUSE ME --
TWENTY SIXTEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN
OKAY.
THAT'S HELPFUL BECAUSE WE
WEREN'T REMEMBER THAT FROM LAST
YEAR SENATOR.
SO THE QUESTION THEREFORE IS HOW
WILL THIS MONEY BE DIFFERENT
HELL WILL BE ALLOCATED DIFFERENT
WHAT WHAT WHAT CONCERNS CAN THEY
GIVE US THAT THIS WILL BE ONE
THE PREVIOUS FIVE WAS NOT.
I AM SO THIS LANGUAGE ACTUALLY
DEDICATE THE FUNDS TO FOR
SPECIFIC COUNTY SHERIFF'S AND
AND SO THE INTENT IS TO
DISTRIBUTE THOSE FUNDS
IMMEDIATELY AND ADD THE IT'S UP
TO THOSE COUNTY SHERIFF'S TO
IMPLEMENT PROGRAMS.
CAN YOU TELL US WHICH WERE
COUNTY THEY ARE I BELIEVE THEY
ARE SANTA CRUZ ALAMEDA -- SAN
DIEGO INVENTOR.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS OFF WELL
IS THERE IS THERE REPORTING
REQUIREMENT YOU KNOW YOU'VE
HEARD MY COMMENTS ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE BEFORE ON
TRYING.
TO CHANGE YOUR A PROTOCOL FOR
PICKING UP WEAPONS AND WE WORLD
THIS MONEY OUT THESE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S.
AND IF IT'S UP TO THEM HOW THE
USER THEN I'M ALL FOR THAT LOCAL
CONTROL WILL THERE BE SOME
REPORTING BACK SO WE CAN
DETERMINE WHAT THE BEST
PRACTICES ARE AND THEN PERHAPS.
DURING THE NEXT BUDGET CYCLE OR
THE ONE AFTER THAT DECIDE IF
THERE'S A BETTER WAY TO DO WHAT
WE HAVE BEEN DOING.
AM I EIGHT I DON'T RECALL THE
SPECIFIC REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
SO WE PUT BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
BUT THIS IS INTENDED TO ALSO
WORK FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
I'M AND SHARE INFORMATION ABOUT
THE TYPE OF WEAPONS THAT HAVE
BEEN SEIZED AND THINGS LIKE THAT
SO VERY SIMILAR IN SUPPORT OF
OUR APPS EFFORTS.
OKAY THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU.
HOPE EVERYONE IS CLEAR ABOUT THE
MOTION AS DOCUMENTED HERE.
THAT IS THE MOTION THE ASSEMBLY
VOTE IS. FIVE ZERO SENATE VOTE
IS [inaudible] FIVE ZERO
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE KYRIE'S
MOVING ON TO ILLEGAL DUMPING
PILOT.
THERE IS A COMPROMISE YEAH I
SAID THIS IS MONEY TO ENFORCE
DUMPING LAWS FOR TWO COUNTIES
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY.
THAT IS THE MOTION WITH AN
ASSEMBLY VOTO. FOUR ZERO AND THE
SENATE VOTE OF THREE TO TWO
COMPROMISED KERRY'S.
MR THIS ONE OFTEN YOU'RE GONNA
GIVE US THE INFORMATION ON THE
TRAINING ITEM DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S YOUNG YES.
SURE SO THIS WAS AN ACT ACTUALLY
IN THE BUDGET LAST YEAR'S A
REDUCTION OF REDUCING THE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
SO WE ARE RESTORING THAT.
AND IT'S SPECIFICALLY FOR
STATEWIDE TRAINING GRANTS FOR
LOCAL PROSECUTORS ARMED.
AND ON THE PROSECUTION OF CRIMES
AGAINST WOMEN.
GOT IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CONTINUING ON WITH THE NECKLACE
THE CAR BREAK IN PREVENTION
FUNDING THERE IS A CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE YES SERVICES FUNDING
FOR FIVE CITIES MILPITAS FREMONT
NEWARK SAN JOSE AND SANTA CLARA.
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO EACH OF THEM. FOR A
NUMBER OF STRATEGIES RELATED TO
PREVENTING CAR BREAK INS.
THANK YOU THAT IS THE MOTION.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VODA. FIVE ZERO
A SENATE VOTE OF THREE TO TWO
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE KERRY'S
COUNTY OF IMPERIAL FOR VALLEY
COLLEGE MEDICAL ASSISTANT IN
CORRECTIONAL ACADEMY IS A
COMPROMISE YES THIS IS ONE
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE COUNTY.
JAIL FOR THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT TO SUPPORT THAT
MEDICAL SYSTEM PROGRAM.
THAT'S THE MOTION WITH AN
ASSEMBLY VOTO. THREE ZERO AND A
SENATE VOTE OF THREE TWO ONE
CHALLENGER MORAL YOUTH CENTER OF
LOS ANGELES IS A CONFERENCE
COPPER MINES YES THIS IS A ONE
TIME FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
TRANSITION THE CENTER INTO A
RESIDENTIAL VOCATIONAL TRAINING
CENTER FOCUSED ON YOUNG ADULTS.
THAT IS THE MOTIONS AND ASSEMBLY
VOTE OF THREE ZERO AND A SENATE
VOTE OF THREE TWO ZERO YOU THREE
INVESTMENT GRANT
COPPER MINES FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THIS GRANT.
THAT IS THE MOTION ASSEMBLY VOTE
OF FIVE TO ZERO SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TWO ONE TRIBAL YOUTH
DIVERSION THERE'S A COPPER MINES
YES AND THIS IS TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THESE EFFORTS.
THAT'S THE MOTION ASSEMBLY VODA.
FIVE ZERO SENATE VOTO
[inaudible] THREE ONE GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER
TRAINING THERE'S A COMPROMISE
YES THIS IS TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS -- I BELIEVE
THERE IS -- EXTRA ZERO AT THE
END OF HE CAME BACK AND HEAD OUT.
AND THIS IS SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
CITY ATTORNEY OF SAN DIEGO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT IS THE
MOTION REMOVING THAT EXTRA --
ZERO WITHIN ASSEMBLY VOTE UP.
FOUR ONE FIFTIES ME [inaudible]
FOUR ZERO SENATE [inaudible]
BOTH OF THREE TWO TWO IF YOU
NINETEEN INCREASE PEACE OFFICER
TRAINING THERE'S A COMPROMISE
YES SO THE FUNDING LEVELS
REFLECT WHAT THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED -- FOR RESTORING AN
INCREASING FUNDING FOR THE POST
COMMISSION HOWEVER BASED ON
CONVERSATIONS WITH MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE IN BUDGET YEAR
AND BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE
PRIORITIZING TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF THAT. FOR USE OF
FORCE AND DE ESCALATION TRAINING.
THAT IS THE MOTION WITH ASSEMBLY
VODA. FIVE ZERO AND THE SENATE
VOTE OF FIVE ZERO MOVING ON TO
CANNABIS TAX REVENUE ISSUE
TWENTY PROP SIXTY FOUR TAX
REVENUE THE COMPROMISE PLEASE
YES SO WE'RE ADOPTING THE SENATE
ACTION HERE BUT WITH TWO
IMPORTANT ACTIONS IN AND BEYOND --
ONE IS FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND THESE ARE FOR
CANNABIS EQUITY PROGRAMS AND
SECOND -- THE ACTION ADOPTS
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
REQUIRE THE ADMINISTRATION TO
CONSIDER MOVING CANNABIS
ENFORCEMENT RESOURCES -- FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS TO THE BUREAU OF
CANNABIS CONTROL THANK YOU THAT
IS THE MOTION WITH AN ASSEMBLY
VOTE OF THREE ONE AND THE SENATE
VOTE OF THREE TWO ONE COMPROMISE
KERRY'S.
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL
WE'RE ON THE NECK WE'RE INTHE
NECKLACE AUDITING AN OVERSIGHT
THERE'S A COMPROMISE AGREEMENT
ON THREE POINT FIVE MILLION.
GENERAL FUND ONGOING SET ASIDE
CAN YOU ELABORATE -- SO BOTH
HOUSES OF THE LEGISLATURE
ORIGINALLY PROVE SEVEN POINT
NINE NINE THIS IS THREE AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARSTO SET
ASIDE FOR FUTURE CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW THAT OVERSIGHT WOULD --
TAKE PLACE.
SO THAT IS THE MOTION.
WHAT THE ASSEMBLY VOTE OUT? FIVE
ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO TO ME I DON'T LAWSUIT
REVISED COULD THE COMPROMISE
THIS IS SIMPLY A REDUCTION OF
THE CURRENT YEAR ITEM AND THEN
ALLOCATION FOR THE BUDGET YEAR --
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
EXACT AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
REQUIRED TO SETTLE THIS DECISION
THANK YOU THAT WILL BE THE
MOTION.
WITH THIS ASSEMBLY VODA FIVE
ZERO AND THE SENATE VOTE OF FIVE
TWO ZERO THANK YOU.
THAT CONCLUDES THE PUBLIC SAFETY.
SANDERS IN TRAINING PURPOSES.
I'M SORRY ONE SECOND I'VE GOT TO
GO BACK --I THINK EVERYONE NOW
GOT A COPY OF THE DOCUMENT. FOR
THE ITEM.
SABLE'S ISSUE NUMBER.
IT IS AN ADMONITION NUMBERS.
HELP RIGHT PAGE.
FIVE SHE TENDS.
TO AGAIN IT WAS A NECKLACE ITEM
UNDER.
THE FCC THE STANDARDS AND
TRAINING FOR CORRECTIONS.
THERE WAS A CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED TO APPROVE THE MAY
REVISE.
AGAIN UNDER B. S. C. C.
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
SO THIS WAY TO RESTORE THAT BSE
SEES PROGRAMS -- TO WITH SIX
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS BACK
TO HISTORICAL LEVELS AND A
LITTLE BIT NEW.
FUNDING FOR NEW PROGRAMMING.
THAT WILL BE THE MOTION -- ANY
QUESTION THE VOTE FROM THE
ASSEMBLY [inaudible]
WILL BE. FIVE TWO ZERO THE VOTE
FROM THE SENATE.
WILL BE.
FIVE TO ZERO NOW WE'VE PULLED
OUT PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND THE JUDICIARY
.
FUNDING FOR THE COMMISSION THIS
IS THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN
AFFAIRS THE MOTION IS THE
ASSEMBLY VERSION.
WITH A ASSEMBLY VOTE OF THREE
TWO ZERO AND THE SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TWO ONE UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT WILL
MOVE TO ISSUE TO INTERNATIONAL
TRADE PROGRAM SPECIALISTS AND
IT'S THE SENATE VERSION PLUS S.
R. L..
YES I BELIEVE IT.
IS GOOD FOR ME -- GROUP DOES
THAT POSITION -- OFFICES.
COMMENT BUT ALSO PROVIDE SOME
REPORTING LANGUAGE WHEN IT COMES
SPECIFICALLY TO INTERNATIONAL
TRADE AND WHAT THOSE FUNCTIONS
ARE DO YOU YEAH YOUR SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY.
TO YEAH I THINK YOU IS
MEASURABLE OBJECTIVES AND I'M
SORT OF EFFORTS THAT THEY'RE
UNDERTAKING SO JUST GENERALLY
ABOUT WHAT THEWORK THEY'RE
GOING TO BE DOING THE NATURE OF
THE WORK THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET THAT BE THE MOTION
COLLEAGUES TO THE ASSEMBLY VOTE
OF FIVE TWO ZERO AND THE SENATE
VOTE OF NIELSEN.
YOU OFF THANK YOU UP.
THREE ZERO ISSUE THREE FILMON
TAX TELEVISION TAX CREDIT KERRY
FOR FORWARD THE MOTION IS
ASSEMBLY VERSION.
ASSEMBLY VOTE.
OF THREE TO ONE AND THE SENATE
VOTE OF FOUR TWO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY VERSION KERRY'S ISSUE
FOR OFFICE OF ECONOMIC IMPACT
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
COPPENS COMPROMISE DEFERRED FOR
LATER DISCUSSION.
AND ARE WE STILL TAKING ACTION
ON IT EVEN THOSE DEFERRED FOR
LATER DISCUSSION.
I BELIEVE SO CHAU.
DO YOU THINK WE SHOULD FOR ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR ISSUE FOR OFFICE OF
ECONOMIC I GUESS THERE'S NO
FISCAL -- SO I THINK
[inaudible]
YEAH.
AGAIN IT'S DEFERRED TO LATER --
GOOD DISCUSSION BUT IT IS A
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE SO WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND VOTE ON IT.
THAT IS THE MOTION WITHIN THE
FAMILY PHOTO FIVE TWO ZERO AND
THE SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
MOVING ON TO THE NECKLACE LOCAL
INVESTMENTS.
THERE'S A COMPROMISE YES SIR
THIS ISFOR A NUMBER OF ITEMS
FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL VALLEY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION
TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE LA
CLEAN TECH INCUBATOR. TWO POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CLAREMONT POMONA LOCALLY FROM
POWER AND ONE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE GLENDALE TECH
ACCELERATOR.
SUCH WILL BE THE MOTION WITHIN
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TO ZERO
AND THE SENATE VOTE OF THREE TO
TO COMPROMISE KERRY'S.
ISSUE FIVE OFFICE OF DIGITAL
INNOVATION.
THE COMP CONFERENCE COPPER MINES
APPROVED FIFTY POSITIONS OF
WHICH TWENTY ARE EXEMPT
POSITIONS.
SELECT ELABORATE HASTA BASICALLY
THE THISIS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND THE NEGOTIATION WAS
AROUND A HOW MANY POSITIONS IN
AND THE STRUCTURE OF THEM IN
TERMS O HOW THE OFFICES
ORGANIZED.
THANK YOU IN CELLS THAT IS THE
MOTION THE ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
THREE TWO ZERO AND A SENATE VOTE
OF THREE TO TWO IF YOU SIX
CENSUS OUT REACH THERE'S A
COMPROMISE YES OF A COMPROMISE
AT BUILDING ON THE RIGHT NAY
REVISION -- INSTEAD OF JUST
SIMPLY HAVING ADMINISTRATIVE
AUGMENTATION AUTHORITY -- IT
ADDS THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND FOR CENSUS SPENDING
OF WHICH TWO MILLION DOLLARS IS
FOR ELLIE A FOCUS STRATEGIES AND
THEN THE REMAINING TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS.
IS FOR PURPOSES INCLUDING
LANGUAGE ACCESS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN STUDIOS AND COSTS
RELATED TO APPEALS AS WELL AS
OTHER OUTREACH COSTS -- BUT WE
DO WANT TO STRESS THAT THOSE
PURPOSES ARE INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO THOSE PURPOSES FOR
THAT FUNDING -- THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE ALSO APPROVES THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WITH REGARD
TO THE HOUSING POPULATION SAMPLE
ENUMERATION THAT THE GOVERNMENT
THAT THE STATE WILL BE
CONDUCTING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT IS THE MOTION WITH THE
ASSEMBLY VOTE UP. THREE TO ONE
AND THE SENATE VOTE UP
[inaudible] THREE ZERO
COMPROMISED KERRY'S MOVING TO
THE OFFICE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING A RESEARCH ISSUE SEVEN
ADMINISTRATIVE RESOURCES.
SO THIS IS A CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE -- SPECIFICALLY
PROVIDING 5% OF AN
ADMINISTRATIVE SET ASIDE FOR OPR
LOCAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS THIS
IS BASICALLY CHANGE TO MAKE SURE
THAT -- PR CAN HANDLE AND
ADMINISTER THESE PROGRAMS THAT
IS THE MOTION WITH ASSEMBLY VODA.
FIVE ZERO SENATE VOTE OF FIVE
EIGHT PRECISION MEDICINE THERE'S
A COMPROMISE YES SO THE
COMPROMISE HERE'S ADOPTING THE
SENATE ACTION BUT ADDING
ASSEMBLY SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
LANGUAGE REQUIRING OPR TO REPORT
ON THE PROCESS OF CHANGING THE
GOVERNANCE MODEL. FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THIS PROGRAM.
THAT'S THE MOTION OF THE
ASSEMBLY VOTER FIVE ZERO IN THE
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE ZERO IT
CARRIES.
UNCLAIMED PROPERTY BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE THE MOTION IS SENATE
VERSION WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
FIVE TWO ZERO AND ASSEMBLY VOTE
A SKEWS ME A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE
TWO ZERO SENATE VERSION CARRIES.
ON THE NECKLACE CALIFORNIA STATE
PAYROLL SYSTEM AND CAL.
I DON'T KNOW THE CAL EIGHTERS
THAT'S FUNNY.
OKAY IN THAT -- FINANCE IS GOING
TO CLARIFY THE ACTION ON THIS
ITEM PLEASE DO THINK THANK YOU
CARLA BECAUSE NOW THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE -- THE FIRST ITEM IS
FOR ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION FOR
THREE YEARS FOR THE PAYROLL
PROJECT.
AND THE MAYOR VISION PROPOSED A
REDUCTION OF THE CALENDARS OF
SEVEN HUNDRED FOR FOR THREE
YEARS.
THIS RESTORES THAT FUNDING IN
THE BUDGET YEAR.
SO THE SECOND PART ONE MORE TIME
FOR MAJOR A CONTINUE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FOUR THOUSAND IN THE
BUDGET YEAR FOR THE CALENDARS
PLANNING PROCESS [inaudible]
GOT IT.
THAT IS THE MOTION.
WITH ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FOUR TWO
ZERO AND THE SENATE VOTE OF FOUR
TWO ZERO COMPROMISED CARE IS
MOVING ON TO THE OFFICE OF TAX
APPEALS ISSUE.
TEN SMALL BUSINESS TAX CODES TAX
CODE STREAMLINING THE MOTION IS
SENATE VERSION WITH AN ASSEMBLY
VOTO. FIVE TWO ZERO AND IN THE
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
SENATE VERSION KERRY'S.
SECRETARY OF STATE ISSUE ELEVEN
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION OF CAL
ACCESS THAT WAS CLOSED OUT.
ISSUE TWELVE TECHNICAL CHANGE TO
AB EIGHT A ONE THE ASSEMBLY
VERSION IS THE MOTION.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE A FIVE
ZERO AND THE SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TO TWO ASSEMBLY VERSION
KERRY'S.
ISSUE.
THIRTEEN VOTERS CHOICE ACT
FUNDING THE ASSEMBLY VERSION IS
THE MOTION.
WITH N ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE
ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO ASSEMBLY VERSION KERRY'S.
CALIFORNIA POLLUTION CONTROL
FINANCING AUTHORITY THE CARE
ISSUE FOURTEEN CAL REVIEWS
PROGRAM THE ASSEMBLY VERSION IS
THE MOTION WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE
OF FIVE ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF
FIVE ZERO ASSEMBLY VERSION CARE.
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ISSUE
FIFTEEN HOUSING RELATED
INFRASTRUCTURE THE ASSEMBLY
VERSION IS THE MOTION WITH AN
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
SO DURING THE DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM LAST WEEK MANAGER THERE WAS
SOME TALK ABOUT SETTING ASIDE A
PORTION OF THIS FUNDING FOR
SMALL AND RURAL COUNTY SINCE
THEY HAVE TROUBLE COMPETING FOR
THESE FUNDS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY DON'T ALL GO TOWARDS A
LARGE COUNTIES TO DECCA DONE.
THE INTENTION -- OF THE
COMMITTEES TO DEAL WITH THAT
ISSUE IN THE TRAILER BILL
.
SO YOUR CONCERNS WERE HEARD LOUD
AND CLEAR WELL THAT THEY'RE NOT
DONE YET BUT I'M GLAD THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON YES WE ARE.
ALL THE MOTION IS THE ASSEMBLY
VERSION.
WHAT THE ASSEMBLY VOTE OF? FIVE
ZERO AND A SENATE VOTE OF THREE
ZERO ISSUE SIXTEEN INNOVATIVE
FINANCING TOOLS IS SIMPLY
VERSION IS THE MOTION WAS AN
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO
AND A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE TWO
ZERO THE LIVE VERSION KERRY'S.
SKIPPING THE ISSUE EIGHTEEN
SUCCESSOR AGENCIES THE SENATE
VERSION.
IS.
THE MOTION.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE
TWO ZERO SENATE VOTE OF FIVE
ZERO SEVEN VERSION IS ACCEPTED.
THE NEXT ITEM [inaudible]
FAR [inaudible]
NICK ADAMS [inaudible]
NOW
.
ISSUE -- NINETEEN UNDER
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS
BOARD TO DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS THEIR
VARIOUS LABOR ADJUSTMENTS.
ARE THERE IS A COMPROMISE. FOR
TWO AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS
AND THAT WILL FALL THE
SUSPENSION CALENDAR.
AT THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND ADDITION WITHOUT THE SENATE
ACTION ON THE SUBSEQUENT.
INJURY BENEFIT TRUST FUND AND AB --
ONE ONE ONE ONE AS WELL AS THE
SENATE ACTION ON THE GARMENT
MANUFACTURERS SPECIAL ACCOUNT.
AND THAT WILL BE THE MOTION
MISTER OBERNOLTE VENTURE COULD
WE SPLIT OFF ITEM NUMBER TWO
PLEASE HAPPY.
TO SO WITH THAT THE MOTION.
IS ITEMS ONE AND THREE THE
SENATE VERSION.
ON A. B. ELEVEN ELEVEN AND ITEM
THREE THE SENATE VERSION FOR
GARNET MANUFACTURE SPECIAL.
THAT IS THE MOTION WITH ASSEMBLY
VOTE OF FIVE TWO ZERO A SENATE
VOTE NO. FIVE TWO ZERO THE
SECOND MOTION IS COVERS
COMPROMISED PROVIDE HERB TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION TO BE
SUSPENDED IN.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO THAT IS
THE MOTION WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE
OF THREE TWO TWO AND A SENATE
VOTE OF THREE TWO TWO THANK YOU
ON THE OTHER INVESTMENTS.
THESE ARE TWO ERA OTHER
INVESTMENTS TOWARD A FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE YOUTH
WORKS RICHMOND BILL PROGRAM AS
WELL AS EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR THE STYLES HALL PROGRAM AT
EXPERIENCE BERKELEY HIGH SCHOOL.
AND THE THIRD ITEM THE FIVE
MILLION FOR OUT WHICH EDUCATION
REGARDING LABOR PROTECTION
RIGHTS FOR DOMESTIC WORKERS
ANOTHER LOW WAGE INDUSTRIES YES --
THAT IS THE MOTION.
MISTER MOORE Là.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS I HAD EARLIER.
I GUESS THE LAST WEEK WAS
WHETHER OR NOT THE STATE'S
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS WOULD BE
RELEASED BEFORE.
WE FINISHED OUR BUDGET.
IN.
A WEEK WE GOT OUR CAT FOR THIS
WEEK.
AND OUR UNRESTRICTED THAT
DEFICIT IS NOW GROWN -- TO TWO
HUNDRED AND IN THIRTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS.
AS A DEFICIT FOR OUR GOVERNMENT.
ACTIVITIES AND THAT OUR USINESS
TYPE ACTIVITIES IS NOW NEGATIVE
SIXTEEN BILLION SO COMBINED. FOR
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY BILLION
DOLLARS -- IN DEFICIT SO I'VE
BEEN VOTING NO WHERE I'M
STANDING ON A LOT OF SPENDING
OPPORTUNITIES.
AND AND SO SOME PEOPLE LOOK AT
THE GLASS IS HALF FULL AND I'M
KIND OF LOOKING AT IT IS HALF
EMPTY SO THAT.
THAT WILL MAYBE EXPLAIN MY KASHA
A LOT OF THESE.
SPENDING BOTH SO WE'VE MADE
TONIGHT I JUST WANTED.
TO BUT THAT ON THE RECORD WE
APPRECIATE YOUR CLARIFICATION.
THE MOTION -- IS ESTATE IT.
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE ZERO
SENATE VOTE OF THREE TO TWO
MOVING.
TO EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT ISSUE TWENTY PAID
FAMILY LEAVE -- THERE IS A
COMPROMISE WITH MODIFICATIONS
THE BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE IN TBL
YES.
AND THE TV ALL SPECIFICALLY
INCLUDES THE GOAL OF PROVIDING A
90% WAGE REPLACEMENT RATE FOR
THE PAID FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAMAND SO THAT IS THE MOTION
[inaudible]
MR OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
WE A ROBUST DISCUSSION AS YOU
RECALL ON THIS ITEM I DO AND THE
EXACT COSTSTHAT.
WOULD BE BORNE BY THE STATE
DISABILITY INSURANCE ACCOUNT BUT
WE WERE NOT DISCUSSING THOSE
COSTS AT THE WHITE REPLACEMENT
RATE OF 90% I WONDER IF THE LA --
CAN OPINE AS TO WHAT THE IPACT
ON THAT FUND WOULD BE.
WITH THE REPLACEMENT AT THAT
RATE [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
AND QUESTION.
ASSEMBLY PERCENTAGE BELIAU
WELCOME.
THANK YOU CAROLYN SHE FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
HAVE NOT DONE THAT SPECIFIC
ANALYSIS -- AS YET THAT SAID --
WE HAD ESTIMATED -- PREVIOUSLY
THAT UNDER EXISTING LAW THE
STATE COULD EXPAND -- BENEFITS
BY ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS THE
CURRENT REPLACEMENT -- WE'D
REPLACE THE RATE IS 60% GOING UP
290% -- SORT DEPENDING ON TAKE
UP WE HAVE TO REALLY RUN THE
NUMBERS AND LOOK AT THAT TO TO
TELL YOU EXACTLY WHAT IT WOULD
MEAN UNDER EXISTING CURRENT LAW.
OKAY SO JUST.
BACK OF THE ENVELOPE.
WHEN WE WERE DISCUSSING AT LAST
WEEK?
THE US SAID THAT'D BE ABOUT A
POINT 1% ADDITION TO THE STI
PAYROLL TAX.
IN OTHER WORDS A 10% OVERALL.
INCREASE TO THE COST PRESSURES
ON THE FUND. FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO MOVE FROM SIX TO
EIGHT WEEKS THAT'S CORRECT.
AND IT IT ACTUALLY MEAN.
IT THE IT'S NOT AN INCREASE IN
THE RATE FROM YEAR TO YEAR UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IT MEANS
THE RATE WILL NOT GO DOWN IN
NINETEEN TWENTY WHICH OTHERWISE
WOULD HAVE OCCURRED ABSENT THE
GOVERNOR'S.
PROPOSAL. TO THE MAXIMUM RATE IS
A ONE ONE HALF PERCENT CORRECT
AND I I BELIEVE WE ARE AT ONE
NOW AND WE WILL GO WE WOULD GO
TO A ONE ONE ONE TWO UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO GO FROM
SIX TO EIGHT WEEKS.
OKAY AND SO IT LOOKS AS WE WOULD
WE WOULD STAY AT ONE VERSUS
GOING TO POINT NINE I'M SORRY
OKAY SO I MEAN TO PUT IT A
DIFFERENT WHEN AND I WOULD
IMAGINE THIS IS GONNA BE ABOUT
50% MORE.
IF WE GO FROM A WAY TO REPLACE
RATE OF 60% 290%.
ARE WELL YOUR YOUR INCREASING
THE WAGE REPLACEMENT RATE WITH
KERR UP BY ABOUT 50% THAT'S
CORRECT I THINK IT WOULD DEPEND
ON TAKE UP AND THE DISTRIBUTION
OF TAKE UP AN INDIVIDUAL'S WAGES
UNDER.
OKAY WHAT LET ME TELL YOU MY
CONCERN BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO
PROLONG THE DISCUSSION BUT IF.
IF IT'S WERE TALK ABOUT A POINT
1%.
ESSENTIALLY TAX ON ALL PAYROLL
IN CALIFORNIA IS PLAYED BY THE
EMPLOYEES.
THE AVERAGE PAY THE WAGES
CALIFORNIA'S ABOUT SIXTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR LAST
YEAR SO ESSENTIALLY WE'RE TAKING
IF WE ADOPT THIS TODAY WE'RE
pTHE AVERAGE PAY A PERSON IN
CALIFORNIA'S PAYCHECK TO DO I
GET THAT RIGHT.
I BELIEVE IF I WAS FALLING MATH
CORRECTLY AYE AYE AYE TH I THINK
THAT IS CORRECT OKAY WELL THAT
THAT'S MY CONCERN I MEAN I THINK
THE IN THE DISCUSSION WE'VE BEEN
HAVING WE'RE PRETENDING THAT
THIS HAS NO COSTS.
BUT IT REALLY DOES EVERY
EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA WOULD BE
ASKED TO PAY -- SIXTY TWO
DOLLARS A YEAR OR WHEN DOING IT
THE OTHER WAY ABOUT NINETY
DOLLARS A YEAR TO PAY FOR THIS
AND THAT'S MY CONCERN BUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- FOR FOR CHECK
IN MY MATH ON THAT.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
OKAY THE MOTION IS HAS --
PROPOSE MODIFIED BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE.
IN ADOPTEES HOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO INCLUDE THE GOAL OF
PROVIDING A 90% WAGE REPLACEMENT
RATE [inaudible]
ASSEMBLY [inaudible] THREE ONE
SENATE WILL LET SENATOR MITCHELL
COME BACK IN AND ON SENATE. TO
TWO ONE TWO ONE TWO TWO START.
TO TO WE'LL COME BACK IN AND OUT
ON ON THAT -- ONE ITEM ISSUE
TWENTY ONE SALES AND USE TAX
CREDIT EXPANSION.
MENSTRUAL HYGIENE PRODUCTS IN
DIAPERS.
SO ON THIS SIDE OF THE
CONFERENCE COMPROMISES THE
SENATE ACTION ON THIS ITEM BUT
IT ALSO INCLUDES THE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR CERTAIN COUNTY
REALIGNMENT REVENUE THAT WE
BELIEVE WAS.
NECESSARY.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS.
THE QUESTIONS AS ASSEMBLY SO
THIS IS SENATE VERSION PUTS
REIMBURSEMENT CERTAIN COUNTY
REALIGNMENT [inaudible]
ASSEMBLY. FIVE OH SENATE
[inaudible] THREE ZERO ISSUE
TWENTY TWO THE I. T. C.
EXPANSION IN ADVANCE PAYMENTS WE
HAVE A CONFERENCE COMPROMISED
YES THERE'S A COMPROMISE HRE --
WITH PLACE HOLDER TAX CONFORMITY
AN E. I. T. C. P. B. L. AND T.
B. L. PACKAGE -- AND THIS SALAS
PENDING DISPOSITION OF A
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE ON THOSE
ITEMS AND WE'VE BEEN IN
DISCUSSIONS ON THE APPROPRIATE
VEHICLE FOR ALL OF THAT -- AND
THEN SECOND AT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED IS NOT INCLUDED --
FUNDING FOR THE ADVANCE PAYMENTS
OKAY THE IDC.
IN THIS ROOM.
TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO.
AS YOU ENVISION THIS ITEM RIGHT
NOW IS THIS INCLUDE THE
EXPANSION OF THE I. T. C..
TO CALIFORNIANS WITH I TUNES.
SO RIGHT NOW -- THAT IS NOT IN
THAT CONFERENCE COMPROMISE -- IN
THE DISCUSSIONS THAT WE'VE HAD
BUT IT ALL DEPENDS ON HOW THIS
VEHICLE MOVES FORWARD.
BUT YOU'RE ASKING FOR VOTE
TONIGHT.
ASKING FOR A VOTE ON THE GENERAL
REVENUE AN EITC PACKAGE YES.
NOT THE POLLS.
OKAY [inaudible]
AND DO WE WOULD REIMAGINE HAS TO
BE ONE BILL OR WILL IT BE WILL
BE SPLIT UP BETWEEN TWO SEPARATE
VISIT GIVE ME ONE TRAILER BILL
ARE GOING TO BE STATE TO
SEPARATE.
TRAILER BILLS SO THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN WORKING
WITH LEGISLATIVE FUNDS STAFF ON
THAT HI SO I DON'T HAVE A 1100%
SURE ANSWER TO ANY OF OUR STAFF.
I THINK WE HAVE TO GET BACK TO
YOU ON THAT OKAY.
DISTRIBUTOR OKAY SO TALK ABOUT
TX CONFORMITY.
ARE WE ADOPTING ALL THE
CONFORMITY ITEMS OR SOME OF THEM
ARE.
ALL OF THAT BOTH OF THOSE THAT
RESULT IN A POSITIVE AS WELL AS
A NEGATIVE FOR A FEW IMPACTS
[inaudible]
IDC
.
SO JUST TO CLARIFY.
ON T. MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THE I TEN ISSUE STILL ON THE
TABLE WE HAVEN'T.
FINALIZED DISCUSSION ON WHAT
COULD BE IN THE E. I. T. C.
PACKAGE.
YES SIR THAT THE UNDERSTANDING
OF THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISE IS
THE TAX AND FOR MANY REVENUES
BECAUSE THAT IS A PART OF THE
OVERALL BUDGET PACKAGE -- AND
THE E. I. T. C. SPENDING -- PART
OF THAT PACKAGE WHICH IS ONE
POINT ONE NINE BILLION -- AND
THEN THE FINAL DISPOSITION NO.
IS STILL BEING WORKED OUT WITH
THE LEGISLATURE.
YOUR BLOCK THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WE'VE ALREADY DISCUSSED.
THAT THE ATTACKS CONFORMITY WILL
BE DONE THROUGH A TRAILER BILL --
BUT YOU'RE SAYING THAT YOU'RE
GOING.
TO CONFORM TO EVERY ASPECT OF
THE FEDERAL.
TAX BILL NO SO WE ARE ONLY
CONFORMING TO ITEMS THAT WE
BELIEVE -- HI THERE REALLY
SIMPLIFY THE PROCESS IN A MATE
IN THIS IN A WAY THAT MAKES
SENSE FOR TAXPAYERS AND OR
CONSTITUTE GOOD PUBLIC POLICY
AND EDUCE ERRORS AND IMPROVE
POLICY IN CALIFORNIA SAID THERE
IS ALIST OF ITEMS -- WE PUT OUT
A DRAFT IN JANUARY AND AND
UPDATED IT AND WITH THE MAY
REVISION IT'S A PACKAGE THAT
RAISES ABOUT ONE POINT SEVEN TO
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
AND THEN ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING AFTER THAT BUT
IT IS A MIX -- AS MENTIONED WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE A MIX
OF ITEMS THAT REYES AND REDUCE
REVENUE.
SO GETTING BACK.
TO MR OPEN ORTIZ KIND OF GROUP
LOGIC THIS IS NOW ANOTHER TAX
INCREASE.
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO USE TO
OFFSET THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT INCREASE. TO REVIEW THIS
IS PART OF A PACKAGE YES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
AND SO THE MOTION IS AS STATED
WITH THE ASSEMBLY VOTE BEING.
THREE ZERO AND THE SENATE VOTE
BEING. THREE TWO TWO CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED KERRY'S [inaudible]
FILE -- THE ISSUE -- TWENTY THE
SENATE IF WE CAN GO BACK PLEASE
SO I CAN ADD ON ISSUE TWENTY
PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
THE SENATE VOTE IS.
ISSUE TWENTY I'M GOING BACK TO
PAY FAMILY LEAVE BECAUSE I WAS
OUT OF THE ROOM.
PAID FAMILY LEAVE ISSUE. TWENTY
THREE TO THE SENATE VOTED.
THREE TO TWO ISSUE.
TWENTY ONE SENATE VOTE THE SALES
AND USE TAX CREDIT EXPANSION FOR
MENTAL.
PRODUCTS AND DIAPERS
[inaudible]
SENATE VOTE [inaudible] THREE
ZERO MOVING ON TO ISSUE TWENTY
THREE MINISTRATION INDIVIDUAL
HEALTH MANDATE AN EXPANDED
SUBSIDIES THE MOTION IS THE
SENATE VERSION.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
PROVIDING ON ISSUE. TWENTY THREE
THREE TO ONE AT A SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TO TWO ISSUE TWENTY FOUR
DEBT LIABILITIES AND RESERVE
THERE IS A COMPROMISE IF I COULD
JUST CLARIFY VERY BRIEFLY MADAM
CHAIR ON THE ITEMS WE WERE%
DISCUSSING BEFORE AND I KNOW
THERE IS SOME -- BACK AND FORTH
REGARDING THE EITC IN THE TAX
CONFORMITY.
THE REASON THAT THEY'RE PART OF
THIS COMPROMISE EVEN THOUGH
THERE ARE OTHER VEHICLES MOVING
AS I THINK FOR THIS EXERCISE
WHAT WE'RE REALLY CLARIFYING IS
THE BUDGET ARCHITECTURE AND WHAT
REVENUES WE HAVE.
THATAFFECTS OUR PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT LEVEL -- AND WATER
SPENDING LEVELS ARE AT SO THAT'S
WHY IT'S IN THIS PACKAGE EVEN
THOUGH THAT THERE ARE THOSE
OTHER BUDGET -- OTHER VEHICLES
MOVING AS WELL THANK YOU YES.
AND THEN WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
SPECIFIC ISSUE ON DEBT
LIABILITIES RIVER RESERVES --
THERE COUPLE MOVING PARTS -- SO
JUST CLARIFY THE MAIN POINTS
FIRST IS THAT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED CONTINUES THAT NAY
REVISION PROPOSAL -- THAT
PROVIDING EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN RELEASE ON
PENSION PAYMENTS TO SCHOOLS OVER
THE NEXT TWO YEARS -- BEFORE AND
THAT MAY REGION PROPOSAL IT WAS
ALL ALLOCATED TO CAL STIRS NOW
WE HAVE OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS
SIX HUNDRED SIX MILLION DOLLARS
TO CAL STIRS AND TWO HUNDRED
FORTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS TO
THE CALPERS SCHOOL POOLS SO THE
OVERALL NUMBERS THE SAME -- BUT
IT'S SPLIT UP IN A DIFFERENT WAY
THE SAME GOES FOR THE TWO POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS -- AND THE
OUT YOUR PAYMENT -- SAME OVERALL
LEVEL BUT NOW ONE POINT SIX FOUR
BILLION IS THE CAL STIRS AND SIX
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS IS
TO THE CALPERS SCHOOL POOL.
WE CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN OUR
THREE BILLION DOLLARS -- PAYMENT
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE TO
CALPERS FOR THE STATE'S UNFUNDED
LIABILITY BUT INSTEAD OF DOING
ALL OF THAT IN THE CURRENT YEAR
WE DO TWO POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN THE CURRENT YEAR. TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN. TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND A HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO WE
CONTINUE OUR PROPOSITION TWO
PAYMENTS ON CAL STARS ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE.
AND WE APPROVE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL -- FOR THE PAYROLL DATA
AND CALPERS DEFERRALS HELPING TO
PAY OFF THE WALL OF DEATH.
AND THEN FINALLY WE APPROVED THE
SENATE ACTION REGARDING THE
TRAILER BILL FOR FUTURE P.
PAYMENTS OF CALPERS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT IS THE MOTION.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF FIVE
TWO ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE
TWO ZERO CONFERENCE COMPROMISED
KERRY'S.
ISSUE TWENTY FIVE MUSEUM FUNDING
IS A COMPROMISE.
YES IT IS A CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE -- THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL AND THIS
IS A APPROVAL OF FUNDING FOR THE
MUSEUM IS LISTED AND ITEMS
BEFORE YOU.
THANK YOU THAT IS THE MOTION AS
REFLECTED IN THE AGENDA.
WITH ASSEMBLY VODA. FIVE ZERO
SENATE VOTE OF FOUR ZERO MOVING
ON TO THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION
ON THE STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS
ISSUE TWENTY SIX PAY EQUITY
PROGRAM THE MOTION IS ASSEMBLY
VERSION WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE.
FIVE ZERO SENATE VOTE OF FIVE
ZERO ASSEMBLY VERSION KERRY'S
ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN AND IT
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
MINORITY IN UNDER REPRESENTED
VETERANS DIVISION THE MOTION IS
ASSEMBLY VERSION.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE UP FIVE
ZERO AND THE SENATE VERSION OF
FIVE ZERO ASSEMBLY VERSION
CARRIES.
UNDER NOT IN CONFERENCE THE
HOMELESS VETERAN FUNDING THERE'S
A CONFERENCE COMPROMISE YES THIS
IS FOR TWO POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ORANGE COUNTY'S
HOMELESS VETERANS AND THIS IS
DONE THROUGH THE UNITED TO END
HOMELESSNESS IS WELCOME HOME OF
C. PROGRAM.
THANK YOU THAT IS THE MOTION
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTO.
FIVE ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE
ZERO COMPROMISE CARE IS ORANGE
COUNTY VETERANS CEMETERY THERE'S
A CONFERENCE COMPROMISED
APPROVED TWENTY MILLION TO FUND%
THE VETERANS CEMETERY.
IN ORANGE COUNTY WHAT THE
ASSEMBLY VOTE UP. FIVE ZERO A
SENATE VOTE OF FIVE ZERO
COMPROMISED CAREY
.
THE YEAH MILTON IT ACTUALLY DOES.
THAT IS THAT'S THE ADVENTURE.
YES I JUST WANTED TO NOTE THAT
THIS IS A FABULOUS --
INVESTMENTS I JUST WOULD WITH I
JUST WISH THESE WERE.
AVAILABLE IN ALL AREAS OF STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
INDEED ISSUE.
TWENTY EIGHT UNDER LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FINANCING FUNDING FOR
DISASTER IMPACTED COUNTIES
THERE'S A CONFERENCE COMPROMISE
YES AND THIS COMPROMISE IS
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THESE COUNTIES.
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT ONE AND
A HALF MILLION FOR FLOOD RELIEF
IN THE CITY OF SEVASTOPOL. EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
PARADISE FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENT PREPARATION AND TWO
MILLION FOR BUTTE COUNTY FIRE
DEPARTMENT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE COMPROMISE MOTION.
IS ON THE TABLE WITH ASSEMBLY
VOTE. FIVE ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF
IF YOU TWENTY EIGHT FIVE ZERO
THE COMPROMISE KERRY'S.
ISSUE TWENTY NINE COUNTY FUNNY
RELATED TO GOLDEN STATE KILLERS
TRIAL THE SENATE VERSION IS THE
MOTION WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
FIVE ZERO SENATE VOTE OF FIVE
ZERO FOOD VERSION KERRY'S
UNDER THE NOT IN CONFERENCE
INVESTMENTS FOR LOCAL ENTITIES
THERE IS A COMPROMISE.
YES AND THESE ARE A NUMBER OF
ITEMS OF LOCAL INVESTMENTS --
THAT YOU CAN SEE ON THE LIST
BEFORE YOU.
THANK YOU THAT IS THE MOTION.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY MOTION OF VOTE
OF FIVE TO ZERO AND THE SENATE
VOTE OF THREE TWO TWO COPPER
MODERNIZE.
MOTION KERRY
.
LIKE TO RE OPEN -- THE VOTE.
ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE. TWENTY
THREE TWENTY NINE THE SENATE
VERSION IS THE MOTION AND THE
ASSEMBLY VOTE IS NOW
[inaudible] FOUR ONE PRESIDENT
DONALD.
MOVING ON TO INVESTMENT IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT HAN ARE NOT AND
CONFERENCE LISTS RUN.
THERE IS.
A SEVEN FIGURE PLEASE
[inaudible]
YES.
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT TO
COMBATING HOMELESSNESS I GOT
AHEAD OF MYSELF I APOLOGIZE IT'S
AT COMP PRINCE COMPROMISE IF
YOU'D WALK US THROUGH IT PLEASE.
SIR FOR THE HOMELESSNESS WONDER
NUMBER OF ITEMS IN A LIST OF
VERY BRIEFLY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN GRANTS TO LIMIT BEARS
FOR HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS WITH
PETS. FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT HOUSING NAVIGATORS FOR
YOUNG ADULTS WITH PRIORITY TO
FOSTER YOUTH -- ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FUND AND SENATORS
CARLSBAD OCEANSIDE INVEST A
QUARTER MILLION DOLLARS EACH FOR
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION
INTERVENTION SERVICES.
PLACEHOLDER TBL TO EXTEND THE
DEBATE THE DATE BY WHICH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
REHABILITATION MUST COMPLY WITH
HOUSING FIRST PRINCIPLES AND
REQUIRE THEM TO WORK BETTER WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO IDENTIFY WAYS TO
BETTER PROVIDE HOUSING SERVICES.
AND FINALLY FIVE POINT SIX TWO
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE LA
HOMELESS SERVICES AUTHORITIES
WORK IN SERVICE PROJECT AREA.
THREE THANK YOU THAT IS THE
MOTION MISTER MOORE Là.
THIS IS IN ADDITION TO THE ONE
BILLION YOU'VE ALREADY SET ASIDE.
YES SIR THAT THAT BROADER
HOUSING PACKAGE IS BEING WORKED
OUT AS WE AS WE SPEAK BUT YET
THESE ARE ADDITIONAL ITEMS THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION DID NOT HAVE
CONCERNS WITH.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU
THAT'S THE MOST MISTER OBERNOLTE.
MANAGER WHICH IS PUT OFF --
ITEMS ONE AND FIVE PLEASE.
HAPPY TO SERVE FOR THE FIRST
MOTION I WILL ENTERTAIN IS ITEM
ONE FIVE MILLION FOR GRANTS TO
LIMIT BEER YEARS. FOR HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS WITH PETS AARON ITEM
FIVE WHICH IS FIVE POINT SIX
MILLION FOR THE LOS ANGELES.
HOMELESS SERVICES AUTHORITIES
WORK IN SERVICE PROJECT AREA
THREE THAT IS THE MOTION WITH AN
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF THREE TO ONE
AND A SENATE VOTE OF FOUR TWO
ONE THE SECOND MOTION WILL
INCLUDE ITEMS [inaudible] TO
THREE AND FOR AS NOTED ON YOUR
AGENDA.
THE ASSEMBLY VOTE IS.
FIVE ZERO THE SENATE VOTE IS
[inaudible]
FIVE ZERO CONFERENCE.
PACKAGE CARE IS.
NEXT INVESTMENT IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT THERE IS A
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE YES
SERVICE INCLUDES A NUMBER OF
ITEMS -- FIRST EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS AGAIN WITH THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SUSPENSION AND
PLACEHOLDER TBL FOR HALF
PROVIDER HOUSING SUPPORT FOR
OLDER FOSTER YOUTH. ONE AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS FOR
VETERANS HOUSING PROJECT IN
CATHEDRAL CITY. THREE AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE MISSION
HERITAGE PLAZA AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND CIVIL RIGHTS
INSTITUTE. FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THE BOYS AND GIRLS
CLUBS OF LA HARBOR FOR LOAN
INTEREST FORGIVENESS ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE ORANGE COUNTY
HOUSING FINANCE TRUST USED FOR
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CITY OF SAN BERNADINO FOR
GENERAL PLAN AMENDMENTS FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE CITY OF
ONTARIO FOR A DOWNTOWN ON TERRIO
REVITALIZATION PROJECT WITH
SIXTY FIVE UNITS OF LOW TO
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING AS WELL
AS A BUSINESS TECHNOLOGY
INCUBATOR.
WITH A CENTRALLY LOCATED
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT CENTER AND
FINALLY THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO SAN FRANCISCO THIS IS
FOR A PLANNING GRANT TO BUILD
CAPACITY FOR COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT ON THE WEST SIDE OF
THAT CITY.
THAT IS THE MOTION ANY QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE THE ASSEMBLY VOTE
WILL BE. FIVE ZERO SENATE VOTE.
FIVE ZERO COMPROMISED HERE.
CONTINUING ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES NOT IN
CONFERENCE LIST OUR STREET
PARKING LOT THERE'S A COMPROMISE.
YES SIR THIS COMPROMISES FUNDING
FOR PROPOSED OUR STREET PARKING
LOT TEN POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND. THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS SERVICE REVOLVING FUND
AS WELL AS TBL FOR THE
ACQUISITION DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION OF THIS PARKING LOT.
THANK YOU THAT IS THE MOTION
WITH ASSEMBLY VODA FIVE ZERO A
SENATE VOTE UP. FOUR ZERO
COMPROMISED KERRY'S TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FOR THE STATE CAPITOL
ANNEX YES THIS IS A CHANGE THAT
ALLOWED FOR IN TBL THAT ALLOWED
MONEY TRANSFERRED FOR THE STATE
CAPITOL BUILDING AN EXACT PAST
THREE YEARS AGO. TO BE DEPOSITED
IN INTEREST BEARING ACCOUNTS
THANK YOU THAT IS THAT IS THE
MOTION WITH ASSEMBLY VOTE OF
FIVE ZERO A SENATE VOTE OF FIVE
ZERO DEFERRED MAINTENANCE THE
STATE WIDE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS THERE'S A COPPER MINES.
YES ALTERNATE OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE CHRIS THANK YOU FOR
CHRISLEY TO PARTNER FINANCE SO --
THE THERE'S A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR REDUCTION AND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE TO VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS -- AT THAT WAS PART
OF THE BUDGET ARCHITECTURE.
YEAH.
THE FACT.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT.
THERE'S ANOTHER HANG ON ONE
SECOND WHILE WE FOR ALL THAT YOU
HAVE.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS WHEN IT'S
NOT A CONFERENCE.
WE DID ACTUALLY BREAK A LOT OF
IF THIS LAST ONE THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
THE CABLES FROM THE COPIES FOR
EVERYBODY
[inaudible]
AND
JEFF OKAY JUST [inaudible]
LOS.
NO NO THAT'S THAT [inaudible]
FROM
[inaudible]
AND
THE BILL HAS.
SO WE ARE THIS IS GONNA POTS FOR
MINUTES WHILE WE CONTINUE TO GET.
MATERIALS FOR DISTRIBUTION SO
BEAR WITH US.
SO WHY DON'T WE GO AHEAD AND
CLOSE OUT THE TO EDUCATION ITEM.
WHILE WE'RE WAITING ON THE
ADDITIONAL MATERIALS.
SO WE'RE GOING BACK TO EDUCATION.
SOME WILL HAVE TO REMIND ME OF
THE ISSUE ITEMS PLEASE ONE I
BELIEVE A SEVENTEEN ISSUE
SEVENTEEN WHICH WAS THE ONE TIME
K. TWELVE PROP NINETY EIGHT
INVESTMENTS.
EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE RECEIVED A
COPY OF SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
LANGUAGE RELATING TO LOW
PERFORMING STUDENTS.
I BELIEVE THE ADMINISTRATION
BOTH HOUSES THE OLD CAUCUSES
HAVE REVIEWED THE LANGUAGE.
AND ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
ON THE ADDITIONAL SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE FOR LOW
PERFORMING STUDENTS MOTION.
SEEN NONE THE COPPER MINES AS
NOTED APPROVED FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND ONE TIME PROP 98%
DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
TO SUPPORT THE EDUCATION OF
HOMELESS YOUTH APPROVED FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND A ONE TIME PROP
NINETY EIGHT FOR THE BREAKFAST
AFTER THE BILL PROGRAM AND WE
ARE ADDING.
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
REGARDING LOW PERFORMING
STUDENTS.
THAT IS THE MOTION.
WITH AN ASSEMBLY VOTE -- THREE
ONE THREE THREE FOUR TO ONE AND
THE SENATE VOTE OF THREE TO TWO
THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISE PASSES.
THAT IS FILE ITEM ISSUE
SEVENTEEN THAT WE CAN NOW CLOSE
OUT.
THE NEXT OKAY THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATION ITEM.
WAS A NOT IN CONFERENCE ITEM.
IT'S LISTED AS VARIOUS EDUCATION
ADJUSTMENTS.
FINANCE CAN YOU SPEAK TO IT YES
SIR.
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE ON THREE
ITEMS THE FIRST IS ONE AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR THE RECEIPT A CHILD
DEVELOPMENT INSTITUTE.
SECOND IS FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
OLYMPICS NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THIRD IS A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE TIME FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS.
ALL RIGHT THAT IS THE MOTION.
ALL THOSE WHO LOST THEIR STUDENT
COUNCIL ELECTIONS I'M SURE WOULD
BE TRYING TO VOTE NOW BUT WE ARE
WATCHING YOU.
SO THE ASSEMBLY.
THE ASSEMBLY VOTE ON THIS MOTION --
I'M SORRY WE HAVE A QUESTION
THIRTY NIELSEN WELL YEAH
[inaudible]
WE'RE DISCOMFORT.
SO THIS IS MORE THAN THE LAST
MINUTE STUFF NOW IT MAY BE OF
MERIT BUT WE JUST GOT IT.
THE ADMINISTRATION DID NOT HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THIS LANGUAGE
THAT'S NOT AN ANSWER SIR.
SO WHY NOT DOING JUSTICE TO THE
MEMBERS TO MAKE IT THAT'LL LEARN
A DECISION ABOUT SOMETHING WE
JUST THROW IN OUR LAPS NINE
TWENTY AT NIGHT.
NUMBER. THIRTY NIELSEN IN ALL
FAIRNESS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- THESE DID NOT COME
FROM THEM -- THEY HAD NO ISSUE
WITH IT BUT I THINK THESE
PROBABLY REFLECT MEMBER ASK SIR.
THAT IS I RESPECT WHERE THEY
COME FROM IT'S A LITTLE LATE YOU
KNOW FIVE DAYS AGO I TOLD FOLKS
DON'T BE BRING ANYTHING MORE TO
ME.
IT'S OVER WITH.
AND THERE IS A TIME TO SAY FUNNY.
YES.
I AGREE WITH YOU SIR -- MR TANG.
JUST TO CLARIFY I THINK ON THESE
WERE BROUGHT A WHILE AGO AND
THIS WAS A CLERICAL ERROR SO WE
YOU KNOW AS AS WE KNOW WHEN WE
DO THESE BUDGETS VERY LAST
MINUTE THERE ARE.
A COUPLE THINGS THAT YOU FORGET
TO TYPE UP SO THEY ARE PART OF
THE AGREEMENT THEY JUST.
OR TYPE OF WITH THAT OF THE
ACTION IS BEFORE US.
OF THE MOTION HAS BEEN MADE AND
SO THE ASSEMBLY VOTE IS. FIVE
ZERO AM THE SENATE VOTE IS
[inaudible] THREE ZERO THE
COMPROMISE LANGUAGE KERRY'S.
SO WE'VE NOW CLOSED OUT ALL OF
OUR MEANING ITEMS.
IN EDUCATION AND WE'RE WAITING.
FOR ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE
[inaudible]
THE PRIME
.
COLLEAGUES WERE GOING BACK NICK
LIST ITEM UNDERSTATED
MINISTRATION AND GENERAL
GOVERNMENT.
IT IS A PART OF THE THREE WAY
AGREEMENT UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
IS THE VETERAN CAREER PATHWAYS.
THE COMP FRIENDS COMPROMISE.
IS TO APPROVE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND GENERAL FUND FOR
VETERANS CAREER ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM.
IN LOS ANGELES.
CAN YOU ELABORATE -- NO THIS WAS
JUST -- WILL -- WILL ONE TIME --
FUNDING THAT WAS A PART OF THE
BUDGET DEALS THANK YOU.
THIS OBERNOLTE.
IS LIKE TO ECHO THE SENTIMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUES FROM SACRAMENTO
AND ORANGE COUNTY'S DISAPPEAR
NICE THING TO HAVE EVERYWHERE IN
THE STATE.
DULY NOTED -- IF THE MOTION IS
CLEAR.
I'LL ASK THE ASSEMBLY TO VOTE
PLEASE.
VOTE FIVE TWO ZERO FROM THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE VOTE OF%
THREE TWO ZERO THE COMPROMISED
CARRIES ON THE VETERAN CAREER
PATHWAYS
.
TURNING TO AGAIN STATE
ADMINISTRATION GENERAL
GOVERNMENT.
THE FINAL ITEM.
OF STATE WIDE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS.
THE COP WITH COMPROMISE WAS TO
REDUCE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
OF TWO HUNDRED MILLION IN
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE TO ONE
HUNDRED MILLION IN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS.
FINANCE STATE POLICE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE OF THIS A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IS -- PRODUCTION
IS DISTRIBUTED BETWEEN NINETEEN
DEPARTMENTS [inaudible]
QUESTIONS [inaudible] THIRTY
NIELSEN.
YES.
SO A HUNDRED MILLION.
FROM OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IS
NOT NOW NECESSARY. ONE IS
CHANGED IN THE LAST WEEKS MONTHS
THAT HAVE.
ELIMINATED THE NEED TO FOR A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
EXPENDITURE. FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IS AT ALL TAKEN CARE
OF BY ITSELF.
ARE WE GETTING VOLUNTEERS TO DO
THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE SORT OF
BEING A LITTLE FACETIOUS HERE
BUT THIS IS A PRETTY.
SIGNIFICANT CUT IN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND WE HAVE BEEN
TRYING STARTED WITH JEFF
GOVERNOR BROWN TO GET CAUGHT UP.
ON DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PERFECTLY IN THE SACRAMENTO AREA
SO.
WHITE WHY SO LATE.
SO THE STATE'S DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEEDS EXCEED IN
ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION TWO
HUNDRED NINE DOLLARS SO IN ANY
GIVEN BUDGET THE QUESTION IS
WHAT CAN WE DO GIVEN.
THE OTHER PRIORITIES THAT WE
HAVE IN THE BUDGET AND SO THIS
BUDGET -- A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS STILL IS IN THE BUDGET
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE WE ALSO
HAVE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
ALLOCATIONS FOR UC AND CSU.
SO WE THINK GIVEN THE OTHER
PRIORITIES THAT WE HAVE TO
BALANCE IN THIS BUDGET HI THIS
IS STILL A MEANINGFUL INVESTMENT
IN WHAT WILL THIS. ONE HUNDRED
MILLION BE SPENT ON SO IT'S
STILL IS -- AS SAID THE SHEET IN
FRONT OF YOU SHOULD REFLECT --
IT MAY HAVE BEEN TAKEN DOWN FROM --
THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THE ALLOCATION THAT WE HAD THEIR
BACKS ALL THESE NINETEEN
PROJECTS I BELIEVE ARE ALL STILL
RECEIVING.
APPLICATIONS HI CHRIS CAN SPEAK
TO SOME OF THE DETAILS PLEASE.
YES SO WE OF THESE TO THESE TO
PUT NINETEEN DEPARTMENTS THAT
ARE BEING REDUCED THEY HAD MEANS
THAT EXCEEDED THE INITIAL
ALLOCATION THAT WE GAVE THEM SO --
THAT THEY WILL JUST NOT GET AS
FAR ON THEIR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE LIST WITH THIS MONEY
AS THEY WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE.
GOTTEN [inaudible]
MADAM CHAIR.
THE MORE LOT.
USUALLY YOU CUT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND A RECESSIONARY
PERIOD -- SO FOR DOING IT WHEN
WE HAVE A TWENTY ONE AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS SURPLUS.
THAT MEANS THAT THAT HUNDRED
MILLION WENT TO OTHER THINGS
[inaudible]
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE SAYING THAT
THOSE OTHER THINGS ARE MORE
IMPORTANT THAN [inaudible]
MAINTAINING OUR OUR FACILITIES
AND WE WE TEND TO HAVE A HABIT
AS GOVERNMENTS.
TO WAIT UNTIL THE LAST MINUTE.
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO PAY FOR
REPAIRS.
THEN WE DON'T ACT LIKE A
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION WERE
PUTTING MONEY ASIDE EVERY MONTH
EVERY YEAR. TO PREPARE FOR YOU
KNOW RESURFACING ROADS AND RE
DOING ALL THESE THINGS WE JUST
SORT OF WAKE UP AND ACT LIKE.
WELL NEXT WEEK IS CHRISTMAS AND
WHAT WE FIND THE MONEY TO PAY
FOR THE GIPSON YADA YADA.
AND SO.
MAYBE AS YOU.
ENJOY THIS NEW POSITION THEY
ALWAYS ARE LOOKING AT HOW DO WE
ACT MORE LIKE A HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION WHERE WERE.
PUTTING MONEY ASIDE
SYSTEMATICALLY.
SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE A SURPRISE
WHEN WE HAVE TO REPAIR A LEVY OR
A ROAD OR A OR WE WOULDN'T
WHATEVER IT MAY BE -- BUT THIS
ALSO KIND OF IS IS IS MAYBE.
AN INDICATOR OF A OF MAYBE THAT
THIS ISN'T THE BEST BUDGET.
IF WE HAVE TO MAKE THIS KIND OF
ADJUSTMENT.
IN A IN A GREAT YEAR.
SO I'M I'M I'M JUST A LITTLE
CONCERNED I JUST WANTED TO AT
LEAST SHARE THOSE CONCERNS YES.
ARE YOU TAKING FOR THE LONG TERM
IS CERTAINLY THE APPROACH OR HOW
YOU ADDRESS THESE ISSUES I WOULD
JUST SAY TWO THINGS ONE IS THAT --
IT IS A REDUCTION FROM OUR
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL
BUT I WOULDN'T CHARACTERIZE IT
AS A COP YOU KNOW IT'S STILL A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS -- THAT
IF THIS BUDGET IS ENACTED THAT
WILL GO TOWARD DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
AND THEN THE SECOND THING IS
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS ALSO
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN FOR HOW
WE'RE GOING TO BALANCE THESE
PRIORITIES AND THAT SHOULD BE
OUT THIS YEAR AS WELL
[inaudible]
YES [inaudible] SIX QUESTIONS.
THE MOTION IS -- THE COMPROMISE
AS STATED NEED GENDER WITHIN
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF THREE TO ONE
AND THE SENATE VOTE OF
THREE TWO
ONE COLLEGE WE'VE COME TO THE
POINT IN THE BUDGET CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE -- TIME WHERE IT IS
REQUIRED THAT WE ALL SIGN THE
BUDGET CONFERENCE REPORT.
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO ADJOURN UNTIL
WE DO THAT SO THEY ARE NOW GOING
TO BE DISTRIBUTED [inaudible]
EVERY MEMBER -- YOU NEED TO
RECALL SIGN EVERY SHEET OF THE
GREEN SHE TO START THE TOP
.
IT'S ONE SIGNATURE PER PAGE
RIGHT -- YEAH.
I THINK THE ASSEMBLY OF THE SIGN
UNDER YOUR CALLING.
THIS WEBER I THINK YOU SIGNED ON
TO MISTER TING [inaudible]
I JUST.
THANK YOU.
I THINK THAT THAT'S THE CORRECT
BECAUSE THIS IS A FAMILY.
ALL YOU KNOW WHAT NINETEEN
HAPPENED FINALLY.
LEFT THAT'S FUNNY.
YEAH YEAH YEAH ASSEMBLY SITES TO
THE RIGHT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SIGN ON THE
RIGHT HAND COLUMN SENATE MEMBERS
SIGN ON THE LEFT HAND COLUMN
[inaudible]
OKAY.
NO WE DON'T WE'VE DONE IT.
YES.
THANK YOU I'M GOING ON WITH THE
HOUSING BECAUSE THEY'RE STILL.
IT'S KIND MEETINGS [inaudible]
FIVE I LAWCENTER.
IT'S THREE ABOUT.
THREE THREE
TOTAL SEATS.
THERE'S THREE TOTAL SHE IT'S
THREE GREEN SHAKES EVERY MEMBER
SHOULD SIGN.
EACH SEAT.
IT'S SIMPLY A SIGN ON THE RIGHT
THE CITY DECIDED ON THE LEFT
CENTER NIELSEN YOU WANT TO BE
RECOGNIZED SIR.
MADAM CHAIR I WOULD LIKE TO AS
WE WRAP UP TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES THROUGH THE COURSE OF
THIS YEAR ON THIS BUDGET TRAVAIL.
WE STARTED THE YEAR WITH QUITE A
TRAGEDY IN.
PARADISE IN BUTTE COUNTY THERE
HAVE BEEN MANY BEFORE.
AND EVEN SOME SENSE.
BUT I THINK I SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
THE SETTLEMENT GALLAGHER SENATOR
TO BE DOLLY AND CONGRESSMAN I'M
OFTEN MYSELF THANKING ALL OF YOU
FOR YOUR SENSITIVITY. TO THE
PEOPLE UP THERE.
AND THE CHALLENGES THEY FACE.
IT TRULY HAS BEEN A DISASTER.
BUT SOMETHING I'LL TELL YOU THAT
WAS CHAU HEARTENING AND
ENCOURAGING TO MEET.
BACK DURING THE WORST MOMENTS OF
THE FIRE IN THAT TOWN WITH THE
FLAMES ALL AROUND US.
NATIONAL RESPOND OR IS FROM ALL
OVER AMERICA WHO WERE THERE
PRESENT.
CAME TO ME AND SAID SENATOR YOU
KNOW WE'VE BEEN TO DISASTERS ALL
OVER AMERICA KATRINA YOU NAME IT
WE'VE BEEN THERE.
BUT WE'VE NEVER SEEN THE
OUTPOURING OF SUPPORT THAT WE'VE
SEEN FOR THIS LITTLE TINY TOWN.
THAT SAYS SOMETHING TO THE
CHARACTER OF CALIFORNIA.
AND STUDENTS IN YOUR OWN SCHOOLS.
SONICALLY HAVE COME UP TO ME
SAYING WELL OUR MUSIC CLASS.
THE LITTLE FUNDRAISER. FOR
PARADISE.
AND FOR MáS.
WE WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
YOUR SYMPATHY AND SUPPORT FOR
THE PEOPLE OF THAT RIDGE UP
THERE ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
NIELSEN WE ARE ALL CALIFORNIANS
ALL OF US.
AS WE ARE WRAPPING UP AS MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE SIDE.
SIGN ON THE LEFT HAND COLUMN
FISCAL RIGHT UP UNDER MY NAME
CITY MORE LOT.
NO LITTLE MAKE ANY ASSUMPTIONS
IS FINE.
RIGHT HOLLY YEAH PLEASE YOUR
LUCKY DAY RIGHT I'M.
I WANT TO CONGRATULATE OUR NEW --
LA L. MISTER PECK AND ARE A NEW
REPRESENTED FROM FINANCE MISTER
THIS WANT TO FONG FOR YOU
SURVIVING YOUR FIRST BUDGET
CONGRATULATIONS TO BOTH OF YOU
GENTLEMEN
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SOMEBODY WILL WANT.
TO BE ON THE LINE
.
WITH THAT WE THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION AND THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED